Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Worüber wollen wir reden?
Wir sagen erst, was wir im Salon lesen.
Oh, warte, wir müssen erst sagen, dieser Podcast heute ist wieder pünktlich bei Spotify.
Ah ja.
Und der letzte war leider verspätet bei Spotify, weil die amerikanischen Tech-Pros, die auf Europa Einfluss haben, nicht wollten, dass unseren Zykligalbesprechung in der Welt, nein. Es gibt Umstellung, technische Umstellung. Das kann man ja mal kurz erklären für Leute, die es interessiert. Typischerweise ist ja Podcast ein RSS-Medium. Das heißt, ein über zwei Jahrzehnte altes Format proliferiert den Podcast in die Welt. Und das ist eigentlich gut, das ist ein offenes Standards. Jetzt haben aber unser Hoster und Spotify umgestellt auf irgendeinen API-technischen Zugang, keine Ahnung. Weil ja alles Video wird jetzt. Selbst Apple Podcasts überall ist jetzt dieses Video zu sehen. Und dabei kommt es natürlicherweise zu Fehlern. Ohne, dass diese Techie-Leute, die jetzt alles mit Code irgendwie zusammenklamüsern, noch mal daran denken, dass sie auch Fehler, Meldungen mitliefern sollten. Also im Sinne von, kam nicht bei Spotify an, warum? Ja, keine Ahnung. Und dann habe ich ein bisschen investigiert und habe sehr viel schneller herausgefunden als unser Hoster, dass es an der Länge der Show Notes liegt. Also wir haben einfach die 10.000 Zeichenmarke durchbrochen. Ich denke mir ja, ich hätte gerne die Freiheit, Leute, die vielleicht noch mal nachlesen wollen, worüber wir sprechen, sozusagen den Prompt abzunehmen, das wir einfach selber kurz zusammenfassen, warum es in Kapiteln geht. Aber das ist uns jetzt ein bisschen, also klar, 10.000 ist eine hohe Marke. Da kann man immer ein bisschen was schreiben, ja. So, genau. Außerdem der Hinweis, die Show Notes beim letzten Mal waren wirklich ganz schnell so mitveröffentlicht. Die habe ich ja im Nachhinein noch mal schön gemacht. Ja, deswegen ist leider, also wenn ihr das hier bei Spotify hört, Wolfgang und ich, wir haben zwei Stunden über den Enzyklika des Papstes gesprochen. Es könnte noch an euch vorbei gegangen sein. Denn bei Spotify wird ja dann ein Fünf-Tage-Alter-Podcast veröffentlicht, der nicht gleich ganz oben angezeigt wird. Da wir noch sehr häufig auf die Enzyklika zurückkommen, wie heute zum Beispiel auch, lohnt sich das vielleicht, das sich noch mal anzuhören.
Das sowieso, man hat auch eine höhere Sicherheit, wenn man uns abonniert hat, wenn man hinter die Bezahlschranke tritt, dass man immer alles mitbekommt. Das ist möglich über Steady, Apple oder Patreon. Steady empfehlen wir ja besonders. Und wir sprechen diese Folge, also im Salon, nach dem wir jetzt ein bisschen Vorgeplänkel machen und auf Wolfgang Kubicki eingehen, sprechen wir danach dann hinter der Paywall sehr ausführlich über Bücher, die neu erschienen sind. Wir sprechen über Gegenmacht, die Zivilgesellschaft schlägt zurück. Das neue Buch von Arne Semsrott. Wir hatten schon sein erstes Buch besprochen. Dies ist sein neues. Er zeigt also jetzt auf, was kann eigentlich zivilgesellschaftlich erfolgen gegen Rechtsruck und so weiter. Außerdem beschäftigen wir uns mit dem Thema Kunstfreiheit. Und ich muss es gleich spezifizieren. Wie ist es mit staatlich geförderter Kunst beziehungsweise Kunst, die in staatlichen Institutionen stattfindet? Welchen Einfluss darf der Staat darauf nehmen, auf das, was da ausgestellt wird, auf die Personen, die da ausstellen oder etwas performen oder lesen, was auch immer. Das ist ein Buch von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg, Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit. Ursprünglich ein Gutachten, das dann erweitert wurde. Keine leichte Lektüre, aber für uns doch sehr erhellend, dass wir das einmal uns klar machen können. Wo liegen eigentlich die Unterschiede und was ist zu beachten? Und ja, es sind so ein paar kleine Empfehlungen, liegen da auch drin. Wir werden sehen, was für uns daraus folgt als Debatte.
Es ist ja nicht nur ein Gutachten von Möllers, der dann den Weinberg fragte, ob man den Text mal in gemeinsamer Arbeit noch obskurer machen könnte. Also selten so dicht. Sondern dieser Text versteckt sich ja auch hinter einer Gutachtensprache, um noch mal klarzumachen, wie das Verhältnis aus Kunstfreiheit und antisemitischer Kunst ist. Wenn man sie als solche erkennt, darf dann gleich der Schulleiter die Aula rennen und sagen, nicht in meinem Haus oder etwa nicht und so, ja. Also das ist sozusagen doppelt obskur.
Ja, aber im guten Sinne, denn wir werden tatsächlich Wir müssen es wirklich entziffern. eine Klarheit gewinnen in diesen Debatten und sind dann gerüstet für die Debatten, die noch kommen werden, denn wir können sicher sein, eine Politisierung findet statt überall. Das heißt, diese Debatten werden zunehmen. Und da gibt es auch so die ein oder andere Nebensätze, die ordentlich reinhauen. Dann habe ich dabei ein Buch, das sich mit Marmor, Quecksilber, Nebel beschäftigt, woraus die Welt gemacht ist, heißt der Untertitel von Judith Schalansky. Ich spreche mit der Autorin auf der Lit Kolon am Sonntag, also am siebten, und habe dieses Buch jetzt gelesen. Bin sehr begeistert von diesen literarischen Essays. Außerdem habe ich einen sehr ungewöhnlichen, sehr guten Roman gelesen, was nicht gesagt werden kann, von David Szalay. Er ist ein Autor, der eine Prose des Minimalismus schreibt, weil das zu den Protagonisten passt. Wir haben einen Mann, Istvan, der am liebsten gar nicht spricht, oder wenn er spricht, dann sagt er OK, oder ja, oder OK. Wie geht man so durchs Leben? Und so erleben wir, wie jemand durch Unfälle und Zufälle aufsteigt in die Upper Class von London und auch wieder fällt. Und in diesem minimalistischen Stil ist das alles geschildert. Da ist nicht die große Innerlichkeit, aber da ist eine Innerlichkeit. Und manchmal zieht es einem wirklich den Boden weg beim Lesen. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon. Und außerdem gibt es einen Musiktipp. Ich habe mir auch noch angesehen, was Franziska Brantner, die Grünenvorsitzende, zum Thema Liberalismus zu sagen hat. Wir sprechen jetzt gleich über Liberalismus im Hinblick auf die FDP und was die Grünen da vorhaben. Nun ja.
OK, gut. Ich ergänze heute auch unsere beiden Bücher durch ein drittes Stefan Kühl, Führung und Gefolgschaft. Wir sprachen schon einige Male darüber. Diesmal müssen wir es uns vorstellen. Und ich kann hier schon mal sagen, für alle, die immer wieder fragen, welches Buch soll ich denn lesen zum Einstieg in irgendetwas, das ist wirklich das beste Soziologien-Lehrbuch der letzten Jahre. Außerdem, es gibt eine Firma, die heißt Every, die macht Software, und deren Chef hat einen Text darüber geschrieben, After Automation, wie es so ist in einer Firma, in der im Grunde alles automatisiert ist und seine E-Mails auch zu 95 Prozent nicht nur gelesen, sondern auch beantwortet werden in seinem Sinne von einer KI. Und der springt nun dem Papst bei. Allerdings 20 Tage bevor der Papst seinen Enzyklika veröffentlicht hat, ist wirklich auf dem Punkt dieses große Diktum, das ist nur Datenverarbeitung, wird hier richtig bestätigt. Und ich denke, wir werden die nächsten Jahre einen großen Konflikt haben zwischen Leuten, die dem Papstlage angehören. Also ich rechne uns beiden jetzt aber auch dazu. Und diesen Every Typen. Und alternativ dazu zum einen Jeffrey Hinton, der schon sagt, die Dinger leben und so weiter.
Das ist wer?
Das ist ja der große Google Mastermind Professor Nobelpreis zu diesem Thema, der allerdings flankiert wird in Deutschland neuerdings von Markus Gabriel. Der auch sagt, diese Dinger. Ich weiß nicht genau, Gabriel sagt, die leben und so, aber er geht sehr in diese Richtung. Und von daher hauen wir heute eine weitere Kerbe in das ist Datenverarbeitung mit sehr guten Argumentationen aus einem Techniktagebuch sozusagen. Und am Ende Sebastian Hubers, der Begriff der Narrative in Hegemonie. Also Charlie Kirk, ich hatte angekündigt, wir gehen nochmal durch die Hausarbeit durch, durch die Bachelorarbeit durch.
Wunderbar. Jetzt zuvor aber haben wir mitbekommen, dass Deutschland doch keinen Sitz im UN-Sicherheitsrat erhalten wird. Wir können daran sehen, die Außenpolitik von Friedrich Merz und Vorgänger wird ordentlich abgestraft. Vor allem auch die Außenpolitik in Bezug auf Gaza. Und jetzt auch natürlich das Duckmäusertum von Friedrich Merz gegenüber Donald Trump hat sich dann hier jetzt doch als schlecht herausgestellt, obwohl man ja der zweitgrößte Beitragszahler ist. Also hat man schon hier einen ordentlichen Affront kassiert und auch Baerbock ist ja international nicht gerade beliebt. Insofern rächt sich das jetzt alles, was so an Hybris in den letzten Jahren und bis in die Gegenwart zu beobachten ist.
Ja, wir koppeln das ja gleich mit oder du koppelst es mit Kubicki. Derzeit ist ja wirklich total schräg. Wir haben ja schon über den Sadismus geschrieben. Also dass die AfD nicht wie die NSDAP uns echt Wahlgeschenke macht, sondern uns die ganze Zeit quält. Und so einige Vorzeichen scheinen echt verdreht zu sein, weil Annalena Baerbock ist in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit nicht sehr beliebt. International, du hast gesagt, nicht sehr beliebt. Sie ist in den Apparaten auch nicht sehr beliebt, weil sie ja die ganzen Leute rausgeholt hat. Sie ist eigentlich nirgendwo beliebt. Und ich stelle mir wirklich die Frage, wenn die Demokratie wirklich so funktionieren sollte, wie es uns immer verkauft wird. Sie spült nur die Besten nach oben. Man hat eine echte Bewährungsprobe. Man muss schon so 40, 50 Millionen Leute von sich überzeugen. Und andauernd sehen wir Merz hier, Kubicki da, Annalena Baerbock da, Wadepool, bei dem wirklich der Scherz ist. Für den Fall, dass er jetzt einfach geht. Dann geht er, wie er gekommen ist, aus heiterem Himmel. Niemand kennt ihn. Einfach so ein 60-jähriger Mann, der plötzlich auf der Bühne steht, ein bisschen Außenpolitik spielt, die ganze Zeit immer nur denselben Scheiß labert. Ja, also wir stehen immer noch an deren Seite, die stehen immer noch an unserer Seite. Er spricht die ganze Zeit im Namen von irgendwem, aber wir wissen, der redet nicht mal mit den Leuten über dir da und für die er da angeblich spricht. Also wirklich aus Heid um Himmel kommt er so, ist irgendwie Außenminister, geht wieder weg. Es ist also so eine Spurelosigkeit, die dahinter lassen wird, ist wirklich sagenhaft. Also irgendwas ist mit dieser Demokratie wirklich ganz schief gerade.
Ich will aber Wolfgang Kubicki da ausnehmen, aus dieser Reihe, die du jetzt gerade aufgetan hast und will jemand anderes in diese Reihe stellen, nämlich Marie-Agnes Strack Zimmermann. Wir haben das mitbekommen. Es gab eigentlich die Alleinkandidatur von Wolfgang Kubicki. Dann aber plötzlich, ganz überraschend, eine einstündige Rede war auch schon vorbereitet oder nicht vorbereitet von Marie-Agnes Strack Zimmermann, dass sie jetzt als Gegenkandidatin antritt.
Eine Stunde hat sie geredet.
Ich glaube, oder 45 Minuten. Sie hat lange geredet. Ich habe sie mir nicht angehört, bin ja nicht verrückt. Allerdings interessant war ja, dass sie also da auftritt und sagt, ich bin jetzt die Gegenkandidatin, hat dann 40 Prozent der Stimmen, 60 Prozent der Stimmen bei Wolfgang Kubicki. Meine Einschätzung dieser Geschichte ist die folgende, dass sich Kubicki durchgesetzt hat, ist für die FDP gut. Ist für die FDP gut. Also mich verbindet mit Wolfgang Kubicki wirklich nur der Vorname. Seitdem er auch anfängt, dann doch nicht für Free Speech zu sein, sondern auch versucht Klagen zu führen gegen El Hotso oder so, ist er bei mir unten durch. Ich fand ihn vorher einfach auch immer noch lustig und dachte, naja gut, wenn er so redet, wie der Mund ihm gewachsen ist, gut. Aber wenn er dann andere versucht einzuhägen, dann finde ich das nicht mehr gut, kann das nicht mehr mittragen. Aber ich will jetzt gar nicht bewerten, wie ist Wolfgang Kubicki, was könnte der für mich bedeuten? Denn das spielt alles gar keine Rolle. Ich werde die FDP niemals wählen. Von daher brauche ich mich darum nicht zu kümmern. Ich will aber sagen, die Wahl für Kubicki ist gut für die FDP. Wenn die FDP eine Chance hat, dann nur mit jemanden wie Wolfgang Kubicki, jedenfalls auf keinen Fall mit jemanden wie Marie-Argne Strack Zimmermann. Und das wollen wir uns ein bisschen klar machen, nämlich in der Kommunikation von Wolfgang Kubicki. Er ist also nach diesem doch sehr nervenaufreibenden Parteitag angetreten, um den Tagesthema auch noch ein Interview zu geben. Ist zugeschaltet.
Muss man dazu sagen, dass es sehr heiß war. Ich kenne einen Clip, den nur der Koch gemacht hat.
Ja.
Es war ja ein sehr heißer langer Tag für den alten Mann. Ja.
Ja, man schwitzt ein bisschen und ist auch sonst vielleicht schon etwas derangiert. Kann alles sein. Jessi Wellmer interviewt Wolfgang Kubicki.
Das Ergebnis heute gerundet, so 60 zu 40. Äußerst knapp für sie. Braucht man, um eine Partei zu retten, nicht eine Partei, die etwas mehr hinter einem steht?
60 zu 40 ist doch ein gutes Ergebnis und ich hatte nicht das Gefühl heute im Parteitag, dass die Partei nicht hinter mir steht. Darum geht es gar nicht. Die Freien Demokraten sind ein lustiges Völkchen, streitbar, selbstbewusst und auch professionell genug, mit solchen Situationen umgehen zu können. Wettbewerb schadet der Partei nicht, sondern stärkt die Partei.
So, genau mal gegen diesen üblichen Konsens. Ja, wir müssen jetzt sehen, dass wir alle in einem Boot sitzen. Wir müssen alle einen, wir wollen keine Konflikte. Nein, der Konflikt ist in der Partei. Wettbewerb, das ist doch eh so ein FDP-Ding. Das machen wir jetzt hier. Egal. Finde ich genau die richtige Ansage. Also das muss man jetzt von links lernen. Ja, also das ist jetzt zuhören und für die eigene Sache.
Angenommen, das wäre jetzt erfolgreich gewesen für Arknestrakz Zimmermann. Hätten wir dann Wolfgang Kubicki auch so reden gehört?
Natürlich nicht.
Eben.
Ja, das ist ja vollkommen klar. Nur, dass man jetzt nicht sagt, ja, wir müssen jetzt... Also jeder SPD-Politiker, der diese Frage gestellt bekommen hätte, nach einem solchen Wahlergebnis, er hätte jetzt gesagt, ja, und ich will mich auch am nächsten Morgen mit der anderen Seite zusammensetzen, denn am Ende geht es ja um unser Land und wir müssen gemeinsam bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Und genau jeder Grüne hätte das so gesagt, ich höre schon so einen Habekton, wie er das uns erzählt. Nein, es ist genau die richtige Haltung, die dann noch verstärkt wird. Wirklich, Sternstunde Wolfgang Kubicki.
Ja, also der Applaus für Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann und ihre Rede hat schon verdeutlicht, dass da auch möglicherweise Lager sind in der Partei. Sie polarisieren ja außerhalb der FDP, aber wie viele zumindest den Eindruck gewinnen konnten, auch innerhalb der FDP. Wie wollen Sie denn Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann und Ihre 40% Anhängerschaft noch mehr für sich gewinnen?
Gar nicht. Das ist mal eine Ansage.
Ich bin mal weiter.
Interessiert mich nicht. Also wir hören noch mal.
Anne Strack-Zimmermann und Ihre 40% Anhängerschaft noch mehr für sich gewinnen?
Gar nicht, weil meine Aufgabe nicht darin besteht, irgendjemand zu gewinnen, sondern dazu beizutragen, dass die Freien Demokraten von den Wählerinnen und Wählern wieder ernst genommen werden. Es ist völlig egal, wie wir uns nach Ihnen selbst empfinden, ob wir lustig oder traurig sind. Entscheidend ist, wir brauchen gute Ergebnisse bei Wahlen. Darum werde ich mich kümmern.
Also, Wolfgang Kubicki weiß, dass diese Parteien, gerade so klein wie die FDP und so, mittlerweile medial nur noch reduziert werden auf ihren Chef. Das gilt insbesondere für die FDP nach Christian Lindner. Dass er jetzt sagt, ich möchte diese Partei nach außen wenden, in der Gesellschaft wieder eine Rolle spielen, was aber bedeutet, die Partei bin ich, ist auf jeden Fall nicht ein zu unterstützender Satz im Verhältnis zu dem davor, wo es einfach heißt, naja, es gibt halt, deswegen macht man ja eine Wahl, mehrere Kandidaten und am Ende 50 plus.
Die Überlegung muss doch folgende sein. Wer überhaupt ist noch fälsch und willens, die FDP zu wählen? Wenn man die Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann-Position haben möchte, dann gibt es dafür ein Angebot, das liegt bei den Grünen oder zum Teilen bei der CDU. Wenn man diesen Essay, den wir dich heute vorstellen, von Franziska Brantner über Liberalismus diest, dann würde ich sagen, zu 99 Prozent wird Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann das genauso sehen. Wenn die FDP sich in eine grüne Partei verwandeln will, also in die grüne Realus, dann braucht es die FDP ja gar nicht. Es gibt ja schon ein Angebot, nämlich die Grünen. Dass Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann jetzt so beliebt ist in der eigenen Partei, beziehungsweise dass man sagte wohl, ich will den Kubicki nicht, deswegen wähle ich jetzt mal sie, um den Kubicki eins auszuwischen, heißt ja überhaupt nichts über die Beliebtheit von Strack-Zimmermann in der Bevölkerung. Also wenn irgendjemand die FDP zu mehr als fünf Prozent bringen kann, dann ist das ein Typ wie Kubicki oder Kubicki selbst. Aber das ist garantiert nicht eine Strack-Zimmermann. Und das ist ja genau das Problem, was wir bei allen Parteien jetzt aus der Mitte vorfinden. Du hast es ja gerade angesprochen. Baerbock nicht beliebt, trotzdem bekommt sie die Posten. Wir sehen das bei der SPD. Also du glaubst doch nicht, dass irgendjemand, wenn man einfach so frei wählen würde, auf die Idee gekommen wäre, Lars Klingweil als Vorsitzenden zu nehmen. Da würden einem ja hundert andere Namen einfallen. Man würde auch bei der CDU, würde man nicht sagen, Friedrich Merz, der gefällt mir so gut. Da würden andere Kandidaten anstehen. Und genau deshalb ist es die richtige Haltung von Kubicki zu sagen, ja gut, das mag ja sein, dass die das in der Partei so sehen. Das ist eben die Berliner Blase, unser partei-internen Kram. Das hat aber nichts mit dem da draußen zu tun. Und das ist in meinen Augen ein wirkliches Verständnis von populistischer Politik, die ich inhaltlich, um das nochmal zu sagen, vollkommen ablehne.
Ich mache jetzt ein Verweis auf später. Denn wenn wir nachher gegenmacht von Arne lesen, kommen wir an einigen Stellen drauf zurück, um zu sagen, klar, die FDP verhält sich jetzt so und so und im Verhältnis oder im Unterschied dazu macht die SPD die CDU und so folgendes. Ich sage jetzt, in dieser Demokratie, über die ich mich eben schon gewundert habe, sind alle Parteien kaputt. Und Arne beschreibt Situationen, in denen man überhaupt nur an Aufbruch und etwas Neues denkt, wenn man den Laden intern auf eine Basis gestellt hat, dass es sich überhaupt lohnt, das zu expandieren. Wir beschreiben aber jetzt, schon ganz zynisch und völlig zurecht, diese Parteien als completo verloren.
Ja, das ist eine zynische Analyse von mir.
Also, dass die Aussage einfach lautet, damit Kubicki gesellschaftlich für die FDP überhaupt noch eine Rolle spielen kann, muss er im Grunde die ganze Partei als Müllhaufen hinter sich lassen und am besten schon mal einen Container werfen. Das sagt wirklich einiges über unseren aktuellen Zustand der Politik.
Das sagt sehr viel aus. Und dennoch ist es, glaube ich, so interessant, dass wir es hier einmal erleben, auch in der Art, wie mit den Journalisten gesprochen wird. Denn Velma fragt jetzt zur AfD. Ich halte diese Position von Kubicki auch für falsch. In Bezug zur Brandmauer oder so. Aber auch die Kommunikation, die einfach jetzt von Kubicki zurückkommt, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Weil alle sofort sonst, wenn sie irgendwas gefragt werden in dieser Hinsicht oder in anderer, ja wollen sie dann wirklich enteignen oder sehen sie dann nicht, dass diese Gaza-Position schwierig ist, dann sind alle sofort wieder, ah ja, da muss ich zurückruten, nicht, dass irgendwas nachher in der Bildzeitung oder so steht. Da muss ja, die Linke hat ja auch inzwischen eine solche Angst, Interviews zu geben, dass man auch nur noch beschwichtigend ist. Nee, Kubicki nicht.
Es gibt ja durchaus Punkte, über die auch relativ hart diskutiert wird. Wenn man Marie-Agnieszka Zimmermann heute zugehört hat, dann ist es auch die Brandmauer-Debatte. Das wurde heute deutlich. Sie halten die Debatte für Grund falsch. Und dabei bleiben sie auch, obwohl das viele in der FDP möglicherweise anders sehen?
Ja, ich sehe nicht, dass es viele in der FDP anders sehen. Brandmauer ist für Liberale kein Kriterium. Wir weichen keine Diskussionen aus und wir haben einständige Überlegungen, die wir präsentieren. Uns ist völlig egal, ob CDU zustimmen oder SPD zustimmende, was auch immer. Was wären wir für eine Partei, wenn wir unsere Überzeugungen und unsere Äußerungen davon abhängig machen würden, wer sonst noch im politischen Spektrum begeistert oder bin ich begeistert ist. Man kann sich darauf verlassen, die Freien Demokraten sind der größte Antipode der AfD. Und ich hasse es langsam, dass kein Interview stattfindet, ohne dass über die AfD geredet wird. Wir machen sie alle größer, als sie wirklich ist. Sie ist nicht das Zentrum des Universums.
Auch einfach mal zu artikulieren. Ich will jetzt mal keine Frage zur AfD. Ist gar nicht so schlecht. Jetzt wirklich diese völlig egal Haltung.
Für die FDP geht es darum, eine politische Marktlücke zu besetzen, einen Markenkern zu definieren. Wie groß ist das Risiko, dass der vor allem aus ihren rustikalen Sprüchen besteht?
Es kann bewerten, wer weh. Tagesthemen genauso wie Tagesschau oder was auch immer entscheidend ist, auf wer die Menschen erreichen in diesem Land. Und da traue ich der Partei sehr viel zu. Alles Weitere werden wir sehen.
Ja, also.
Das ist doch die richtige Kommunikation. Verschrecken Sie mit Ihrer Politik gegen die Vermieter nicht die Mitte der Bevölkerung? Das ist so eine typische Frage, die jetzt Heidi Reichneck gestellt bekommt. Dann wird sie versuchen, zu beschwichtigen. Ist mir egal, was die Tagesthemen denken, machen wir jetzt einfach so.
Also zur Brandmauer, die FDP hat ja die Brandmauer eingerissen. Auch hier wieder Arne Semsrott, das Buch beginnt mit viel schlimmer als wenn die AfD AfD-Politik macht ist, wenn die Parteien, die angeblich mit der AfD-Politik machen.
Definitiv, ich stimme da auch Semsrott zu.
Die FDP ist also da viel schlimmer als die AfD.
Ja, ich stimme Semsrott ja da auch völlig zu. Mir geht es ja auch nicht, das inhaltlich gut zu finden.
Zweitens zu diesem alles egal und so weiter. Also wir dürfen nicht übersehen, dass Kubicki, du betont es jetzt, ihm ist das alles egal und das stimmt. Nur, er ist halt jetzt die One-Man-Show FDP. Es gibt hinter Kubicki keine FDP. Wir werden niemanden sehen. Niemanden.
Das wird sich zeigen, ob sich da dann andere herausbilden.
Ja, also wird sich zeigen, aber ich kann eine Prognose abgeben.
Bei der SPD wäre ja, also nehmen wir mal die SPD, die ja in einer ähnlich tiefen Krise steckt. Wenn wir jetzt die SPD nehmen und wissen, was jetzt passieren wird, nehmen wir mal an, Lars Klingbeier geht, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ja. Dann wissen wir, dann kommt als nächstes jemand, der Klüssendorf ist und fast genauso ist wie Lars Klingbeier.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber das passiert ja jetzt zumindest in den letzten 15 Jahren SPD immer. Einmal kurz Martin Schulz. Dann hat man gemerkt, Martin Schulz, bitte gar keine inhaltlichen Positionen, denn wir wollen einfach nur einen Hype. Und dann stellt sie sich heraus, dass so ohne Inhalt geht nicht. Das heißt, die SPD hat ja jetzt immer auf Köpfe gesetzt, die alles nur schlimmer gemacht haben, weil sie nur Seeheimer Kreis, Pragmatiker und irgendwas. Und auf keinen Fall jetzt jemand wie Kevin Kühnert, der eins von Sozialismus sprach, wurde dann auch zu dem angepasstesten Politiker der Welt. Das heißt, das ist ja alles immer total gescheitert, weil man immer sagt, wir müssen alle einigen. Ich muss auch danach noch zum Spargel essen mit dem und dem. Und einfach zu sagen, ne, wir haben jetzt bei der SPD aus der Mitte heraus irgendeine Figur, die polarisiert und die schert sich jetzt nicht darum, ob der Seeheimer Kreis gerne noch 5.000 Panzer nach Israel schicken will. Das ist egal, machen wir nicht. Das wäre genau die richtige Position zu sagen, wir drehen jetzt frei, das ist die einzige Chance überhaupt noch. Und das nimmt man aber nicht im Kauf, so verwaltet man den Abstieg immer ganz staatstragend und langweilig.
Auch hier wieder ein kurzer Verweis auf Arne Semsrott. Man hüte sich in diesen Zeiten jetzt vor Kontinuitätsunterstellung, denn nichts läuft gerade kontinuierlich weiter außer zwei Sachen, das Fernsehprogramm und wie die SPD ihre Leute rekrutiert. Nur ich sehe da auch, Lars Klingball ist der Letzte. Also da ist einfach niemand anderes mehr, der diese Linie so fortführt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, man ist ja erstaunt.
In der SPD hassen alle Lars Klingball.
Ja, ja, aber ich kann dir ja über ganz viele Vorsitzende, die die SPD schon hatte, sagen, dass die nicht beliebt waren und trotzdem hat man es immer weitergeführt.
Und deswegen sage ich ja jetzt keine Kontinuitätsformutung.
Natürlich ist die Performance von Kubekinech immer einwandfrei, aber vielleicht authentisch. Jetzt kommt der Clip, den du kennst und den müssen wir natürlich spielen. Also abschließende Frage, wie bringt man jetzt die FDP nach vorne mit einer kleinen Sprache vielleicht?
Wie soll der gelingen? Wie sieht die Marktlücke konkret aus? Wie definieren Sie sie, in die Sie reinwollen, mit der Sie erfolgreich sein wollen? Welches Konzept?
Ja, also wir müssen einfach nur eine klare Position beziehen und eine klare Sprache sprechen, anders als in der Vergangenheit. Wir sind ja von vielen Menschen gar nicht mehr identifiziert worden. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass bis vor fünf Wochen die Freien Demokraten bei den meisten Meinungsumfragen gar nicht mehr ausgewiesen worden sind, weil noch unser Sonstiges abgestapelt worden sind.
Einfach klare Sprache. Ja, sehr zum Wohle.
Das könnte man zum Einbürgerungstest.
Ob man das nachsprechen kann oder verstehen kann.
Ob man das aufschreiben kann. Wer das transkribieren kann, sofort einbürgern. Also ich sehe hier wirklich Hoffnungslosigkeit.
Aber wenigstens wird es lustig.
Deutschland ist wirklich das allerletzte Land. Schauen wir mal nach England. Die BBC hat jetzt eine ganze Newsnight-Sendung, eine komplette Sendung, sich selbst zensiert, weil sie in irgendeinem Halbsatz Farage falsch zitiert haben. So mächtig ist der mittlerweile mit seinem Reformding. Der Typ hat vor zehn Jahren Brexit verbrockt. Dann hat er dazu geführt, oder die immer wieder provoziert, dass sich das keiner eingesteht. Man hat also ganz viele Ausreden mit, da war halt Corona, dann war halt Ukraine, Kriegmann, was auch immer. Dass man sich das wirklich selber herbeizugefügt hat, dass einfach ein Drittel des Landes komplett in die absolute Armut gerutscht sind. Wartelisten bei NHS, sieben Monate und der ganze Scheiße. Also Parteiensystem einmal komplett, Tories gibt es gar nicht mehr, Labour sehen wir ja, was da los ist und so. Selbst Tony Blair sagt es irgendwie, es geht so nicht weiter. Und die einzige Hoffnung ist, Reform irgendwie mit Verrag, der soll jetzt nächster Ministerpräsident werden. So, Frankreich. Also Macron war derjenige, der eine neue Partei erfunden hat. Und schon wieder abgemeldet. Ja, so, das in Deutschland überhaupt noch FDP. Wie die haben wir nicht vor 15 Jahren aussortiert? Also die sind schon mal rausgeflogen, haben wir die wieder zugelassen. Was ist denn das für ein Quatscher? Ja, CDU. Also ihr habt noch christlich-konservative Parteien, von denen wir jetzt durch die Entzüglichkeit gesehen haben, wie christlich die sind.
Gar nicht.
Es ist wirklich grotesk. Ja, so, dass wir es überhaupt so weit geschafft haben, das ist erstaunlich, dass in der Frankfurt Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung 25 Jahre auf den Gründungsmoment 2001 zurückgeblickt werden kann. Und man feststellt, wow, also Jörg Thoma hat noch mal die erste Ausgabe der Sonntagszeitung gelesen und hat sich gefragt, welche Welt ist das? Hier ist ja nichts wie 2001 außer die Tagesthemen. Ja, so, dass wir noch Tagesthemen haben und Kubicki da noch in dem, so haben wir es seit 50 Jahren gemacht, Gesprächen zugeschaltet ist, um als 74-Jähriger noch mal die Hoffnung der Partei zu beschreiben.
Und auch dem Wein noch zuspricht, ganz wie früher, der alten Bundesrepublik.
Das ist einfach groteske Welt, in der wir hier leben.
Es ist grotesk, ja.
Es ist unglaublich.
Das heißt, mit diesem kleinen Anlauf gehen wir in den Salon, sprechen wie gesagt über Gegenmacht von Arne Semsrott. Ich will dich auch fragen, was traust du eigentlich der Zivilgesellschaft zu? Ich hier vielleicht noch ein bisschen weniger als Arne Semsrott. Darüber müssen wir diskutieren. Wir sprechen über die öffentliche Kunstfreiheit von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Die Frage also, kann der Staat eingreifen, wenn er zum Beispiel meint, dass ein Kunstwerk antisemitisch ist? Wie ist das überhaupt? Wie frei ist die Kunst, wenn sie staatlich gefördert ist? Weiter dann ein Roman, der wirklich unglaublich beeindruckend ist, der so minimalistisch ist und eine so interessante, sehr einsame Figur spielt. Der ist 400 Seiten lang, aber trotzdem ist er sehr, sehr sparsam mit den Worten. So ist es auch gesetzt, ja, sehr sparsam in den Dialogen. Literarische Essays von Judith Schalansky, dann Musik und wir gucken uns mal an, wie jetzt eigentlich Franziska Brantner so dieses Strackzimmermann-Lager für sich gewinnen will. Und was heißt das eigentlich für die Grünen?
Politiker, die Laufkundschaft einfangen wollen, ne? Ja. Also Gegenmacht von Arne Semsrott wird gleich ein großer Kontrapunkt sein. Zum Thema Menschenfischerei.
Dann auf in den Salon.
Bis gleich.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Zeigst du zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement?
Ja.
Also bist du auch bei den Ultras?
Nebenanverband.
Was hat es damit auf sich? Also Arne Semsrott geht die große Liste durch und sagt, völlig unterschätzt wird der Ultra als organisierter Fußballfan. Und als ich das so las, dachte ich, ja das stimmt, weil wenn einer mit dem Staat die ganze Zeit konfrontiert ist und sauer auf ihn und andauernd Ideen hätte, wie man es eigentlich besser macht, aber immer zurückgehalten wird, dann ist das ja der Fußballultra.
Ja, da gibt es ja verschiedene politische Strömungen und das ist definitiv so. Allerdings sind die Ultras ja nur ein Teil der Zivilgesellschaft. Wir erfahren von sehr vielen NGOs, von Vereinen, von Bürgerinitiativen. Nachdem er ja in seinem ersten Buch Machtübernahme schilderte, wie könnte es konkret aussehen, wenn die AfD regiert, ist dieses Buch jetzt eines, das sich erst mal dagegenstellt zu sagen, das wird ja ohnehin kommen, sondern wir haben durchaus Handlung, Spielraum. Ja, wir haben eine Gegenmacht. Deshalb auch dieser kämpferische Titel, Die Zivilgesellschaft schlägt zurück. Dabei ist auffallend, dass Arne Semsrott gleich auf der ersten Seite auf sein Buch eingeht, aber feststellen muss, es ist ja alles viel schlimmer geworden, beziehungsweise ja, wie verquer ist das eigentlich? Er beginnt damit zu sagen, dass wir verloren haben. Und auf gewisse Weise ist das eine gute Nachricht, denn jetzt können wir so handeln, als hätten wir nichts mehr zu verlieren. Innerhalb kürzester Zeit sind in den vergangenen Jahren lange geglaubte Gewissheiten geplatzt. Frieden, ein stabiles Klima und Demokratie sind nicht mehr selbstverständlich. Und es zeigt sich, viel gefährlicher als eine AfD in der Opposition sind aktuell Regierungsparteien, die AfD-Forderungen umsetzen. Ob menschenfeindliche Abschiebungen zu Terrorregimen wie den Taliban, europarechtswidrige Zurückweisungen an den deutschen Grenzen, eine rückwärtsgewandte Wirtschaftspolitik oder der fossile Klima-Rollback in der Bundesregierung. Die Rechtsextremisten können genüsslich zuschauen, wie ihre Agenda die Bundespolitik bestimmt. Nicht nur Deutschland, auch andere Staaten befinden sich in einer Phase der autoritären Wende.
Genau.
Damit ist also deutlich gemacht, dieses Buch ist jetzt nicht nur eines, das sagen wir, wir müssen mal schauen, wie wir gegen die AfD kämpfen müssen, sondern die, die bekämpft werden müssen, sitzen in der Regierung und die sind nicht von der AfD, machen aber eine solche Politik.
Also das Argument, also das, was du jetzt vorgelesen hast, ist ja höheren hier bekannt, weil du das ja auch immer wieder betontest. Und deswegen kann man hier nochmal in die Worte, also Arne Semsrott sagt wirklich, viel gefährlicher ist. Er wird es ja später entfalten mit so Mehrheitsunterstellungen. Was bedeutet eigentlich dieses Mitläufertum und so? Das kennen wir ja auch.
Und die Umfragen.
Ja, die Umfragen, genau. Das hat ja, also genau die Demoskopie, der Demoskopie-Populismus. Ich will nur wieder auf den Papst verweisen. Der hat uns ja auch darauf hingewiesen, dass Hannah Arendt uns lehrte, viel gefährlicher als der Demagoge und Brandstifter ist, derjenige, der es einfach geschehen lässt. Schon allein, weil er Masse ist. Also genau dieses Argument kehrt hier wieder. Man darf jetzt also nicht einfach über diesen Bucheinstieg hinweggehen und sagen, wenn Tilo Banaschak fragt, was ist, wenn ein AfD-Minister der Verteidigung dann da ist, da sind wir jetzt schon. Im Grunde. Also ist trotzdem eine tolle Frage so, weil man dann sieht, ja genau diese Antwortlosigkeit, diese Sprachlosigkeit und auch Gedankenlosigkeit von Banaschak ist im Grunde das viel Gefährlichere. Ja, also dass es hier um viel gefährlicher geht, finde ich schon sehr gut und klar entfaltet das dann mit diesen Ideen, dass man sie kopieren könnte, was immer nur wieder bedeutet, dass man ihnen in die Hände spielt, also der AfD und er zieht einen ganz klaren Schluss daraus. Selbst interne Strategie Papiere der Rechtsextremisten benennen den wirksamsten Hebel gegen sie klar, das Parteienverbot. Solange sie nicht verboten ist, kann sie gewählt werden. Solange sie gewählt werden wird, ist sie diesen Demoskopiepopulismus ausgeliefert. Mehrheitsverhältnissen, bei denen wir gleich nochmal diskutieren müssen, wie gut das eigentlich ist, das so zu delegitimieren, was da geschieht da.
Ich verstehe, das Argument teile es hier doch nicht, um das gleich zu sagen.
Ich teile es auch nicht so ganz.
Ich bin ja nicht derjenige, der sagt, mit dem Parteienverbot kommen wir da erheblich weiter. Wir schenken uns Zeit dadurch möglicherweise. Offenbar gibt es nicht viele Innenminister, die daran glauben, dass ein solches Verbot funktionieren könnte. Wenn das scheitert, wissen wir, wie katastrophal das dann werden könnte, wenn das Verbot scheitert. Aber das wäre jetzt nochmal eine ganz eigene Debatte hier. Ich finde jedenfalls diese Argumentation schlüssig, wenn man sagt, wenn sie nicht da ist, dann kann man sie nicht wählen. Dann ist auch dieser Umfragenpopulismus nicht mehr in dieser Weile da. Damit hat man sich das Problems entledigt. Aber er gibt ja dann in diesem Buch doch sehr viel mehr und mir auch naheliegendere Antworten, wie man eigentlich eine Gegenmacht bilden kann, ohne dass man dieses Verbot braucht, um zu zeigen, man könnte nicht nur sagen, eine Gegenmacht ist möglich, sondern auch eine Gegenwelt ist möglich.
Er hat in diesem Vorwortkapitel Brüche, noch ein paar Gedanken, die sind ganz gut. Zum einen noch mal von ihm der Hinweis, es ist nicht das unzureichende Wissen, das haben wir ja auch immer wieder betont, es nützt jetzt nichts, noch mal eine Aufklärung und hier noch mal eine Kampagne und so, sondern es ist der fehlende Wille. Und der fehlende Wille, und das finde ich sehr witzig in dieser KI-Diskussion, auf die wir auch nachher wieder zu sprechen kommen, die KI will ja auch nichts. Und da gleicht sie sich ja sehr mit dem, also der KI sagt man einfach Sachen, dann macht sie das halt so, also in dem Rahmen, in dem man ihr ein Prompt, ein Befehl gibt. Und die KI, damit können wir uns abfinden und damit müssen wir arbeiten, will von sich aus nichts. Sie ist uns ausgeliefert. So, was hier bedeutet, der Mensch ist ja zum eigenen Willen befähigt und er könnte ja auch mal eine Vision haben, also so eine Idee, wie es besser sein könnte. Da dreht er natürlich dann Helmut Schmidt das Wort im Munde um. Also, wer keine Vision hat, könnte ja auch mal zum Arzt gehen. Denn das ist doch das Eigentliche, was uns zum Menschen macht, dass man so eine Idee von morgen hat. Und so positioniert er dann auch das Buch, deswegen Gegenmacht, Gegenmacht als Unterscheidung zur Ohnmacht. Ja. Und damit sehr gut programmatisch aufgeschlüsselt, worum es dann in den folgenden Kapiteln geht.
Ja, die Herrschaft der Macht ist das erste Kapitel. Da steigt er damit ein, dass festgestellt wird, dass die Union erst mal wissen will, welche NGOs werden eigentlich vom Staat gefördert. Und da werden Listen angefertigt. Und er fragt sich auch sehr bald, warum sind wir eigentlich nicht dabei? Mit fragt den Staat, müssten wir nicht da auch schon gefremd werden als extremistisch oder was auch immer? Haben wir was falsch gemacht? Das ist natürlich die richtige Frage, die man sich stellen kann.
Er schreibt es natürlich sehr schön, denn wie wir alle, sagt er, ich war schockiert, als ich die Liste sah. Gedankenstrich, wir standen gar nicht drauf.
Also man muss schon auch für sich annektieren, dass man gefährlich ist. Also nicht sozusagen diese Selbstverharmlosung, die laufen stattfindet, sondern sagen, ne, wir sind aber gefährlich. Können wir da mal, können wir mal mit dem Verfassungsschutz reden oder so? Da stimmt doch was nicht.
Genau. Und dann der Verweis auf Machtübernahme. Er hat ja davor gewarnt, dass genau solche Listen geschrieben werden. Aber eigentlich war die Warnung vor, wenn die AfD mal an der Macht ist, schreibt sie solche Listen. Und dann war es aber CDU, CSU. Also da kommt wieder das viel gefährliche.
Ja, er schreibt, ich dachte, sie würde von der AfD gestellt werden, nicht von der CDU und CSU. Was für mich tatsächlich überraschend ist, wie schnell die autoritäre Wende voranschreitet.
Deswegen jetzt Vorwärtsverteidigung. Man muss jetzt raus aus der Defensive, in der wir alle sind und einen demokratischen Kern finden. Die Frage ist natürlich, wo und wie. Er kommt auf Demokratievereine, die sich gründen lassen. Immer wieder Techno und Tanz. Er macht das später dann mit den, also, ich kannte es nicht, aber dass man bei der AIDS-Bekämpfung damals gesagt hat, ja, tagsüber haben wir halt das und das gemacht. Und abends sind wir tanzen gegangen, um uns noch mal dran zu erinnern, warum wir das alles machen. Und das übernimmt er einfach für sich. Wobei ich jetzt wieder denke, AIDS ist halt so eine Krankheit, die Krankheiten so an sich einfach biologisch über unsere als Gesellschaft hereinbrechen. Während die AfD ja nun eben genau nicht dieses externe, ja, da landen so Aliens oder so. Also so behandeln die, das ist die Tagesthemen. Die gehen ja immer davon aus oder haben immer diesen Diktum, dass alle Zuschauer natürlich auch die AfD ganz blöd finden. Während sie natürlich auch in Sachsen-Anhalt senden, wo 50 Prozent der Leute sagen, wieso finde ich das gar nicht so blöd? Was redet die schon wieder?
Na, ich glaube, es geht ihm da eher mit dem Bezug zu den Anti-Aids-Kampagnen und auch zu den großen Aufklärungskampagnen, die ja auch sich sehr gegen neokonservative Politik, ob jetzt in der Bundesrepublik oder auch sehr stark dann unter Thatcher oder Reagan durchsetzten und ja die auch dann AIDS-Kranke entsprechend stigmatisierte, dass man sich dort also nicht in dieser Weise erstens stigmatisieren ließ und zweitens auch, dass man sagte, na ja, das Leben ist also sehr endlich, wie wir jetzt gerade in unserem Bekanntenkreis überall sehen. Das ist aber jetzt nicht der Grund, in eine totale Frustration zu versinken, sondern eigentlich aus dieser mystischen Lage heraus dann doch auch einen trotzdem dem entgegenzusetzen. Und ich glaube, das ist ja etwas, woran ja vieles, was aktivistisch stattfindet, oft leidet, dass man eigentlich sehr schnell gegen Barrieren läuft und dann müde wird und sagt, ich kann eigentlich nicht mehr. Und das sich dann auch bei Panel-Diskussionen, erlebt man es mitunter, so eine allgemeine deprimierende Stimmung breitmacht. Und da setzt er dieses Tanzen jetzt gegen. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen kitschig an manchen Stellen. Aber gut.
Also ich kenne ihn ja so ein bisschen, deswegen kann ich mir das ungefähr vorstellen, wie das so abläuft. Wenn er sich erinnert, ich hatte ja dieses Buch vorher, wo er dieses Remonstrieren und so. Und dann kommen einige, wir schreiten Beamte auf ihn zu und fragen schon mal, also wie ist das jetzt hier gemeint? Kannst du mir nochmal genauer erklären, was ich dann machen muss und so? Ja. Und dann sagt er, ja, also wir haben jetzt einen Demokratieverein gegründet und auch eine Techno-Veranstaltung. Komm doch zu beidem.
Ja, das wiederum finde ich ja sehr richtig, dass man also beides miteinander verbindet und dass man nicht sagt, hier machen wir jetzt den politischen Kampf und da darf auch nicht gelacht werden und alles andere ist irgendwie deine Freizeit, zieh zu. Sondern dass man sagt, also die Freizeit hat natürlich auch genau diesen zivilgesellschaftlichen Charakter, den er hier meint. Er fragt sich ja auch in diesem ersten Kapitel, wer wählt eigentlich in Deutschland, wer regiert eigentlich in Deutschland?
Lass uns das mal so einführen, dass wir sagen, genug Lobhudelei für den Anlass des Buches. Jetzt kommt ein Punkt, bei dem ich bei dir schon rausgehört habe, dass du es nicht so gut findest und ich auch nicht. Also ich muss hier klar Widerspruch üben.
Also die Sache ist, zunächst mal könnte man ja denken, dass dir das sehr zu Passe kommt. Also wir haben 84 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland und haben nicht alle eine Staatsbürgerschaft. Jetzt gibt es Leute, die sind zum Beispiel minderjährig, die können nicht wählen. Also stellst du dich schon mal heraus, wie viele Leute von den 84 Millionen wählen eigentlich. Und das sind dann genau 43 Millionen. Das heißt, 51 Prozent bestimmen, wer im Bundestag sitzt, ob Kubicki reinkommt oder nicht. Also nur 51 Prozent. Da heißt es dann hier, die Regierung hat eine Mehrheit. Sie hat nicht die Mehrheit, also eine Mehrheit, aber nicht die Mehrheit. Wer weiß, wie Wahlergebnisse aussehen würden, wenn Regierungskoalitionen zur Wahl stünden. Das fragt er sich dann auch noch, denn wir wählen ja tatsächlich nicht die große Koalition oder Rot-Grün, sondern wir wählen ja eine Partei und müssen dann ja zusehen, mit wem sie koordinieren, können das also nicht beeinflussen. Das ist ja erstmal eine Beobachtung, die ich jetzt so teilen kann als solche, dass das tatsächlich so ist in einem repräsentativen System, was ihn also dazu führt zu sagen, wenn das nicht die Mehrheit ist, sondern nur eine Mehrheit, dann muss man sich vielleicht gar nicht so sehr auf dieses nur parlamentarische Konzentrieren, weshalb ja die Zivilgesellschaft so stark gemacht wird. Das ist wiederum dann der Schritt, bei dem man sich fragen muss, wie weit kann man den mitgehen? Und da kommen wir jetzt, glaube ich, an so einen interessanten Punkt, dass wir es mit einem durchaus sehr effektiven Aktivismus zu tun haben, ob es jetzt um Sanktionsfall geht oder auch andere Initiativen, die hier aufruft und die auch konkret Situationen für Menschen verbessern. Die Frage für mich ist aber, ob nicht eine Überhöhung der Zivilgesellschaft stattfindet, wenn man so sehr sagt, na ja, aber die politische Macht ist ja jetzt auch nur eine von 43 Millionen und so weiter. Denn diese politische Macht ist ja doch, wie wir wissen, sehr entscheidend, zum Beispiel, um finanzielle Mittel zu bewilligen. Letztendlich auch bis hin zu einer Förderung einer NGO oder nicht.
Also da fand ich das Buch gut, weil ich es genau andersherum gelesen habe. Ich habe genau andersherum die Schlüsse draus gezogen. Wir haben ja sowieso einen großen Diskurs gerade rund um Ole und Simon und hier und da. Lohnt es sich, für diesen Staat zu kämpfen. Und in diesem Buch wird uns ja nochmal später dann vorgeschlagen, zu sagen, einfach die Unterscheidung mal richtig ernst nehmen. Der Staat ist nicht die Politik und die Politik ist nicht der Staat. Sondern die Politik ist einfach so ein Verwaltungsapparat, der sich um allgemeine Angelegenheiten kümmert. Manche fließen in Gesetze, die begegnen uns dann mit Handlungsvorschriften, Ermöglichungen, Subventionen, wie auch immer. Das ist dann der Staat. Und jetzt sagt er, naja, man...
Du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, das ist nicht der Staat. Also du sagst, der Staat und die Politik sind voneinander zu trennen.
Ja, also die Politik macht Gesetze. Und die Gesetze begegnen mir im Leben. Also mir werden rote Ampeln hingestellt und Subventionen ermöglicht, was auch immer. Das sind die Momente, in denen ich den Staat erlebe. Also wenn ich an der roten Ampel stehe, weiß ich, dass es der Staat, der mir hier gerade verbietet, jetzt zu fahren. Aber es ist nicht an jeder Kreuzung eine rote Ampel. Sondern manchmal können sich das auch die Menschen einfach unter sich klären. Und nur im Konfliktfall ruft man eine Stelle an. Aber auch das ist noch nicht der Staat, sondern erst mal geht man zu einem Richter. Dass der Staat wieder kommt und sagt, ach so, ja, hier haben wir so komplizierte Fälle, dass selbst die Richter sagen, wir wissen ja nicht weiter, wir brauchen einen Regelungsbedarf. Also da ist der Staat dann schon die Politik ganz schön weit weg, um in den Staat einzugreifen. Also hier eine Unterscheidung zwischen Zivilgesellschaft und Politik zu machen, finde ich sehr richtig.
Aber ich habe mir genau diese Unterscheidung mein Problem. Also ich mache den Unterscheid auch zwischen Politik und Zivilgesellschaft offensichtlich. Ja, sonst würde man ja sagen, könnte man gar nicht über Vereinsleben oder irgendetwas sprechen in Deutschland. Nur ist diese Idee von, es gibt eigentlich den Staat und der ist sehr stark gespeist aus der Zivilgesellschaft. Und dann gibt es noch so ein Anhängse, das heißt Politik. Und das wird eh nur von 43 Millionen unterstützt durch Wahl. Das ist etwas, was ich so nicht teilen würde, sondern da möchte ich schon festhalten. Nein, nein, also die Politik ist schon der Staat. Also das heißt, wenn Friedrich Merz in der Koalition entscheidet, innenpolitisch, außenpolitisch dies oder das zu tun, dann kann ich noch so sehr Zivilgesellschaft hier machen. Dann kann ich diskursiv vielleicht da einbringen, dass ich dagegen bin. Aber ich bin doch an sich diesem staatlichen Handeln und das ist dann zugleich das politische Handeln unterworfen.
Ja, und genau das ist ja nicht so, sonst würde ja Ferdinand von Schierach nicht vorschlagen, dass wir dem Kanzler jetzt mal genau diese Durchgriffsrechte mit drei Gesetzen, die man nicht hinterfragt.
Der will ja nur noch mehr Staat.
Also es gibt nicht noch mehr Staat und weniger Staat. Es gibt einfach Staat und nicht Staat. Und ich sage jetzt, was in zum Beispiel Privaträumen passiert, geht den Staat gar nichts an. Was irgendwer in seinem rechtsradikalen, publizistischen Wesen in seine Computer tippt, geht den Staat nichts an. Und wenn dann die Innenministerin kommt und sagt, ich verbiete jetzt Compact, also die rechte Radkanzlerin. So, dann kriegt sie ja ganz schön in die Fresse. Und da hat auch die SPD ganz schön in die Fresse gekriegt. Also das hat die Politik ganz schön Federn gekostet, die da beteiligt war.
Das liegt an dem rechtlichen Rahmen, der gesetzt wurde durch die Verfassung.
Und kommt ja Arne Semsrott und weist im Grunde schon sehr direkt gegen eine Argumentation, wie du sie gemacht hast, drauf hin. Also wenn hier Flüchtlinge ankommen und die Zivilgesellschaft kümmert sich darum, indem sie mit Teddybären zum Bahnhof fährt und Leuten Obdach gewehrt, dann muss sich die Politik da gar nicht einmischen. Sie macht es nur immer wieder trotzdem. Und das ist ein Problem. Jetzt sagst du, weil sie es kann. Genau. Und jetzt sage ich, also wenn wir das jetzt mal historisch betrachten und das jetzt mal auch zurückgebunden an, was wir hier vorfinden als Argumentation, es gab mal eine Zeit, in der hat gar niemand irgendwen gewählt, sondern da war einfach der totale Start. Also wenn da jemand auf dem Pferd angeritten kam, mit einem Helm auf und er lanze, dann wusstest du, der Typ macht jetzt eine Ansage und du gehörst. So wir hatten dann irgendeine Idee von, ja, da gehen so sieben Kurfürsten, die fahren so nach Frankfurt und dann wählen die jemanden. Und der Typ ist aber jetzt klar auf Lebenszeit, aber auch nicht so richtig. Dann haben wir hier dieses Bürgermeisteramt in Hessen, das im Grunde gar nicht von Bedeutung ist. Also nur für die Medienöffentlichkeit wird noch so der Bürgermeister, im Cosplay des alten Patriarchen der Stadt und so. Aber politisch ist das schon einer unter vielen und genauso steht es auch in der Verfassung. Und wir haben eine Entgrenzung der Beteiligung, dass wir heute sagen, naja, statt gar niemand 7 oder die 500 in Athen bestimmen zumindest mal so 43 Millionen, dann gehen ein paar nicht hin. Und ein paar sind Ausländer in der Art, dass sie hier nicht mitwählen dürfen und so weiter. Also wir haben, was die Politikseite angeht, finde ich ein politisches System, bei dem ich sagen würde, also wenn in Sachsen-Anhalt die AfD regiert, dann regiert sie dort ganz legitim. Weil sie ist nämlich gewählt worden. Und da sollte man jetzt kein Buch schreiben, in dem drin steht, das erkennen wir jetzt irgendwie nicht an, weil das waren ja nur so und so viele Wähler und nur 27 Prozent oder so. Weil das könnte man nämlich über jede andere Regierung dann auch sagen. Und dann hat nämlich die AfD Anhängerschaft auch recht zu sagen, die schweigende Mehrheit steht mit uns. Weil Merkel wurde nur von 13 Millionen gewählt.
Ja, aber das bestätigt doch eigentlich meine These, dass es am Ende die politische Macht ist, die die zivilgesellschaftliche überbietet.
Ja, und jetzt schließe ich an an unseren Diskurs beim Papst. Ich habe ja gesagt, der Papst weist schon darauf hin, dass es ein Primat bei den Konzernen gibt. Dann hast du ja hart widersprochen. Du hast gesagt, nein, die Politik gibt den Rahmen vor, die Konzerne machen. So und hier deswegen noch mal expliziter Hinweis, also du darfst dann gleich wieder widersprechen, aber das ist jetzt sozusagen für die Hörer. Die Politiker, die wir heute haben, die sind auch deswegen so scheiße, weil die sich diesen Konzernen komplett ausgeliefert fühlen. Also wirklich komplett. Es ist nicht das Primat der Politik, dass Leute mit mehr als 26 Millionen einfach sagen, ich habe gar keine Lust, von dem Geld was abzugeben, selbst wenn ich sterbe, schreib das mal bitte ins Gesetz. Und kein Politiker konnte sich dagegen wehren. Kein Politiker. Wollte man sich dagegen wehren? Das wurde genau so da reingeschrieben. Das ist ja egal. Du gehst jetzt auf Intention, dann kann man wieder die Politiker direkt nehmen. Ich sage jetzt einfach soziologisch drüber gesegelt. Die Politik konnte sich gegen diese Macht der Konzerne nicht wehren. Die Leute haben gesagt, das ist Betriebsvermögen, das ist sicher. Die Politik konnte nur noch die Waffen strecken und sagen, OK.
Aber das waren doch politische Überzeugungstäter. Das waren ja nicht Leute, die angetreten sind, eigentlich die große Erbschaftssteuerreform anzutreten. Und dann konnten sie sich leider, weil man ihnen die Pistole gegen die Schläfe hielt, nicht mehr wehren.
Du kannst es psychologisieren.
Wenn du ihr jetzt anhörst, ob du Markus Söder dazu anhörst oder Sigmar Gabriel, der ja auch leider jeden Tag im Fernsehen auftritt, das sind ja alles Überzeugungstäter, die immer sagen würden, ne, also mit Verwirrungsteuer, da kommen jetzt Mann nicht in diese Richtung.
Diese Argumentation führt aber nur zu einem, dass man nämlich einfach nur sagen kann, die Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung gibt es, weil damals die falschen Politiker im Parlament waren. Und dann sag ich, ne, es ist völlig egal, wer da im Parlament gewesen wäre. Das könnten superarme Schluckler sein oder Markus Söder, der selber 400 Millionen zu verteidigen hat.
Aber es wäre ja nichts passiert, wenn sie es nicht gemacht hätten.
Also sie haben es ja gemacht. Dieses Gesetz gibt es. Es ist gegen jedes Interesse, vor allem das der Mehrheit, gegen das der Politiker und gegen das der Journalisten, die darüber berichten. Und trotzdem gibt es das.
Aber nicht gegen das Interesse des Kapitals. Also man kann ja schon.
Aber das Kapital ist nicht die Politik, sondern hier hat sich das Kapital gegen die Politik durchgesetzt.
Der Staat ist ja schon ideeller Gesamtkapitalist, der versucht, den Standortvorteil für Deutschland hochzuhalten. Und das bedeutet zum Beispiel auch, dass man eine Eigentumsordnung gewährleistet, die nicht so leicht angefochten werden kann, dass zum Beispiel Vermögen besteuert werden.
Ja, aber damit hast du doch deine Vereinheitlichung von Politik und Staat gerade aufgelöst, indem du gesagt hast, das Kapital ist der Staat.
Und das stimmt.
Das Kapital ist der Staat, nicht die Politik.
Nein, der Staat ist der ideelle Gesamtkapitalist. Die Politik verwaltet kapitalistische Interessen.
Ja, aber damit ist doch das Kapital tonangebend im Staat und nicht die Politik. Und genau das ist doch wichtig zu markieren.
Ja, aber es ist die Politik am Ende, die den Handlungsspielraum setzt oder vergrößert, verkleinert. Das heißt, jedes Offshore Modell ist ja auf Grundlage einer staatlichen Entscheidung entstanden. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die einfach so irgendwo Inseln oder was gründen, sondern das sind ja alles staatliche Entscheidungen, die ermöglichen, dass Google in Irland sitzt und so weiter. Luxemburg zum Beispiel besondere Reformen unter Jean-Claude Juncker durchgesetzt hat. Das sind ja alles staatliche Deregulierungsmaßnahmen, was bedeutet also, der Staat ist der Letzte, der entscheidet.
Ja, aber wenn die Politik entscheidet, das ist ja richtig. Am Ende sind das ja parlamentarische Entscheidungen.
Genau.
So, die parlamentarischen Entscheidungen werden von Politikern getroffen, die aber inhaltlich nicht überwachen, sondern unterwacht werden. Wir haben ja seit Horst Seehofer die Situation, dass die Ministerien, vor allem das Innenministerium, mehr Geld für externe Beratung ausgibt, als für den eigenen Personalbestand. Was ja bedeutet, wir finden ja krasse und jetzt im soziologischen Sinne Korruptionen, also Arenenüberschreitungen, statt. Was ja eben gerade bedeutet, die Politik hat nicht das Problem, dass da dumme Leute sitzen, sondern dass da Leute sitzen, die entmachtet wurden, und zwar vom Kapital.
Nein, das sind Politiker, die gerne diese Interessen vertreten wollen.
Also würdest du sagen, statt strukturell umzubauen, reicht es, neue Politiker zu wählen?
Nein, nur ja. Also eine CDU hat sich ja diese Eigentumsordnung auf die Fahnen geschrieben, deswegen setze sie ja natürlich auch durch.
Also ich sehe das alles sehr kaputt.
Wolfgang Kubicki hat es uns doch in unserem herrlichen Buch links, rechts, deutsch, wie links, deutsch, deutsch, links, aufgeschrieben, warum er gegen irgendeine Art der Vermögensbesteuerung, der Erbschaftsbesteuerung ist. Das ist ja ein absoluter Überzeugungstäter, wo ich dir zustimme und ich glaube, da müssen wir aufpassen, dass wir jetzt nicht aneinander vorbei reden, dass ich, wenn ich sage, der Staat ist da der ideale Gesamtkapitalist, dass ich auch sage, genau, es ist die internationale Konkurrenz, die eine Kapitalistische ist, die am Ende dazu führt, dass solche Entscheidungen getroffen werden. Und deswegen sagen dann auch viele Politiker, die eigentlich mit einem sozialen Gewissen mitunter auftreten wollen, schweren Herzens müssen wir dies oder das tun, weil wir sonst im Standortwettbewerb nicht mithalten können. Und das ist sicherlich eine Unterwerfung unter diese Kräfte des Marktes und der internationalen Konkurrenz. Insofern hast du mit dieser Unterwerfung absolut recht. Nur wollte ich betonen, dass es immer Politik ist, die entscheidet und es ist nicht der Konzern, der in dem Sinne entscheidet. Und das liegt aber an einer internationalen Staatenkonkurrenz.
Ja, ja, ja, die internationalen Staatenkonkurrenz.
Was mein Punkt aber jetzt wäre, mit diesem Begriff der Zivilgesellschaft. Ich habe mir einen Aufsatz schicken lassen, der schon einige Jahre alt ist, aus dem Jahr 1992. Ambivalenzen der Zivilgesellschaft von Volker Heinz erschienen in der politischen Vierteljahresschrift. Und da ist es ganz interessant, dass diese Autor sich kritisch mit dem Begriff der Zivilgesellschaft, der ja hier grundlegend ist für das Buch von Arne Semsrott, auseinandersetzt, da die Zivilgesellschaft eigentlich im Zuge des Zusammenbruchs der Sowjetunion und auch mit dem Ende einer klassenkämpferischen Politik plötzlich überall groß auf die Fahnen geschrieben wird. Und man eigentlich, so sagt Volker Heinz, dann die Zivilgesellschaft sieht als etwas, das jetzt so dagegen treten kann gegen Technokratie, gegen ja eine, sagen wir, nur auf Mehrheit ausgelegte Politik, also eine Aufwertung der Minderheit findet statt. Und Heinz sagt dann, für die aktuelle Verwendungsweise des Begriffs der Zivilgesellschaft ist andererseits Kennzeichen, dass die liberale Wende gegen jeglichen Etatismus von einem theoretischen Antiökonomismus begleitet wird, der die Tabuisierung des strategischen Handelns durch Habermaß noch neo-aristotelisch steigern möchte. Zwar kritisieren die Anhänger des neuen Konzepts ausdrücklich das neoklassische Projekt einer Rücknahme des Staates in eine dann nicht mehr länger vorpolitische Sozietat Zivilis, im Gegensatz etwa zum Bürgerhumanismus der Renaissance. Zugleich wird jedoch der Begriff der Zivilgesellschaft von jeglichen Interessehandel gereinigt, so als wolle man doch den antiken Tugendbegriff übernehmen. Klingt jetzt schwierig, was ist aber damit gemeint? Und da sehe ich ein gewisses Problem, dass man sagt, der Staat ist eigentlich gut und gehört uns und wir sind der Staat. Und dass man auch so tut, als gäbe es da eigentlich keine Interessenkonflikte und deshalb die Zivilgesellschaft so stark macht und sich von der Politik so fernhält, weil in der Politik noch Interessengegensätze tatsächlich aufeinanderprallen. Und ich würde tatsächlich diesem doch sehr aristotelischen Demokratiebild von der Zivilgesellschaft, das ja auch mit einer 84 Millionen Republik wenig zu tun hat, doch in eine gewisse Skepsis entgegensitzen und mich fragen, ob man hier nicht versucht, quasi mit Bürgerbewegungen, Initiativen und so weiter unter dem Begriff Zivilgesellschaft was normativ aufzuwerten, was aber, wenn man einfach auf die klare Interessenpolitik sieht, einfach einem großen Block von Gegensätzen konfrontiert ist, nämlich die sich politisch dann auch zum Beispiel in einem Parlament artikulieren.
Also das sehe ich alles ganz anders und ich sehe auch in der Entfaltung, wie du es jetzt gemacht hast, eine große Gefahr, nämlich dass sich Leute einschüchtern lassen, weil irgendwer Aristotelisch und irgendwas mit Habermas gesagt hat. So, irgendwas ist neoklassisch, alles gut, aber so wie ich das hier verstehe und so wie ich es auch fühle und so wie ich es auch gut finde, um das alles auf einen Begriff zu bringen, entfaltet sich das für mich wie folgt. Es ist nämlich alles gar nicht so kompliziert und es gibt einzelne Sätze, die wir alle kennen und die wir auch richtig finden, wie zum Beispiel gegen Armut hilft Geld. Da nützt es nichts, eine Reform zu machen. Leute, die einfach zu wenig Geld haben, haben auch deswegen Depression. Eine Therapie, das würde Geld kosten, würde man denen das Geld einfach direkt zahlen, hätten sie sehr viel weniger Sorgen und vielleicht auch keine Depression. Punkt. Das ist ein ganzes Argument. Ohne Aristoteles, ohne Neoklassik, ohne 1000 Jahre Menschheitsgeschichte. Dasselbe, wir hatten diesen Text hier besprochen, gegen die Einsamkeit von mittelalten Männern hilft, dass sie einfach mit den Männern reden.
Punkt.
Wieder kein Aristoteles, wieder keine Neoklassik, wieder kein Habermass. Einfach nur Geselligkeit. So, und jetzt folgender Punkt, auch wenn du gegen den jetzt schon zweimal anargumentiert hast, aber ich wiederhole nochmal, weil ich das sehr wichtig finde, wie das im Buch entfaltet wird. Die Politik ist die Politik und da widerspreche ich, wenn nach unseren Verfahren eine Legitimation ausgesprochen wurde, gilt sie. Wir können nicht das Thema über den Haufen werfen, in dem wir sagen, zwar wurde nach 80-jähriger bundesrepublikanischer Tradition in Sachsen-Anhalt ein Landtag gewählt, aber ich erkenne ihn einfach nicht an, weil ich keine Lust habe. Oder weil mir das meiner Meinung widerspricht. Oder weil mir das schlechte Laune macht. Sondern wenn die AfD da regiert, regiert da die AfD. Und wir könnten allenfalls noch sagen, naja, die letzten 80 Jahre war es nicht. Und da hatten wir Glück gehabt. Und jetzt muss halt mal AfD. Vielleicht entzaubert sie sich, wir auch nicht.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist die Grenze, die die Zivilgesellschaft akzeptieren muss.
Ich bin hier noch gar nicht bei entweder Grenze oder Zivilgesellschaft. Sondern ich entfalte jetzt überhaupt erst die Idee der Zivilgesellschaft.
Sagen wir, das ist eine Gewalt des Faktischen, die man nicht ignorieren kann.
Ich habe einfach ein Faktum reingeworfen. Man kann die Welt ändern, aber nicht alles auf einmal und vor allem nicht in den Fundamenten so hart. Also ein Landtag ist ein Landtag. Wir können jetzt nicht den Kapitalismus abschaffen und gleichzeitig noch die sachsen-anhaltinische Verfassung neu schreiben. Sondern es ist jetzt wie es ist. Was aber bedeutet, so sehr ich hier widerspreche, dass wir jetzt bitte nicht die sachsen-anhaltinischen Verfahren der Legitimation untermauern, sondern dies ist einfach wie sie sind. Aber das Argument zu sagen, neben diesem politischen Betrieb, der einfach nur ein Verwaltungsapparat ist, nach Verfahren, die wir halt in Gesetzen drinstehen haben, das ist nicht alles. Sondern da sitzen einfach nur 400 Leute in einem Parlament oder so und machen halt so Sachen. Aber das ist nicht die Zivilgesellschaft. Die Zivilgesellschaft ist das allgemeine Leben, das sehr gut auch ohne Politik auskommt, dann natürlich immer droht, in die Anarchie zu verfallen, weshalb man sich so Regeln stellt, über Regeln muss bestimmt werden, also gibt es halt irgendwie so Politik. Aber wieder, ohne Aristoteles, ohne Habermas, ohne alles. Einfach nur, Menschen finden halt Regeln und wenn es zu viele Menschen werden, muss man sich halt gedenken, wie das war.
Der Bezug zu Habermas wurde ja von Volker Heinz nur deshalb hergestellt, weil er festgestellt hat, dass im Zuge des Zusammenbruchs der Sowjetunion, sich dieses Konzept der Zivilgesellschaft, das im Übrigen, so schreibt er, ein Angloamerikanischer Reimport ist, so ausgebreitet hat, auch mit sehr vielen Verweisen zu Hannah Arendt laufend, um dann zu sagen, hier in der Zivilgesellschaft ist eigentlich die große Macht. Das ist auch ein sehr akademischer Diskurs. Was dann bedeutet, dass man sich fragen muss, inwieweit ist das jetzt einfach nur eine Verschleierung der eigentlichen Machtverhältnisse, bei denen du ja jetzt auch gerade sagst, naja, wenn der Landtag da ist, ist er so da, wie er ist. Dann gibt es zwar immer noch Bereiche, die ja Arne Semsrott auch sehr gut beschreibt, in denen sehr viel Handlungsspielraum ist, aber das bedeutet nicht, dass damit die politische Macht übertrumpft werden kann, die de facto da ist. Und damit geht es doch nur, weil ich den Eindruck gewinne manchmal in diesem Buch oder jetzt mit dir im Gespräch, dass der Einfluss bzw. die Macht der Zivilgesellschaft mitunter gerade sehr überhüllt wird. Und ich feststelle, ähnlich wie Volker Heinz vielleicht sogar, schon 1992, dass damit ein bisschen uns verloren geht, anzuerkennen, dass vielleicht die Macht gar nicht so groß ist, wie man sie glaubt, wenn sie eben politisch anders konstituiert ist.
Ja, so, also die Politik macht Sachen. Allein, weil es einen Setzungskalender gibt. Weil jemand die Tagesordnung bestimmt. Nicht, weil die Politik hochgradig magisch aufgelöst... Ja, das ist jetzt nicht... Es finden einfach Wahltermine statt, dann sitzen da Leute, die kriegen eine Tagesordnung, die kriegen Beschlussvorlagen, die entscheiden. So, das ist alles. Keine Magie. Die Frage ist jetzt, in welchem Sinne entscheiden sie? Und gerade wir in unserem Podcast können sehr genau sagen, in wessem Sinne seit den 80ern in Deutschland politisch entschieden wird. Und jetzt kommt mein Argument. Es gibt einen spezifischen Einfluss der Zivilgesellschaft auf diese politischen Verfahren, die genau dazu führen, wo wir heute sind. Verschonungsbedarfsprüfungen, Kapitalerträge, obwohl es Einkommen ist bei 25 Prozent pauschal, statt einfach einen persönlichen Einkommenssteuersatz, den ja jeder hat, anzuwenden. Mietpreise, die durch die Decke gehen. Und wenn die Leute das nicht mehr bezahlen können, kommt einfach der Staat und sagt, ich zahle Wohngeld, ich leg noch was drauf. Ja, all diese Sachen. Das ist nicht einfach die Politik, sondern hier gab es einen spezifischen Einfluss der Zivilgesellschaft, von denen wir sehr genau sagen können, wie sich diese Zivilgesellschaft definitorisch auf den Begriff bringen lässt, nämlich reiche Leute. Reiche Leute haben sich in der Politik durchgesetzt.
Aber hier in diesem Buch ist es ja eher so, dass unter Zivilgesellschaft, so heißt er auch der Unterteil, die Zivilgesellschaft vielleicht zurück, doch gesagt wird, dass also Zivilgesellschaft an sich etwas Positives ist. Nein, ganz anders. Und in dem Diskurs der vergangenen 30 Jahre meint Zivilgesellschaft das bürgerliche Engagement, Ehrenamt etc. und meint gerade nicht das Engagement, das du da beschreibst, nämlich du beschreibst ja einen Lobbyismus.
Ich lasse es mir jetzt weder auf Aristotelische noch auf Habermas noch auf Lobbyismus bringen, sondern ich sage einfach nur, die Zivilgesellschaft, die Gesellschaft selbst hat sich in die Politik eingemischt und es in ihrem aber particularistischen Sinne hingebogen. Und jetzt ist die Frage einfach nur für jeden Einzelnen, ist es denkbar, dass es noch andere gesellschaftliche Einflüsse auf Politik gibt, neben den Reichen? Nur weil wir bisher ausschließlich den Einfluss der Reichen auf die Politik sehen, die letzten 40 Jahre, heißt es noch nicht, dass das für immer so sein muss, dass es unerklärlich ist, dass darin eine paradigmatische, definitorische Konstanz liegt, sondern es kann auch anders sein.
Das stimme ich voll zu.
So, und jetzt ist die Frage, jenseits von der reichen Zivilgesellschaft, die ja nur ein Teil der Zivilgesellschaft ist, welche anderen Bereiche der Zivilgesellschaft können wir denn überhaupt uns erdenken, die Einfluss haben könnten, und wie würden wir sie definieren? So, und hier macht das Buch Angebote. Und deswegen, ich habe es schon angekündigt, es ist auch wichtig, jetzt hier vermeintlich alberne Begriffe. Es könnte ja sein, dass man Begeisterungsfähigkeit, oder wie ich bei Markus Lanz gesagt habe, Geselligkeit mal wieder zum Maßstab macht. Also nicht der Reichste. Wir fragen mal nicht den Reichsten, der natürlich am meisten Kapazität hat, sich den Tag freiräumen kann und noch delegieren kann, um Einfluss zu nehmen, sondern wir fragen mal die Leute, die zum Beispiel diese ganzen privaten kleinen Vereine so tragen, zivilgesellschaftlich, die da auch wollen, dass sich die Politik da nicht einmischt. Und denen geben wir trotzdem mal Anhörungszeit und so. Es gibt einfach neben den, die reichen, noch andere zivilgesellschaftliche Kräfte, ohne dass man immer gleich, ja die Politik und die Reichen, das ist eins. Das ist die Politik, das ist der Staat. Nee, wir lassen mal diese ganzen Begriffe weg einfach. Es gibt die Politik, die macht Legitimation durch Verfahren. Das ist aber nicht gleich der ganze Staat, sondern das ist einfach nur, ich meine, wer kennt den Politiker? Niemanden. Wir können die Politiker nicht einfach verallgemeinern auf alle. Das sind Leute, mit denen hat man gerade keinen Kontakt, deswegen sind sie ja Politiker. Das zeichnet sie ja aus. Das widerspricht ja komplett, das ist der ganze Staat. Die treffen halt mal eine Entscheidung. Aber diese Entscheidung wird präfiguriert. Die wird geprägt, die wird vorbereitet.
Das ist ja die Idee von zivilgesellschaftlicher, vielleicht noch mal diesen Begriff klar zu machen. Zivilgesellschaft meint ja, alles, was nicht direkt Politik ist, bedeutet ganz klar Vereine, Bürgerinitiativen, NGOs. Es geht im Übrigen jetzt nicht um das Privatleben. Also man muss schon als Zivilbürger unterwegs sein, sondern es geht um das öffentliche Leben. Das heißt, wenn ich zu Hause im Bett liege und lese, bin ich da jetzt nicht Teil der Zivilgesellschaft.
Das ist erst der rechten Staat.
So, das ist noch mal eine ganz andere Sphäre. Also es geht um diese zivilgesellschaftliche Dinge. Und das kann dann auch der Fußballverein sein oder kann zum Beispiel sowas wie Sanktionsfrei von Helena Steinhaus sein. All das sind zivilgesellschaftliche Einrichtungen. Diese Aufwertung der Zivilgesellschaft, die ja stattgefunden hat im Zuge der vergangenen 30 Jahre, könnte man auch als einen gewissen Ohnmachtsdiskurs deshalb erleben, weil gerade die politische Macht einem so aus den Händen geklitten ist. Man hat nicht eine starke Arbeiterpartei, die jetzt gerade entsprechende Sozialgesetze durchzieht, bei denen dann gar nicht mehr so ein Verein wie sanktionsfrei vonnöten wäre, sondern man hat eine Politik, die also die ganze Zeit den Sozialstaat kaputt schlägt, weshalb man dann so ein Verein wie Sanktionsfrei hat, der versucht, vereinzelne oder auch diskursiv etwas rauszuholen. Nämlich das ist das Entscheidende. Es geht also bei der Zivilgesellschaft nicht nur darum zu sagen, wem können wir einen Pflaster verteilen, sondern oftmals geht es auch darum zu sagen, wir sind ja auch Teil des Diskurses der Öffentlichkeit und können wir quasi als Zivilgesellschaft auf politisches Handeln einwirken.
Genau.
Wenn ich den Namen noch einmal fallen lassen darf, dann ist ja bei Abmaß diese Idee der deliberativen Demokratie, die du jetzt gerade hier stärker verteidigst als ich, bin ein bisschen erstaunt, aber wir lassen das mal so stehen.
Nein, nein, nein, gar nicht.
Dass wir hier sehen, dass man also sagt, die politische Willensbildung findet nicht einfach nur im Parlament statt, sondern wenn man zum Beispiel weiß, es gibt unglaublich viele Vereine, die jetzt gerade anprangern, dass nicht entsprechend für den Klimaschutz gearbeitet wird, dann prägt das die Politik. Insofern, als man feststellen kann, Fridays for Future hat große Demonstrationen gemacht, sie waren aber auch in dem Sinne wirksam, dass also die Politik sich selbst, wenn sie CDU geführt war, Merkel Politik war, davon beeindrucken ließ und dann den einen oder anderen Schritt in die richtige Richtung gegangen ist, dass es also der zivilgesellschaftliche Diskurs, die Macht, die von dort ausgeht, die auf die Politik einwirkt, weshalb also Politiker durchaus beeinflusst werden können. Wenn sie die ganze Zeit glauben, die Menschen fragen sich nur, wie können wir weniger Flüchtlinge haben, dann liegen sie falsch. Das zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement zeigt vielleicht, dass andere Themen viel wichtiger sind.
So, also wir haben ja eine Ausgangslage, in denen Leute einfach persönlich ganz reich werden wollen und die FDP, die noch das Angebot macht, zu sagen, hier eine Wallet und so, ja, digital first irgendwas, du bist auf dich allein gestellt, mach das Beste draus, dann kannst du später, wenn du reich bist, da mitspielen, wo man den Politikern einfach eine richtig schöne Einflugschneise, 5-Sterne-Hotel, Abendveranstaltungen, Sekt und so weiter. Dann sagt man einfach, was man will, fertig. So, und jetzt sagt Arne Semsrott, ne, wir machen es mal nicht über persönliches Voranstellen. Also jeder muss seine eigene Avantgarde werden, superreich. Und dann ist es einfach ein komfortabler Weg ins Parlament. Sondern nein, wir kümmern uns jetzt mal. Und deswegen finde ich es auch beleidigend, ja, haben wir das Deliberative. Arne Semsrott will keine Sitzkreise, sondern der will Vereine.
Er ist schon für Bürgerräte.
Ich habe es hier gelesen. Er macht das genau richtig. Nämlich nur Bürgerräte, wenn sie entscheiden dürfen. Nicht einfach nur. Und das ist jetzt der Punkt. Keine Sitzkreise, in dem man noch mal eine Meinung bekundet. Sondern, und jetzt ganz wichtig, und es kommt so sanft daher, aber es ist ganz wichtig, Vereine, in denen Leute intern aus Begeisterung dabei sind und die nach außen einen Konflikt organisieren können. Die also genau nicht das machen, wie die reichen Zivilgesellschaft organisieren. Da ist ja keiner dabei, weil er das so begeisternd findet, dass da einfach so viele Superreiche sind, sondern man ist einfach superreich. Jeder will dem anderen zeigen, wie reicher er ist. Und dann baut man genau kein Konflikt zur Politik, sondern man lädt die so ein. Man ist mit denen befreundet. Man zeigt denen noch mal, dass es viel besseres Essen gibt, als wenn der Bundestag eine Sitzung organisiert im Ausschuss und so weiter. Sondern das sind eben, das muss man so deutlich sagen, ganz neue Modelle für Deutschland, dass man Sachen ernsthaft mal im Konflikt regelt. Deswegen warst du ja auch gerade begeistert von Kubicki, der einfach sagt, Sorry, Frau Wellmer, aber ich bin hier im Konflikt mit Ihnen. Ich werde Ihnen Ihre AfD-Scheißfrage nicht beantwortet. Konflikt, Konflikt, Konflikt. Und da gehe ich ja voll mit. Man muss Konflikt machen, aber intern Begeisterungsfähigkeit. Man muss mal wieder eine Vision sich zutrauen können, auch belächelt von außen. Guck mal, da kleben sich Leute auf die Straße. Wie bescheuert sind die denn und so? Ja, aber es war halt die Begeisterung, dass man zumindest mal eine Gruppe findet, die das eigene, die Schicksalslosigkeit, die Zukunftslosigkeit teilt, die einen da zusammenbringt. So und das sind, das muss man ganz deutlich sagen, für Deutschland ganz neue Formen. Da stehen alle Boomer da und machen sich lustig darüber. Das haben wir ja genauso erlebt. Aber das nützt trotzdem nichts. Begeisterungsfähigkeit statt einfach eigener Avantgarde. Ich bin reicher als du. Und ne, wir machen hier nicht komfortabel, glandestin, die Öffentlichkeit geht es gar nicht mit. Und dann haben wir plötzlich eine Verschuldungsbedarfprüfung, sondern Konflikt, Konflikt, Konflikt. Der Konflikt muss in die Politik hineingetragen werden. Und genau diese Forderung wird hier thematisiert. Das ist genau richtig. Das ist eine Definition von Zivilgesellschaft, bei der ich totaler Anhänger bin.
Was dann für Semsrott bedeutet, dass man eine kritische Masse haben will. Und die muss nicht unbedingt regieren, um Wirkmacht zu haben. Fridays for Future ist ein Beispiel. Er sagt, aus dem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner wird oft der Schluss gezogen, dass man nicht die Inhalte, sondern die Kommunikation ändern muss und die Wählerschaft anders anzusprechen. Politik verkommt zu einem Produkt, bei dem Demoskopen statt Betroffener die Prioritäten setzen. Er geht ja auf diese Ideen von Umfragen ein. Also es ist ja einfach so, dass wenn man ein politisches was durchsetzen will, gibt man für viel Geld eine Umfrage in Auftrag und die kommt natürlich immer schon durch die Fragestellung dabei heraus, dass die Leute sagen, ja genau, Migration ist auch mein größtes Problem. Wenn man sie zum Beispiel nicht mal danach fragt, wie wenig Geld haben sie eigentlich und wie hart arbeitet sie.
Da haben wir im Fernsehpodcast auch schon beobachtet. Die Umfrage ist ja nicht mal mehr, wie stehen sie zur Migration und dann wird das aufaddiert, sondern es wird ja über Bande gefragt. Was glauben sie, wie Deutschland zur Migration steht und dann sagen 80 Prozent, ich glaube, Deutschland findet das nicht so gut und dann wird das reportiert als, das ist nicht so gut für Deutschland. Das ist natürlich total bescheuert. Also hier von demoskopischem Populismus zu reden, der nicht nur keine Aufklärung liefert, sondern genau im Gegenteil.
Ja, alle sind dann nur noch Beobachter der Beobachter und so, als seien sie die Analytiker.
Ja, alles auf dritter Ebene, sehr bescheuert.
Er bringt ja diese Frage dann, die SPD kümmert sich mehr um Bürgergeldempfänger als um Leute, die hart arbeiten und wenig Geld verdienen. So, dann gibt es da eine große Zustimmung. Ja, genau, die SPD, da muss sie sich auch mal ändern. Aber nicht gefragt wird, sagt Semsrott, die SPD kümmert sich um Millionäre mehr als um Leute, die hart arbeiten und wenig Geld verdienen. Was würde eigentlich dabei rauskommen, wenn man das zum Beispiel mal erfragen würde?
So, und im Zuge dessen seine Erwähnung von Gerhard Schick, Arne Bräulger, die also genau diesen, wie du jetzt sagen würdest, den Teil Staat verlassen und in die Zivilgesellschaft wechseln, weil sie ja verstanden haben, wie das funktioniert. Politiker regieren nicht einfach, sondern die lassen sich von demoskopischem Populismus hier, von Lobbyismus da unter Druck setzen. Also könnte man auch einfach zu denen gehören, die die unter Druck setzen. Und dann stellen die fest, damit komme ich viel weiter. Also Kevin Kühnert und so. Die können ja die SPD mittlerweile an der Nase herumführen. Das Einzige, was die SPD noch davon abhält, ist eben Lars Klingbeil, der der CDU gefallen möchte. Und jetzt muss die Partei halt irgendwann entscheiden, will mir lieber 10 Prozent oder nicht der CDU gefallen. Und wenn so ein Konsens aufgebrochen wird, dass die GroKo die letzte Patrone ist, weil Robin Alexander das schreit, könnte man ja vielleicht auch mal zu so einer neuen Idee von SPD kommen. Du bist ja natürlich zu Recht skeptisch. Aber es ist ja trotzdem nicht...
Gerade bei Kevin Kühnert, also das ist ja nun ein Paradebeispiel dafür, dass er sich ja der totalen Anpassung hingegeben hat.
Das ist jetzt wieder dein Zynismus.
Nein, aber das ist ja so. Also das wird ja niemand leugnen, dass Kevin Kühnert als Generalsekretär, das schreibt ja Semsrott in gewisser Weise nicht so drastisch wie ich auch selbst, dass er ja da eigentlich den Sigi Gabriel gespielt hat. Und jetzt plötzlich nochmal neue Betätigungsfelder sucht. Das kann man auch verstehen, irgendwo muss da noch Geld reinkommen. Aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass Kevin Kühnert wäre ja genau der radikale Politiker gewesen, der sich sogar mit der Eigentumsordnung angelegt hat und von der Verstaatlichung, Vergesellschaftung von Konzernen sprach und anschließend eine Politik mitträgt, die sogar die Sanktionen gegenüber Bürgergeldempfängern erhöht. Da ist er ja nicht beeinflusst worden durch irgendeine blöde Lobby, sondern dann hat er sich ja einfach dieser Parteikarriere unterworfen.
Ja, guck mal, das ist genau der Unterschied zwischen, du sagst, wir brauchen einfach andere Politiker und ich sage, es ist ein strukturelles Problem. Kevin Kühnert hatte keine Zivilgesellschaft, die ihm erlaubt, dieses Argument innerhalb der Politik zu machen, weshalb er ausgeliefert ausschließlich der reichen Zivilgesellschaft gesagt hat, ich verlasse lieber diese Politik. Aber er hat doch die Politik verlassen, genau aus diesem Grund.
Ja, aber er wollte sich ja nicht anlegen. Also er ist ja dann nur rausgegangen, weil wirklich kein Vor und Zurück mehr da war.
Ja, aber nein, also hier muss ich jetzt wirklich ganz klar sagen, in dieser Politik, wie wir sie haben, hat derzeit die reiche Zivilgesellschaft 100 Prozent der Macht auf ihrer Seite. Kevin Kühnert könnte zwar noch irgendwelche Wortmeldungen zum Thema geben, aber er wäre komplett isoliert. Es sind ja auch viele isoliert. Also hat er gesagt, er geht lieber.
Ja, aber er war Generalsekretär und hat die Sachen ja mitgetragen. Das hätte er nicht machen müssen in dieser Weise.
Das müssen wir jetzt für die Hörer mal markieren. Ich sage ganz deutlich, wir können nicht das Schicksal von 85 Millionen Menschen in die Hand von, ja Kevin Kühnert war einfach nicht hart genug. Wir haben hier strukturelle Probleme.
Ja, aber das ist ja ein Problem.
Wir dürfen jetzt nicht immer Aristoteles Habermas und Kevin Kühnert sagen, sondern wir müssen weg von den Namen.
Aber das strukturelle Problem liegt ja genau darin, was ich ja anfangs gesagt habe, dass die Parteien, wenn man dann in ihnen ist, so funktionieren, wie das sich die FDP mit dem Strackzimmermann auch gerne vorstellen würde, dass man einfach so weitermacht und Kevin Kühnert sich diesem Pfad, den man da eingeschlagen hat, angeschlossen hat. Und dass er dort nicht als der freie Radikale aufgetreten ist, der in irgendeiner Weise die Partei unter Druck setzt. Stattdessen hat er sich dann irgendwann zurückgezogen.
Aber hier gibt es auch zwei Denkangebote.
Weil er gesehen hat, dass da seine Karriere nicht mehr weitergehen kann. Das war ja vollkommen klar.
Ja genau, das sage ich doch die ganze Zeit. Das können wir doch nicht Kevin Kühnert zum Vorwurf machen. In der Politik, wie wir sie haben, ist derzeit keine richtige Politik möglich, weil die reiche Zivilgesellschaft 100 Prozent des Einflusses auf ihrer Seite hat. Es gibt das, was Arne Semsrott hier fordert, eine Zivilgesellschaft, die mal wieder mit einer Vision, einem Angebot, einem nachvollziehbaren Programm gibt es einfach nicht. Und deswegen ist Kevin Kühnert gescheitert. Jetzt kann man natürlich ewig sagen, ich liefere mich der Fernsehlogik aus, ich habe Kevin Kühnert gesehen, Kevin Kühnert ist ein Mensch, Menschen scheitern, ich könnte ja auch scheitern, Kevin Kühnert ist gescheitert. Sondern nein, wenn Kevin Kühnert die Möglichkeit gehabt hätte, einen zivilgesellschaftlichen Zug sich anzuhängen, der das Angebot macht, an die SPD, bei uns gibt es 5% zu gewinnen, wäre das ja möglich gewesen.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel ganz deutliche Mehrheiten und bei allen, die potentiell SPD wählen sowieso, für eine radikale Umbesteuerung.
Die ist aber nicht organisiert. Die schreiben keine Beschlussvorlagen, wir haben keine Termine im Parlament, diese Zivilgesellschaft gibt es nicht, die gibt es nur, die muss grobisch erhoben.
Genau, da muss man es wie Kubicki machen und sagen, es ist mir doch egal, ich weiß, wir werden gewählt werden mit diesem Programm. Und das wäre ja die SPD vielleicht gewählt worden. Also ich würde sagen, wir sollten jetzt nicht den Karriereismus von einzelnen Politikern unterschätzen.
Wir sollten gar nicht mehr auf Politiker, schaffen wir es gar nicht, Politikernamen zu nennen, sondern dann sind wir immer wieder in der, die sind schuld, die haben was gemacht und so weiter.
Nein, ich würde sagen, genau, weil sie sich dann am Ende dieser gesamtideellen kapitalistischen Idee verschreiben und sagen, naja gut, jetzt müssen wir über Standortpolitik reden. Und wenn ich über Standortpolitik anfange zu reden, und das hat Kühnert genau so gemacht, wie das alle anderen dann tun.
So, dann muss man aber jetzt...
Und dann ist er wie alle anderen. Wenn ich das anfange und rede so, dann bedeutet Standortpolitik zu sagen, wir müssen sehen, dass die Leute länger arbeiten und weniger verdienen. Das kann eine sehr gute Standortpolitik sein. So, und da muss ich ja ansetzen bei meiner Fundamentalkritik. Das meine ich ja sehr wohl. Aber ich habe deswegen Schwierigkeiten, wenn ich gesagt bekomme, naja, Kühnert hat nur der zivilgesellschaftliche Rückhalt gefehlt. Nein, es ist schon auch so, dass hier jemand mitgemacht hat, diese Kapitalinteressen umzusetzen, die aber nicht einfach eine Frage der Zivilgesellschaft sind, sondern wirkliche Kräfte, Verhältnisse sind innerhalb der Wirtschaft und der Staatenkonkurrenz.
Und hier muss man jetzt ins Detail gehen. Also wenn du zu Recht sagst, Kevin Kühnert hätte ja einfach formulieren können, was er will. Und dann hätte das ja als... Hat er ja vorher gemacht. Dann wäre das ja ein Signal an die Wähler gewesen, zu sagen, ah, das finde ich gut, den wähle ich jetzt. So, wenn man das will, muss man, muss man einen ganz großen, programmatischen, organisatorischen Umbau unseres deutschen Parteienwesens und des Parteienrechts machen. Und das beschreibt er nämlich hier im Abschluss des ersten Kapitels, Zivilgesellschaft versus Parteien. Man muss dann offene Vorwahlen mit Kandidatenaufstellungen, über die die Öffentlichkeit befindet, also Vorwahlen nach amerikanischen Systemen organisieren. Die haben wir aber nicht. Und genau das war der Genickbruch für Kevin Kühnert. Kevin Kühnert kann von mir aus fordern, BMW entmachten. Aber die Seehammer-Kreise sitzen abgesichert durch unser Parteienrecht, abgesichert durch, das ist mir doch in meinem Landkreis, Wahlkreis, egal, was der da irgendwo fordert. Da ist nichts zu machen. Wir haben kein Spitzenkandidatensystem, in dem genau diese Verknüpfung aus, Kevin Kühnert hat eine Meinung, die die Mehrheit teilt und die Mehrheit kann dann sagen, ich wähle den Weg von Kevin Kühnert. Genau das gibt es in Deutschland nicht. Deswegen hier die Forderung von Arne Semsrott völlig zu Recht. Dann machen wir doch so ein offenes Vorwahlensystem, um genau das zu ermöglichen, was du jetzt gerade als das ist das Potenzial von Kevin Kühnert, bei dem ich sage, ja das hat er nicht genutzt, weil er es nicht konnte und du sagst, das hätte er nutzen müssen. Und wir beide sind dann überein und sagen, ja genau, aber dann brauchen wir wieder ein Verfahren, das legitimiert, das ganz anders funktioniert, als wie wir es jetzt gerade machen. Und das haben wir aber nicht. Deswegen die Forderung von Arne Semsrott, mach doch offene Vorwahl, dann hätte Kevin Kühnert eine Chance gehabt. Dann wäre das nämlich klar gewesen, jemand der so eine Vorwahl gewinnt, wie in Amerika, zieht die ganze Partei hinter sich, sozusagen der informale Parteichef, und kann dann auch programmatisch bestimmen. So, aber solange man einfach nur seinen Wahlkreis gewinnt, sind halt noch 200 andere Leute, die auch im Wahlkreis gewonnen haben in der Fraktion. Und das ist die Einflugsneiße für den Lobbyismus. Und das ist aber nicht den Personen zum Vorwurf zu machen. Sondern dann schaltet einfach nur einer aus, der mit Ambitionen eine Zivilgesellschaft mobilisieren wollte und dann bei der Fraktionsformation gesehen hat, also meine Rednerliste Nummer ist 183. Und das ist halt in Deutschland ein echtes plakate Ding.
Na ja, der Mann war ja schon Generalsekretär. Man hat ja schon auch Stellschrauben, an denen man drehen kann.
Ja, das sehen wir doch, was die Generalsekretäre öffentlich wirksam, aber solange sie da widersprechen.
Ich sehe an Jens Spahn, dass man damit sehr erfolgreich sein kann.
Jens Spahn ist der Fraktionschef der reichen Zivilgesellschaft, die er übrigens reich gemacht hat, mit Milliarden hier und was mit dir jetzt da.
Jaja, ich will nur sagen, also ich glaube, wir müssen noch nicht über Kevin Kühnert. Ich glaube, du überhöfst ihn da sehr. Aber wir werden ja sehen, er wird bestimmt in die Politik zurückkehren.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch.
Davon können wir ausgehen. Und dann kann man sich diese Folge, glaube ich, gut nochmal hören.
Ja, aber dieses Kapitel 1 ist eine sehr gute Vorbereitung für Kapitel 2, nämlich Sorgearbeit. Ich habe das Gefühl, man muss eigentlich gar nichts mehr dazu sagen. Begeisterungsfähigkeit, Sorgearbeit, diese Idee. Leute kümmern sich mal wieder um einander. Man regelt nicht alles nur über Geld und hier und da, sondern man kommt mal wieder zu einer anderen Idee. Jenseits von die Politik ist die reiche Zivilgesellschaft, die alles über Geld regelt. Wer kein Geld hat, braucht Freunde. Und hier wird es beschrieben.
Das Existenzmaximum schlägt davor, soll bei 50 Millionen Euro liegen. Danach 100 Prozent Steuern.
Also es schwirren ja verschiedene Wege. Sein Bruder Nico Semsrott hat ja auch schon so 100 Millionen mal mit Marinic im Podcast gesagt und hat gesagt, die 100 Millionen, wenn man die erreicht hat und danach kriegt man noch eine Urkunde, dass man den Kapitalismus durchgespielt hat und lebt von 30.000 Euro am Tag, die man überwiesen kriegt. Warum nicht?
Er schreibt, die zentrale Antwort auf die Politik sollte sein, Vertrauen in den Mittelpunkt progressiver Politik und Bewegung zu stellen, statt Misstrauen zwischen verschiedenen Bevölkerungsgruppen zu säen. Die Politik hat die Aufgabe, Vertrauen zu stärken. Dabei geht es nicht um kritiklosen Gehorsam. Ein gewisses funktionales Misstrauen gegenüber Macht braucht es immer. Aber wir müssen Institutionen schaffen und stärken, die Vertrauen ermöglichen, statt es systematisch zu untergraben. Wir alle wollen doch den Menschen in unserer Umgebung vertrauen können. Und das klingt ja erst mal so gut. Aber da frage ich mich dann schon bei dieser Idee von Gesellschaft und was die Politik machen soll, ob man nicht hier einfach die Interessen, Gegensätze ausklammern muss, um zu einer solchen Idee zu kommen. Weil wir haben ja nun ein System, das nicht nur arbeitsteilig ist, sondern eben auch in Klassen und alles Mögliche unterschieden ist. Und was bedeutet, dass die Interessen der einen nicht die der anderen sind. Und deswegen ist ja dieses Gemeinsame in der Weise nicht zu finden, sondern eigentlich nur als permanenter Streit oder Kampf zu verstehen.
Also wenn man in Sportvereinen ist und abends Badminton spielt oder was auch immer, gibt es da einfach Systemvertrauen. Und typischerweise weiß man nicht, was die anderen verdienen. Und das ist auch kein Thema oder sonstiges. Sondern da gibt es einfach aus sich heraus.
Auf der Ebene des Nahbereichs. Aber über die war ja hier nicht die Rede. Hier ging es ja um Institutionen, die die Politik schaffen soll.
Ich würde ja sagen, das wichtigste Politikfeld ist die kommunale Ebene. Das wird natürlich medial nie so transportiert. Deswegen kann es aber keiner so richtig glauben. Aber wenn man einmal beschreibt, wieviel Föhrle, Franz und Fantasy im Fernsehen als Bundespolitik dargestellt wird und wie wichtig eigentlich kommunale Politik ist. Und kommunale Politik ist wie dieser Spruch von Florian Haneck aus Dings Erlangen, der Bürgermeister kann nicht flüchten. Also da, wo du noch in einem echten Gespräch drinhängst und der Bürgermeister nicht einfach sagen kann, ich muss jetzt nach Hause und dann 100 Leute stehen lässt. Und auf der Ebene, also da, wo wir wirklich null Übung haben, schon allein, weil wir gar nicht erwarten, dass da eine Entscheidung für uns getroffen werden kann, da kann Systemvertrauen und Personenvertrauen neu verankert werden. Macht man nur nicht. Ist jetzt auch kein Buch, das in diese Richtung geht. Aber da ist auf jeden Fall Potenzial. Also beim Thema Vertrauen, gerade, dass man in einer Welt, in der uns Bundespolitik als Personenvertrauen Problem dargestellt wird. Glauben wir Friedrich Merz oder nicht? Was halten wir von Wolfgang Kubicki? Wer sind die zehn wichtigsten Politiker? Auf einer ganz anderen politischen Ebene wieder in Systemvertrauen zu kommen, sieht nach so einer riesigen Aufgabe aus. Aber es ist fast ein Selbstläufer. Man müsste nur mal den Fernseher ausschalten. Dann ist man schon wieder ganz nah dran am Straßenverkehr oder an den Turbulenzen im Nahverkehr, an dem man so hängt. Aber ja, sanktionsfrei wird ja hier auch erwähnt. Sanktionsfrei fährt ja genauso zweigleisig, wie ich das ja auch total fördere, dass sie zum einen den Solidartopf haben, der ja mittlerweile schon so eine Millionengröße hat, aber auch die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit dazu machen. Und dann macht Sarah Tacke wieder so ein Fernseher-Fantasy für Lefans. Und Helena Steinhaus hält einfach komplett dagegen auf Instagram und gewinnt auch die Debatte. Das sind natürlich genau die richtigen.
Was ich sehr gut finde, die haben ja jetzt wirklich Programmbeschwerde eingereicht.
Ja, genau so.
Nämlich das ist ja etwas, was so Familienunternehmer normalerweise machen. Oder brauche ich meine Programmbeschwerde? Da war bei Panorama irgendein Beitrag, da muss ich mal gegen vorgehen. Und hier sehen wir dann, kann man das auch mal von der anderen Richtung machen. Und so sollte man es viel häufiger tun.
Ja, das ist genau der Punkt. Warum macht das nur die reiche Zivilgesellschaft? Das können doch auch die arme Zivilgesellschaft machen.
Hier sehen wir das. Ja, ich bin sehr dafür.
Konkrete Utopien. Ich finde natürlich dieses Wort prägorative Politik richtig gut, weil das ist so, wir haben hier ein Büro, so ein paar Projekte, wo wir das auch so spielerisch durchgehen.
Du musst es erklären.
Das mache ich später. Ich lasse es jetzt nebulös und obskur, aber mit einem Pflug durch die Gesellschaft pflügen, einfach nur um eine Änderung herzustellen. Und dann aber nicht zu sagen, da muss jetzt ein Avantgarde, sondern Vanguardism. Alle zusammen. Ohne Führung. Mal gucken, wohin die Furche so führt, ja. Das sind so Sachen, begrifflich macht das schon super Spaß, wenn ich überhaupt mal über neue Worte nachdenke, als der Fraktionsvorsitzender hat gesagt, und morgen ist wieder Bundespressekonferenz und so. Das ist ja alles total lame, sondern hier mal neue Sachen zu machen. Von daher auch diese Zeitdimensionen damit reinzubringen. Also wer Visionen hat, die Vision zielt ja auf morgen ab. Wir gehen also nicht jetzt zum Arzt, weil wir uns für morgen was wünschen, sondern wir gehen zum Arzt, weil wir feststellen, wir wissen noch gar nicht, was morgen ist. Herr Arzt, können Sie mir bitte mal sagen, in welche Richtung ich jetzt so denken muss? Ja, da habe ich eine Therapie dafür, wie auch immer. Aber machen Sie es doch schon mal im Hier und Jetzt. Bereiten Sie es doch schon mal vor, damit Sie da nicht so davon überrascht sind, dass plötzlich eine Möglichkeit sich eröffnet, sondern erkennen Sie doch mal eine Möglichkeit, wie der Papst schrieb. Wir können nicht immer alles nur die Reichen haben eine Gier und machen bei dem Arm eine Not. Und dann muss die Politik, weil es der Einzelne nicht mehr schafft, ein Programm. Und danach stellt man fest, aber irgendwie ist das schlechte Programm. So, das geht ja nicht. Von daher, das kann man ja auch alles mal anders denken. Also das finde ich sehr gut. Da nennt man natürlich dann auch hier Fusion Festival, Cast Communication, Kongress. Kann man schon mal die Welt leben, im Kleinen, die man sich im Großen wünscht. Da auch der große Vorwurf. Natürlich gibt es das richtige Leben im Falschen. Man muss halt nur den Kampf, statt immer nur Flauschigkeit zu erwarten. Nein, es muss schon halt gekämpft werden. Das ist wirklich sehr gut. Da kann man in das Buch auch mal ein bisschen abholen. Gerade in so einer großen Orientierungslosigkeit. Man muss halt verstehen, dann einen Weg der Bewältigung finden und sich immer wieder einreden, warum es sich lohnt. Und dann kann man auch anders in die Welt gehen, als sich immer ausliefern zu lassen, weil irgendwer mal wieder in den Tagesthemen, also weil die nur mal wieder nur in der Lage waren, einen superreichen Verbandschef zu irgendwas einzuladen, um ihn zu fragen, was ist denn jetzt mit China? Reiche waren China, was ist denn jetzt mit China? Wen interessiert China?
Dabei wird deutlich, wie wichtig die Fürsorge ist, auch als politisches Instrument. Die Infrastruktur, die dargeschaffen wird, die kann für die Macht gefährlich sein. Da heißt es, Fürsorge besitzt eine enorme politische Kraft, zum Beispiel, um die schwarze Bürgerrechtsbewegung zu bekämpfen, fokussierte sich die US-Regierung unter anderem auf das kostenlose Frühstücksprogramm der Black Panther Party. Das FBI versuchte gezielt, nicht als erstes politische Veranstaltungen, sondern diese sozialen Aktivitäten zu schwächen, weshalb sich auch leicht erklären lässt, warum wir in unserer Öffentlichkeit wenige kostenlose Angebote haben, wo Menschen sich miteinander treffen können und in den Austausch treten. Dann wäre nämlich sehr schnell eine Schwungmasse da, die sich politisch mobilisieren ließe. Aber genau das gibt es nicht. Im Übrigen kann man ja auch sagen, zivilgesellschaftlich jetzt so in der langen Tradition von Vereinen oder so, geht es natürlich auch immer von rechts, was wir ja jetzt erleben, dass also rechte Strömungen in östlichen Gebieten vorwiegend in Deutschland dazu übergehen, Sommerfeste zu organisieren, irgendwelche Veranstaltungen anzubieten für Familien. Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, auch der Aufstieg des Nationalsozialismus hat ja zivilgesellschaftliche Grundlagen. Also auch da hat man sich ja in Vereinen zusammengetan. Das war eigentlich alles immer nur NSDAP.
Das hat jedes Kind in eine Organisation gebracht.
Ja, also das war als sie dann an der Macht waren. Aber die Sache ist ja davor.
Das ist das Fundament dieser Macht.
Also in den Zwanzigerjahren gibt es ja nun sehr viele zivilgesellschaftliche Einrichtungen, die sehr rechts sind. Also zivilgesellschaft hier auch nochmal muss man sich vorstellen, dass es eben nicht einfach nur bedeutet, es gibt das Gute, das Tugendhafte ist bei der Zivilgesellschaft, das kann natürlich auch eine ganz andere Richtung umschlagen.
Was aber immer bedeutet, diese Organisation, die du jetzt auch genannt hast, ich würde auch sagen so Subkulturen, Erlang und so, das ist einfach Anlaufstellen für etwas günstiges Essen. Diese Planstellen müssen halt richtig geschaffen und finanziert werden.
So, und da kommen wir ja wieder in diesen Bereich, wo ich sage, dann müssen wir doch mit der Politik vorleben nehmen.
Oder mit Leuten, die Geld haben und sowas gerne unterstützen.
Genau, das wäre dann mit Senatentum. Ja. Kommen wir zu Kapitel 3 mit Medien und Kultur. Da geht es darum, neue Räume zu schaffen, wie es schon im Titel heißt. Das Kapitel beginnt aber dann erst einmal damit, dass man darüber spricht, wie man mit Nios umgehen kann zum Beispiel, Ja, wie denn? Abmahnen. dass man auch abmahnen kann. Man muss also versuchen, die mit den eigenen Waffen zu bekämpfen. Und das ist etwas, was Arne Semsrott wohl häufig macht. Also Falschberichterstattung, Urheberrechtsverletzung, all das. Ich bin ja nicht so ein großer Fan von diesen permanenten Klagen, mit denen man sich jetzt gegenseitig überziehen kann.
Also News macht ja echte Tatsachen Behauptungen, die einfach falsch sind.
Aber ich sehe, ich lasse mich das doch zu Ende sagen, ich sehe da natürlich einen nötigen Handlungsspielraum, den man vielleicht nutzen kann.
Von X abmelden.
Ja, hast du dich schon mal abgemeldet?
Naja, ich betreibe meinen Account dann nicht.
Wie du betreibst den nicht? Ich verlinke dich da immer brav.
Ja, das sehe ich nicht.
Ach so, dann kann ich das ja lassen.
Und Kevin von Hagen dran meinte auch, ja, die Leute sagen umso mehr, dass man auf X noch bleiben muss und so weiter und so, je mehr Follower sie haben. Und das stimmt natürlich auch. Das ist ja auch der Sender das große Problem, dass da alle jetzt ihre 100.000 Follower oder so haben und es einfach nicht, obwohl die ganzen Follower schon nicht mehr da sind.
Ja, ich kann aber sagen, dass das wirklich nicht mehr konvertiert. Also ich bin da zwar noch, aber stelle ja fest, ich kann das ja in der YouTube-Statistik nachschauen, was ein Post eines YouTube-Videos von mir, von der Filmanalyse bringt. Das kann ich ja nachvollziehen. Da kann ich sagen, da hat Twitter etwa so viel Ausschlag, wie wenn ich in der Nachbarschaft klopfe und sage, hallo, ich habe ein neues Video veröffentlicht.
Es ist die rechtsextreme Echo-Kammer des Faschisten Elon Musk, wie er steht. Und zwar völlig zu recht.
Das bringt tatsächlich nicht viel. Es wird Kritik geübt an der Bildzeitung, aber auch am öffentlich-rechtlichen. Vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig in meinen Augen. Er hat ja dann auch Tipps, was man genau machen kann, wo man auch vielleicht einfach mal ignorieren sollte. Das halte ich sowieso für eine sehr gute Idee, vieles zu ignorieren. Da steht zum Beispiel Weltherausgeber, Ulf Poschert sagt etwas, ignorieren. Die AfD sagt etwas, Plattform entziehen. Weiß nicht so recht, wie das geht. Eine Freundin sagt etwas Blödes, direkt ansprechen. Also das kann man nämlich machen. Ein FDP-Politiker schreibt ein Buch, sich lustig machen. Also das sind konkrete Tipps.
Er hat ja ein Szenario, das er in sieben Schritten durchgeht. Also die AfD macht eine kleine Anfrage zum Thema, was weiß ich, steht in der Wikipedia Blödsinn. News greift das auf, macht das zum Thema. Die BILD vererbt das auf ihre Seite, weil es ja eine Debatte gibt, weil bei News ja so viel Debatte angestoßen wird. Und dann kommt ein Fötterstück in der Zeit. Und ich habe mich gefragt, hat er hier Ijoma Mangold vor Augen, der noch mal die, wie er schreibt, persönlich schlechte Erfahrung mit dem eigenen Wikipedia-Eintrag zum Anlass nimmt, um...
Hat Mangold dazu was geschrieben?
Nein, aber ich habe das überlesen und habe mir gedacht, kommt das nicht von ungefähr, dass hier das Filter der Zeit auf die Debatte, wenn sie dann bei der Bild angekommen ist, nach dem News berichtet hat, was die AfD fordert. So ja, aber vielleicht war das nur ein Scherz, der sich in meinem Kopf entfaltet hat.
Er schreibt, progressive Bewegungen in Deutschland haben viele Erfahrungen damit, die Kommunikation zu verändern, Themen zu setzen und den Diskurs zu verschieben. Das Gendern ist hierfür ein gutes Beispiel. Da bin ich mir jetzt unsicher, ob das wirklich ein gutes Beispiel ist, weil man jetzt ja nicht sagen kann, dass das flächendeckend funktioniert und ich sage mal...
Naja, aber dass man nicht in die Sprache eingreifen soll, während die Bayern und die Hessen, CDU und CSU, die Gesetze machen, diesen Verweis sollte man ja, finde ich, immer wieder machen.
Das kann man natürlich machen. Das macht er ja auch. Es ging ja jetzt darum zu sagen, wie sehr der Einfluss von progressiven Bewegungen betrachtet werden muss. Und da halte ich das nicht für unbedingt jetzt ein Beispiel, wo jetzt so viel gewonnen wurde. Das scheint mir jetzt nicht eine große Erfolgsgeschichte im Ganzen zu sein. Auch wenn sich da der Doppelpunkt oder der Stern da und dort in manchen Medien möglicherweise durchgesetzt hat. Zumal es ja eine uralt Debatte ist. Also diese Art der Sprachpolitik, es geht jetzt zurück auf die 70er Jahre. Was er dann vorschlägt ist, und da bin ich doch von diesem Kapitel ein bisschen enttäuscht, ist, dass er zwar sagt, neue Räume schaffen, aber es entstehen eigentlich in diesem Kapitel so gut wie keine neue Räume, bis auf ein Beispiel, nämlich Flash. Also er stellt sich vor, ein Online-Medium, das angriffslustig und kampagnenfähig ist.
Kompromisslos progressiv.
Es vereint Tagesaktuelle Berichterstattung und pointierte Hot Takes mit Investigativ-Recherchen. Die Säulen der Website und Social-Media-Kanäle bilden Nachrichten, Hintergrundstücke, Meinungen und Satire, Inhalte der Plattform sind stets machtkritisch und zielen auf die Skandalisierung von Missständen ab. Dabei tritt Flash Selbstbewusstheitsstimme der Mehrheit im Land auf, zugespitzt, bis man überdreht und lustig, aber immer faktentreu. Also das wäre jetzt die schon häufig erwähnte linke Bildseite. Warum gibt es die nicht? Man braucht eigentlich nicht viele Leute, sagte 15. Braucht man zwei, sollen reichen Reporter werden. Also die gucken, was die reichen machen. Möglicherweise sogar Paparazzi braucht man, diesen Lebensziel dann einzufangen. Das soll mit freiwilligen Unterstützungsmodellen dann funktionieren beziehungsweise Vermögen, die ihr Erbe sinnvoll einsetzen wollen, sollen da herhalten. Also ich finde die Idee auf jeden Fall gut im Sinn von, die müsste man mal verfolgen. Wunder mich auch, dass es das bislang gar nicht gibt, dass man sich da so wenig zutraut. Die Frage ist natürlich, bis auf das, dass man damit sehr viele Leute wird ärgern können und sehr gut. Die Frage im Ganzen jetzt noch mal so politisch gesehen, wie verändert sich eine Gesellschaft? Also man hat ja auch mit diesem Portal fragt den Staat jetzt nichts, was bulwadesk ist. Aber man hat ja auch etwas, was ein Medium, das also recherchiert, Anfragen stellt und damit Leute in die Bredouille bringt oder bzw. Behörden in Rechtfertigungszwänge. Und das ist ja erst mal ein sehr gutes Mittel, der gegenmacht, wo Arne Semsrott ja auch dahinter steht. Die Frage ist für mich dann nur, was geschieht mit den Enthüllungen oder was wird sich dadurch politisch in Bewegung setzen? Also einen Artikel, ich will nur darauf verweisen, der das kritisch sieht und sicherlich aus einer konservativen Note heraus auch verfasst ist, verfasst, ein bisschen erstaunt, aber doch sehr lesenswert. Es ist ein Artikel, der vor zwei Jahren im Merkur erschien, von Victor Loxon. Der heißt der halb geöffnete Mund und da geht es um diese Frage der Transparenz. Das ist ja etwas, was dann eigentlich schon eine Idee war, die unter US-Präsident Woodroff Wilson stark war, also die geheimnislose Demokratie eigentlich, weil das Geheimnis ist eigentlich noch was aristokratisches. Dann setzt sich in den 50er Jahren ein Diskurs der Informationsfreiheit durch. John Moss ist dann der, der es dann schafft, 1966 eine Mehrheit für dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz zu organisieren. FOIA, ein Modell, das sich dann auch in vielen weiteren Ländern durchsetzt, in den 70ern, Frankreich, 80ern, dann Kanada, Australien, Neuseeland. Jetzt hat man sowas wie, fragt den Staat natürlich auch. Wir haben ja ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz erst 2006 in dieser Weise bekommen. Und die Frage, die aber jetzt Viktor Loxen in diesem Aufsatz stellt, die finde ich ganz interessant, nämlich, was passiert eigentlich, wenn diese Meldungen nun publik werden? Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Medium hat, wie fragt den Staat oder Flash, wenn man jetzt da weitergeht. Und da heißt es dann an einer Stelle, der Slogan, Democracy dies in darkness, der Washington Post, ist stolzer Ausdruck dieser medialen Öffentlichkeit, nicht jener blinden Transparenz. Die fragmentierte Medienlandschaft und eine Bevölkerung, in der sich substanzielle Teile aus der bürgerlichen Öffentlichkeit ausgeklinkt haben, produzieren insofern schon nicht die richtigen Subjekte für die Informationsflutungen der Transparenzmaschinerie. Unter diesen Bedingungen wendet sich das Transparenzideal hinter dem Rücken der Akteure gegen sich selbst und resultiert letztlich nur in mehr gesellschaftlicher Intransparenz. Sind schließlich nicht die unaufhaltsam ansteigenden Antragszahlen symptomatisch für den Vertrauensverlust. Die Sehnsucht nach Transparenz wird ja exakt in dem Maß virulent in dem das Vertrauen in Parlamente, Gerichte, Behörden und traditionelle Medienwelt bereits verschüttgegangen ist. Die Abertausenden-IFG-Anfragen von ressourcenstarken Akteuren organisierter Partikularinteressen an eine demokratische Verwaltung ließen sich dann mit einiger Berechtigung als Bürokratie und Gleichheitsproblem diskutieren. Die Demokratie wird jedenfalls nicht durch geschäftsmäßig habitualisierte Politik paranoier gerettet, sondern durch das von ihr in Aussicht gestellte gute Leben. Also die Frage, die sich ja hier stellt, auch wenn ich mich nicht zurücksehne, was ich ein bisschen daraus lese, nach der alten Medienlandschaft, ist natürlich, wenn wir es mit einer so fragmentarischen Öffentlichkeit zu tun haben, inwieweit kann also ein Magazin wie Flash noch quasi dann mehr bringen als Hot Takes, die einer gewissen Klientel gefallen werden? Also inwieweit ist das überhaupt noch möglich, dass man das hinleitet zu einem Strom, der dann ein politisches Handeln herbeiführt bzw. eine andere Politik herstellt? Das ist ja gar nicht so leicht zu beantworten.
Ja, deswegen würde ich sagen, diese Frage ist einfach zu vermeiden und auch wirklich historisch auszusortieren. Aber das ist ja, sag ich ja hier auch nicht zum ersten Mal, dass mich weder die Politiker namentlich noch ihr Bewusstsein oder das Bewusstsein irgendwelcher Wähler interessiert, sondern wir müssen es abseits dessen organisieren.
Aber du bist ja darauf angewiesen, dass potenzielle Wähler zum Beispiel auf eine von fragt den Staat initiierte Anfrage oder durch ein solches Magazin wie Flash produziertes investigatives Stück entsprechend reagieren, als nur Schulterzucken dazu zu sagen OK, was kommt jetzt?
Da bin ich natürlich total dafür. Nur es gibt da einen großen Unterschied zwischen Oma Erna muss abends vom Schlafengehen nochmal was gesagt werden. Aus heiterem Himmel. Jetzt kommt die nächste Anbrudation zu welchem Thema. Random. Also für sie einfach wirklich random.
Hier geht es mehr darum, wie kann man es bündeln. Also du musst eine gewisse Bündelung von auch einzelne Akteuren in der Zivilgesellschaft herstellen, um einen wirklichen Druck zu bekommen dann auch dadurch. Was die Reichen haben, da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht, sehr leicht, weil sie sind gar nicht viele. Sie telefonieren kurz vorher miteinander. Alle haben schon morgens das Handelsblatt gelesen. Wir wissen also Bescheid. Und dann können sie sagen, der Verbandschef so und so ruft jetzt mal beim Kanzler direkt an oder beim Generalsekretär. Und das ist ja eine Sache wie das zivilgesellschaftlich. Also das, was an Transparenz hergestellt wird durch zum Beispiel fragt den Staat, dann aber auch wirklich eine Wucht entwickelt. Und nicht nur für uns etwas, wo wir hier im Podcast mal drauf eingehen. Da gibt es eine interessante Anfrage. Und wir sprechen also Einzige darüber, sondern das ist wirklich eine Gemeinschaftsherstellung. Und das ist natürlich in einer fragmentarischen Medienlandschaft sehr schwierig herzustellen. Und da sehe ich immer das Problem, also wie organisiert man das? Eine große Frage, die sicherlich Arne Semsrott auch nicht so einfach beantworten kann. Wie organisiert man also Zivilgesellschaft noch mal so im Ganzen, dass man sagt, aha, aber das hat dann wirklich jetzt zum Ausschlag, dass im Ganzen sich etwas bewegt, also über das Regionale hinaus.
Genau, das meine ich, die Zivilgesellschaft im Ganzen, von der ich sage, gibt es nicht, hat es nie gegeben, war immer nur so eine Idee von, oder als größere, Deswegen ja auch mein Interesse für diesen Herrn Hegemon, der als absolutes Phantom, deswegen auch Arne Semsrott, der sich lustig macht darüber, dass bei der demoskopischen Erhebung eines Meinungsbestandes gefragt wird, was glauben Sie, welche Meinung andere Leute haben? Und dann erdieren wir das einfach hoch und damit haben plötzlich andere Leute eine Meinung, die man so sich in Zahlen ausdrücken lässt. Also ich glaube das gar nicht. Ich halte die Vorteile von Frag den Staat von Sanktionsfrei, vom KS-Communication Club und so weiter. Das sind, und das ist der große Erfolg dieser reichen Zivilgesellschaft. Die reiche Zivilgesellschaft hat für sich verstanden, wir müssen es als Partikulare Organisation organisieren. Uns doch egal, was die Zivilgesellschaft hat im Gemeinen, im Allgemeinen, die hat eh keine Zeit sich darum zu kümmern. Genauso muss man hier rangehen. Sanktionsfrei ist für Politiker, Verbandsvertreter, Leute, die in Organisationen arbeiten, die ein Wissensdefizit haben und dann denken, ich könnte da mal nachfragen, weil die haben Kontakt mit den Armen. Und dann schaut mal da mal nach. Deswegen auch die große Wut, wenn plötzlich eine Journalistin, die einfach so, ich informiere die Allgemeinheit, wie Sarah Tacke, so einen Film macht. Weil das ist einfach völlig daneben. Und das passt ja auch konzeptionell in wirklich kein modernen soziologischen Gedanken, was das soll. Oma Erna noch mal Einzelfälle vorzuführen von 84 Millionen Menschen, die angeblich, weil Oma Erna jetzt auf ihre Rente Steuern zahlt, von Oma Erna aus Geld leben und es unverstehend machen. Also diese Bogenschläge kann man alle irgendwie konstruieren, aber die haben mit der Realität nichts zu tun. Wir kommen nachher auf Stefan Kühl zu sprechen, der auch einfach Sätze reinschreibt, wie Management-Moden haben ja nur so ein bisschen was mit Realität zu tun. Das ist halt so eigene, mediale Realität. Und so ist es sich auch. Von daher dieses Flashting, ich hätte es einfach komplett gestrichen. Ich hätte da einen ganz, aber nur soziologisch halt krassen Satz so, was interessiert mich einzelne Politiker? Was interessiert mich das Bewusstsein von irgend wem? Hier gibt es Sachen zu regeln, also werden die einfach geregelt und zwar in einer sehr responsiblen, aber großen Rücksichtslosigkeit auf den Rest der Gesellschaft.
Ein Beispiel, das Semsrott hier bringt, ist der Verband der Familienunternehmer.
Denen war kein Rest, denen ist das auch alles scheißegal. Die wollen ihr Ding durchbrügeln, das machen die.
Und das ist bitte kein Lieferkettengesetz. Da ist es dann, die wirksam das Gesetz sein kann, zeigt er auch der eindrucksvolle Streik an der hessischen Autobahnradstätte Grevenhausen. Da beschreibt er, wie der Familienunternehmerverband so stark lobbyiert, dass dann auch Robert Habeck sich dazu hinreißt, zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt die Kettensäge auspacken und das wegbeulzen. Das war seine Rede, weil dieses Berichtspflichten, alles was damit verbunden ist, doch für die armen Familienunternehmer viel zu schwierig ist. Das heißt also ein Lieferkettengesetz, das ja ohnehin schon sehr geschliffen wurde, auch von seinem Vorgänger Altmaier, wurde dann eigentlich, dem wurde ganz der Zahn gezogen, weil dieser Verband der Familienunternehmer seine Interessen entsprechend artikulieren konnte und Habeck hat das dann mitgetragen.
Guck mal, man kann das Buch wirklich zusammenbinden auf immer wieder denselben roten Faden, den er immer wieder selbst nicht so ganz, also er glaubt sich selbst nicht so ganz, aber ich will es hier ganz deutlich sagen, Arne, du hast ganz recht. Es werden demoskopische Fragen erhoben, die müssen umverteilt werden. Inhaltlich einfach nicht nur die Fragen, die wir bisher immer stellen, wer ist der beliebte Politiker, wer hat vor was am meisten Angst, sondern andere Fragen. Demoskopie umverteilen. Bürokratie nicht abbauen, umverteilen. Warum haben wir bei den Hartz-IV-Leuten so eine Krasse, wir kommen mal zu ihnen nach Hause und zählen die Zahnbürsten durch, während wir vor 30 Jahren einfach die Vermögensteuer abgeschafft haben und dadurch gar nicht mehr ein Datenbestand erhoben wird. Also Bürokratie umverteilen. Hier auch das nächste Kapitel Geld umverteilen. Geld ist ein spezifisches Medium, mit dem wir Handlungsvermögen in einer Gesellschaft herstellen. Das Kapitel müssen wir gar nicht durchgehen, weil jeder weiß, was wir dazu sagen. Jeder weiß, was Arne Semsrott dazu geschrieben hat.
Bezahlkarte kommt hier nochmal auch ein Bürokratie-Monster. Da man ja jetzt einfach in den Behörden, in den Ausländerbehörden, Leutensitzern, die Einzelüberweisungen, ob das 5 Euro für den Sportverein sind oder 13 Euro fürs Internet, den Flüchtlingen genehmigen müssen, damit sie diese Zahnung machen können. Das heißt, man hat ein Bürokratie-Monster geschaffen.
Also ich will es noch mal auf diesen Punkt bringen. Bürokratie umverteilen, Demoskopie umverteilen, Mehrheiten umverteilen, Geld umverteilen. Was man nicht machen muss, ist, Oma Erna nochmal zu informieren, was hier alles im Argen liegt. Aber in dem Moment, wo News Scheiße macht oder Sarah Tackes Scheiße macht, darauf reagieren.
Nur jetzt noch einmal mein Einwand. Geld umverteilen, wenn er zum Beispiel hier schreibt, führt die zentgenaue Überwachung von Asylsuchenden zu mehr Gerechtigkeit? Nein. Führt das Zurückholen von Milliarden Euro Cum-Ex-Kosten zu mehr Gerechtigkeit?
Ja.
Und so weiter. Dann kann ich das auch alles und sehe das auch alles genauso wie Arne Semsrott. Nur das ist ja eigentlich gerade keine Frage der Zivilgesellschaft, sondern da sind wir wieder im Reich der Politik. Wo entschieden wird, die Bezahlkarte einzuführen und stattdessen auf Cum-Ex-Einnahmen zu verzichten?
Ja, aber hätte man vorher die Demoskopie und die Bürokratie umverteilt, dann hätte die Politik auch nicht so einfach, das so zu organisieren. Also sich eine Reservearmee zu schaffen, weil die Superarten gebrauchen.
Dass ich nur sagen will, man muss ja dann, um diese Entscheidungen zu treffen, in die Politik rein. Das meine ich ja nur.
Also er zeigt ja auch Wege in die Politik.
Das kann ich ja nicht in einem Verein regeln.
Das Haustürgespräch.
Genau, dazu kommt er dann. Er hat ja auch einige Absätze dem Campaigning von Gewerkschaften gewidmet. Er ist dafür, Minister zu ahnen. Ich glaube, das wird schwierig durchsetzbar sein, weil dann wird keiner mehr irgendwas entscheiden.
Am Ende haben wir es ja über Mannlegespielt bei Andi Scheuer. Wir können zwar das Geld nicht von ihm zivilrechtlich zurückverlangen, aber dass er im Untersuchungsausschuss gelogen hat, bringt ihn jetzt wahrscheinlich ins Gefängnis.
Kann das sein?
Ja, das kann sehr sein. Die Anklage wurde zugelassen und die wird ja nur zugelassen, wenn es erheblichen Erfolgsmessensspielräume für alle Beteiligten gibt, um das dann auch durchzuziehen. Aber das ist auch wieder eine Umverteilungsfrage. Wer muss hier ins Gefängnis? Die Leute, die schwarz fahren oder die im Parlament sowas machen?
Lustig wäre es schon. Ja, und wenn man dann sieht, wie desolat doch auch dieser bürokratische Apparat ist, ist es ja unglaublich. Also das wusste ich überhaupt nicht. Ich lese mal diese Passage ganz vor. Der Bundestag hatte beschlossen, die Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe zu halbieren, wodurch hunderte Gefangene Monate früher hätten entlassen werden müssen, weil das Justizministerium es jedoch nicht schaffte, seine Software rechtzeitig umzuprogrammieren, bat es um eine Verschiebung der Gesetzesänderung um vier Monate. Menschen blieben also nur deshalb länger im Gefängnis, weil die Verwaltung nicht mit ihrer Software klarkam. Das ist weit mehr als ein peinliches IT-Problem, es ist ein Mangel an Engagement. Offensichtlich war das Schicksal der Inhaftierten den zuständigen Beamten gleichgültig. Hätten sie sich im Sinne der Gerechtigkeit für die Betroffenen engagiert, statt sie als bloßes Beiwerk ihrer Verwaltungsprozesse zu sehen, hätten sie einen anderen Weg gefunden. Und da steckt ja noch mehr drin als eine übliche Bürokratiekritik, sondern er will ja Bürokratie, so schreibt er, im Sinne der Gerechtigkeit, umbauen. Bedeutet eigentlich, dass also die Bürokratie nicht nur ständig mal darüber nachdenken sollte, was ist eigentlich verhältnismäßig. Und dann würde sich das ja schon herausstellen, dass das unsinnig ist, sondern eigentlich bedeutet das auch in gewisser Weise, wenn man also diesen Gerechtigkeitsansatz vertritt und nicht einfach nur Formalien beachtet, dass man dann eine gewisse Politisierung der Bürokratie vornimmt, wo ich also durchaus Vorteile drin sehen könnte. Was natürlich in heißt, dann sind wir auch da wieder stark in Aushandlungsprozessen. Wir wissen ja eh schon bei Richtern, kommt sehr drauf an, wer mehr abschiebt, wer weniger abschiebt und solche Dinge. Das ist ja nicht alles nur neutral und verfahren. Das bedeutet aber hier, und da bin ich gespannt, ob du da auch mitgehst, zu sagen, also Bürokratie muss auch dann einen Ermessensspielraum haben, also der Bürokraten, der Ermessensspielraum der Bürokraten ist dann so groß, dass sie zum Beispiel entscheiden, nee, Vorrang hat folgendes, Softwareprobleme hin oder her.
Also so wie du es jetzt formuliert hast, bin ich natürlich hart dagegen. Ich will ja kein Gnadenrecht einfügen, bei dem der Einzelne, weil er gerade mit einem Sachverhalt zu tun hat, nochmal das Richtige tun kann, auch wenn Arne Semsrott so sehr betont, das Richtige zu tun. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir eine Verwaltung haben, die noch nicht politisiert ist, sondern sie ist ja politisiert, und zwar gegen die Fremden und die Armen. Nur das läuft halt bisher unter absoluter Selbstverständlichkeit, muss niemand mehr erwähnen, wenn der Superreiche im Fernsehen sagt, also mein Verband sieht die und jene Sorge, dann muss die Politik mal was machen, jetzt müssen aber mal die Unternehmensteuern runter. Wird das halt gemacht, weil das so naturgesetzlich fast göttlich vorgegeben ist, während Arne Semsrott hier sagt, nee, das ist doch auch nur eine Verteilungsfrage. Die Nachteile einer Bürokratisierung und die Vorteile kann man ja auch mal umverteilen. Was aber bedeutet, um dazu zu kommen, darf man nicht einfach so bei Instagram eine Meinung haben und hier nochmal Flash gründen, der auch nochmal eine Meinung haben, sondern man muss sich, wie er das ja macht, konkrete Sachverhalte anschauen und sagen, Aber das würde Flash ja tun.
Also ich bin eigentlich für diese Flash-Idee sehr zu haben. Ich frage mich mit Victor Loxen, wie wirksam wäre sie, aber ich finde an sich, dass das das richtige Medium ist, statt sich immer danach auszurichten, was hat gerade die Tagesschau darüber gesagt?
Die Alternative dazu ist, er fragt den Staat selbst, die also sagen, also wir als Redaktion haben jetzt gerade festgestellt, hier liegt etwas im Argen. Und was machen wir? Eine Werbekampagne, um Omer Erner nochmal zu überzeugen oder verklagen wir jetzt den Staat? Und 250 Mal haben sie sich dafür entschieden, den Staat zu verklagen. Und manchmal liegen halt Pointen nahe, wie was du jetzt vorgelesen hast, vier Monate lang sitzen die länger im Gefängnis, ohne Grund, nur weil Bürokratie nicht so schnell kommt, dann sagt er einfach, das kostet pro Person pro Tag 200 Euro. Jetzt können wir einmal durchrechnen und uns fragen, ist das eigentlich sinnvoll? Und dann, finde ich, kann man daraus auch mal eine allgemeine mediale Kommunikation machen, einfach um sich darüber lustig zu machen. Ja, die geht dann entweder real oder nicht. Und wenn nicht, sollte man sich jetzt auch nicht so ärgern darüber. Aber Leute erst mal frei zu kaufen, sanktionsfrei zu organisieren und das halt parallel medial zu begleiten. Immer wieder mit diesem ganz konkreten Kritik, hier Forderung da. Hängt ja immer dran. Da wird ja nicht einfach eine Meinung bekundet, wie so ein Zeitaufmacher, wo meine Altschina, die ich ja immer drauf dränge, zu sagen, wenn ich dir einen Text gebe, sag mir den Anlass und die Kerntese. Und manchmal fällt es der KI wirklich schwer, mir zu erklären, warum die Zeit jetzt gerade diesen und jeden Aufmacher gemacht hat. Und das ist halt hier nicht so.
Eine Pointe noch. Bundestagsabgeordnete haben nicht öffentliche Mail-Adressen. Sie sollten aber nur mit Bedacht genutzt werden. Das Format vorname.name.mbb.at bundestag.de Ja, so viel dazu. Ich möchte eine kleine Stilkritik üben, weil wir viele Bücher gelesen haben aus dem progressiven Lager. Ich möchte einfach zwei Sätze für alle, die jetzt noch wieder ein Buch schreiben. Nicht mehr in einem Buch lesen. Und zwar möchte ich nicht mehr das mit dem Gramsci lesen und den Zeit der Monster, die alte Welt dikt dem Sterben und die neu ist noch nicht geboren. Es hat jetzt jeder einmal gesagt, den Satz. Und ich möchte nicht mehr den Satz hören. Wir können uns eher das Ende der Welt vorstellen als Ende des Kapitalismus zugeschrieben wird. Zier Mark Fischer in anderen Büchern zugeschrieben, auch Slavoj Zizek und Frederick Jameson. Wir kennen jetzt alle den Satz, ist auch nicht schlecht. Aber wir dürfen ihn jetzt wirklich nicht mehr zitieren. Und das kommt nicht im Buch vor, aber deshalb lese ich auch in jedem zweiten Sachbuch, ein Gespenst geht um. Und dann wird der Satz sofort gesetzt, entweder im magischen Sinne oder anders. Bitte unterlassen.
Ich finde noch eine Pointe ganz gut. Also, wenn schon Krise, also wenn wir einfach alle feststellen, wir sind jetzt in einer Krise, muss man sich die Zeit nehmen und kurz für sich und dann auch für andere ausformulieren, wie es besser wäre. Obwohl ich jetzt sehr gesagt habe, wenn wir ja kommunizieren, dann nur, wenn man eine konkrete Kritik, aber eben auch eine konkrete Forderung hat. Also, man muss immer mitformulieren, wie es besser wäre. Und in diesem Klima Kapitel gegen Ende, Kapitel 6, hat er diese Frage eingebaut, wenn Krise ist, muss man wissen, also angenommen morgens Blackout, wer will ich sein in dieser Krise? Mit wem will ich sein in dieser Krise? Wo will ich sein in dieser Krise? Das erlebt man ja immer wieder, dass man so Leute haben, die einfach auch in ihrer Nachbarschaft nicht wissen, wie der Typ am nächsten Kiosk so drauf ist, wer die Nachbarn sind und der ganze Kram. Das kann man nicht erst dann klären, wenn es Gefahr im Verzug ist, sondern das muss man dann vielleicht mal vorbereiten. Was grundsätzlich bedeutet, also es beginnt beim Altenrepubliksthema auch immer wieder, Männer gehen in Rente und stellen fest, meine Arbeitskollegen sind gar nicht meine Freunde. Ich habe ja gar niemanden, außer meine Ehefrau und die ist jetzt genervt von mir. Was mache ich denn jetzt? So, dann wird einfach alles viel zu spät geklärt. Und da würde ich auch sagen, einfach mal in Vereine gehen, alleine damit die Möglichkeit besteht, dass man zum Renteneintritt nicht in eine völlig fremde Welt reinrutscht, jenseits der Arbeitszeit. So, und das ist hier auch. Und allein diese Fragen zu klären, ja, mit wem. Also Urlaub bis ans Lebensende, eigentlich erst mal die Frage mit wem, dann wann, dann wo und so. Das scheint mir doch sehr aus dem Alltag der Leute rausgerutscht zu sein.
Ich sag jetzt abschließend noch ein kritisches und ein positives Element will ich hier vorheben. Folgende Passage steht da kritisch jetzt. Seit Sommer 2025 existiert ein Vorsorgeplan für den Gesundheitssektor, der von der Bundeswehr gemeinsam mit den Berliner Krankenhäusern erarbeitet wurde. Das Land Berlin hielt den Plan geheim, bis fragt den Staat ihn veröffentlichte. Darin findet sich eine brisante Passage. Zitat, eine weitere bislang offene und sehr komplexe Fragestellung betrifft die Triageierung beziehungsweise die Priorisierung von militärischem Personal im Verhältnis zu Zivilisten. Zitat Ende. Offenbar diskutiert die Regierung also darüber, ob Soldaten im Krisenfall vor Zivilisten behandelt werden sollen. Das muss die Öffentlichkeit mitdiskutieren können. Hier sehe ich, dass man sich eine gewisse Illusion über den Staat macht. Und vielleicht liegt das daran, wenn man sich zu sehr auf dieses Zivilgesellschaftliche stützt. Denn der Staat ist schon auch das Kälteste der kalten Ungeheuer, wie Nietzsche sagt. Und das bedeutet natürlich bei diesen z.B. militärischen Fragen, dass man da mit diesem Mitdiskutieren nicht weiterkommt, weil man da gar nicht gebeten wird, mitzudiskutieren. Da mag sein, dass man dann enthüllen kann, dass darüber diskutiert wurde. Aber gerade in diesen Ernstfällen ist es ja der Staat, dann in Form von regierenden Politikern, der Entscheidungen trifft. Und da ist nicht mehr Bürgerrat und Mitbestimmung und irgendetwas. Genauso im Bereich der Aufrüstung, der Wehrpflicht oder sonst was. Und ich glaube, dass man nicht der Illusion erliegen sollte, dass man alles zivilgesellschaftlich auffangen kann, sondern man muss dann schon auch merken, da sind die harten Grenzen. Dann kann man das gut oder schlecht finden. Man kann vielleicht auch in radikale Opposition gehen, was auch immer. Nur man darf sich, glaube ich, nicht der Illusion hingeben, dass das geht, dass man damit diskutiert. Sonst redet man am Ende wie Heinis von der Bundesschülerkonferenz, die sagen, wir wollen bei der Werbpflicht mitreden. Nee, ihr redet halt bei der Werbpflicht nur insofern mit, als ihr auch mal irgendwo auf einem Podium sitzt, aber ihr redet nicht mit im Sinne von mitentscheiden. Das sollte man sich sehr klar machen, dass das eine Illusion ist.
Darf ich was Provokantes dazu sagen? Da das ja ein virulentes Thema ist, was wir jetzt vor allem mit dem Werbpflichtsdiskurs so lange schon mitführen. Mir kommt es manchmal so vor, als ob diejenigen, die derzeit so hart gegen den Staat anreden, gleichzeitig so Staatsfetischisten sind, die es zumindest, wenn auch mit ungedrehten Vorzeichen, faszinierend finden, wie Staats- und Staat eigentlich sein kann. Und gerade in diesem Kontext dieses Buches gegenmacht, oder auch in der Papst Enzyklika, das wir alles nur noch in Krise erleben, also so ein Notfallplan eigentlich abläuft, würde ich sagen, dieses Szenario, dass in Kliniken Soldaten Vorrang haben. In dem Moment, wo wir eine Weltlage haben, in den das greifen könnte, wäre ich mir gar nicht sicher, dass die Ärzte wirklich zur Arbeit fahren. Also dann ist doch, das ist wie die Datencenter.
Aber was sollen sie sonst tun?
Also.
Dann werden sie mit den Feldjägern geholt.
Also, welche Feldjäger? Die sind doch dann im Einsatz. Guck mal, wir planen ja, die Politik plant ja immer für Situationen, bei denen es heißt, wenn eine Atombombe fällt, dann bauen wir die Rechenzentren so, dass sie 7,3 Kilometer auseinander sind. Und dann spiegeln wir die einmal. Und dann überlebt zumindest ein Rechenzentrum. So, wenn der Strom ausfällt, machen wir das und das. Was wir erleben, ist doch, dass die Politik einen Koalitionsvertrag schreibt. Und dann passiert 1000 Kilometer von Deutschland entfernt irgendetwas. Und wir überlegen vielleicht, ob wir mal so 5000 Helme schicken. Und schon ist der Diskurs, ja, keine Pläne gelten jetzt mehr. Man hätte den Koalitionsvertrag neu schreiben müssen. Also in dem Moment, wo in Kliniken überhaupt Soldaten anlanden und andere Patienten noch im Wartezimmer sitzen und man denen sagt, sorry, wir können jetzt leider ihre Bauchspeicheldrüsen-Sache da nicht behandeln, weil hier ist gerade ein Soldat angekommen, der hat jetzt Vorrang. Die Situation kann man gerne so planen und dann steht in Gesetzen drinnen, hat der Soldat Vorrang, nur die Weltlage drumherum sieht doch so aus, dass man vielleicht auch in dem Moment froh wäre, wenn überhaupt noch ein Krankenhaus da ist und so, oder dass mit Strom versorgt wird oder sonstiges. Das kommt für mich immer wieder und es ist jetzt so ein Brückenschlag aus persönlichem Erleben. Sehr häufig, wenn große Sachen anstehen, Urlaubsreisen oder anderes, stehe ich immer neben so Gesprächen, an denen ich eigentlich teilnehmen soll, aber ich kann mich einfach an diesen Gesprächen nicht beteiligen, in denen schon mal geplant wird, was wir dann und dann machen. Und ich weiß ganz genau, wenn wir vor Ort sind und es fehlen drei Regentropfen mehr als das oder die Bushaltestelle ist doch einen Kilometer weiter, dann ist das alles Makulatur. Und das sind für mich so diese typischen, daran kann man jetzt so Argumente draufziehen und so.
Mir ging es jetzt auch gar nicht um den Plan, sondern mir ging es um die Grenzen der Zivilgesellschaft. Zivilgesellschaft funktioniert aber auch und könnte funktionieren, allein schon deshalb, weil man ins Bewusstsein ruft, was einmal möglich war. Zum Beispiel Botschaftsasyl waren durchaus üblich. Das komme ich jetzt hier zu den Positiven. Es gab also Auslandsvertretungen und dort konnte man den Asylantrag wunderbar stellen. Er verweist auf ein anderes Beispiel, wie man Menschen, die fliehen wollen, wie man diese unterstützen kann. Da liefert Cannab da ein Beispiel mit Groups of Five. Hier können private Gruppen als Sponsoren Geflüchtete ins Land holen und verpflichten sich die neuen Kölnlinge mindestens ein Jahr lang finanziell und emotional zu unterstützen. Auch das ist zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement. Er macht auch nochmal ganz klar, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn so von illegaler Migration gesprochen wird. Er nennt das dann mit der Menschenrechtsorganisation Pro Asyl Asyl Darwinismus, der sich einsetzt. Da heißt es jetzt nur, wer den NATO-Draht an den EU-Außengrenzen überwindet oder den Weg über das Mittelmeer überlebt, darf Schutz erhalten. So ist die Richtung. Alle anderen nicht. Das ist die Idee. Das erklärt auch, warum das Gerede der Bundesregierung über die Reduzierung von illegaler oder irregulärer Migration so fatal ist. Gemeint sind nicht etwa Kriminelle, wie der Begriff suggeriert, sondern faktisch alle Geflüchteten. Also man bringt sie in die Not, dass sie erst mal diesen Zaun übersteigen müssen. Sie müssen irgendwie diese Grenzen überwinden oder über das Meer kommen. Damit sind sie aber eigentlich schon irregulär und illegal. Nur dann können sie Asyl beantragen. Zugleich aber sagt man dann, ja, eine illegale Migration wollen wir ja nicht. Also davon eigentlich alle, die dann gekommen sind, wieder abschieben. Und diese Dinge erst mal deutlich zu machen, worum es da eigentlich geht. Und dann aufzuzeigen, wie es anders ginge. Das sind eigentlich dann die wirklichen Glanzlichter, wenn wir von zivilgesellschaftlichem Engagement sprechen.
Ja, wobei das die Zivilgesellschaft nicht hingekriegt hat, Deutschland aus dem Paradeck mal rauszuholen, dass wir natürlich keine EU-Außengrenze haben und deswegen eigentlich gar keinen Asylantrag hier gestellt werden dürfte.
Ja, das Problem nur wiederum bei der Zivilgesellschaft in Bezug auf die Flüchtlinge oder die sogenannte Flüchtlingskrise war ja auch, dass man sich, als man 2015 sich entschied für die Aufnahme von eine Million Geflüchteter, dies eigentlich hauptsächlich der Bürgerarbeit anzuvertrauen, die unentgeltlich stattfand. Das heißt, es wäre da wiederum eine politische Aufgabe gewesen, es nicht der Zivilgesellschaft alleine aufzuhalsen, sondern dann tatsächlich zu sagen, wir versorgen, integrieren, fördern. Wir geben Geld aus und wir wissen, stattdessen hat man Austeritätspolitik scharfgestellt. Also man hat unbezahlte Bürgerarbeit eingefordert. Auf Dauer wurden die dann aber auch nur von wenigen noch geleistet, weil irgendwann sah man, dass man da gegen bürokratische Wände anrannte. Bedeutete also, dass wir hier auch wiederum eine gewisse Grenze der Zivilgesellschaft sehen, wenn die Politik dann nicht eigentlich die Ressourcen zur Verfügung stellt und aus dieser unentgeltlich geleisteten Bürgerarbeit dann etwas anderes macht, nämlich wirklich ein großes integratives Programm.
Also das ist für mich die zentrale Aussage des Textes. Nicht, dass die Politik das hätte mal machen sollen mit dem Flüchtlingeempfang und so.
Nee, das war jetzt mein Wunsch.
Genau, das private Engagement, das es gab, einfach zu finanzieren. Ohne den musste ich hier nochmal die Bürgschaft übernehmen und was auch immer. Das ist ja bei der Familienpolitik dasselbe. Es gibt halt Bereiche, wo sich die Politik nicht programmatisch einmischen darf, was sie aber finanzieren muss. Und da finde ich, ist das Buch ganz stark, auch wenn es nicht so auf den Punkt bringt. Also das ist wirklich mal so als der zitierbare Satz, dass man Felder definiert, in denen man sagt, das lief eigentlich ganz gut, hätten die nur Geld. Und jetzt haben wir einen Staatshaushalt mit einer Billion Euro. Und wo fließt es hin? Ja, nicht dahin. Sondern wir haben ausschließlich die zivilgesellschaftlich der Reichen, die dann ihre 60 Milliarden CO2-Subventionen hier und ihre Unternehmensfinanzierung da und dann nochmal, wenn man im Ausland finanzieren müsste, ihr über einspringen, falls das schief geht und so weiter und so fort. Während überall anders das Geld einfach fehlt. Also in deren Sicht Umverteilungsfragen.
Gegenmacht die Zivilgesellschaft schlägt zurück, heißt das neue Buch von Arne Semsrott, das wir sehr ausführlich im Salon diskutieren. Hier werden Wege aufgezeigt, wie zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement stattfinden kann. Wie man auch eine wirkliche Gegenmacht aufbauen kann. Medial ist das möglich in Bezug auf Migration ist das möglich. Wir bekommen viele Beispiele genannt, aber wir diskutieren auch sehr energisch darüber, ob nicht vielleicht die Zivilgesellschaft hier etwas überhöht wird. Ich melde da zumindest manche Zweifel an.
Ja, wird sie natürlich nicht. Wir müssen nur alles umverteilen in ihrem Sinne. Geld, Bürokratie, Lasten, auch ein bisschen gute Laune. Daran fehlt es ja auch. Die Subareichen sitzen auf ihrem Balkon, trinken Sekt und haben immer gute Laune und alle anderen nicht. Also ein großes Umverteilungsplädoyer, um mal wieder daran zu erinnern, dass es nicht immer nur der Staat, die Politiker, irgendwer verhält sich falsch, sondern nein. Es gibt ja noch die dunkle Masse uns aller. Und die kann man ja mal mobilisieren über eine gute Vision und ganz viel Geld. Wolfgang, du hast dein Buch vorgeschlagen.
Ja.
Es stellt sich heraus, es basiert auf zwei Gutachten für den Bundestag. Also sehr hochspezifische Kommunikation, bei der man jetzt keine Worte auf Literatizität oder wie das heißt, verschwendet.
Ist kein Schmöker.
Sondern man geht direkt rein.
Ja. Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit heißt das Buch von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Christoph Möllers hat diese Gutachten angefertigt. Ein hoch angesehener Professor für öffentliches Recht, der sich mit Fragen der Freiheit innerhalb der demokratischen Ordnung häufig schon auseinandergesetzt hat, publizistisch immer wieder die Öffentlichkeit tritt. Also einer der ganz wichtigen Namen. Wir haben einmal von ihm einen Clip gespielt im Podcast. Erinnere ich jetzt gerade. Kann auch sein, dass wir ein paar gespielt haben schon mal. Aber einen erinnere ich besonders, als er bei Claudine Imke zu Gast war und er dann sagte, ja, gewisserweise findet er doch an der AfD interessant, dass die noch so sehr an die Politik glauben, dass man wirklich mit der Politik so wahnsinnig viel verändern kann.
Ich dachte, das war Blüthorn.
Nee, das war damals Christoph Möllers, der da sich ja gewisserweise amüsiert. Der freut, zeigte natürlich, kein AfD-Anhänger ist ganz im Gegenteil, aber der sagte, es ist ja interessant, dass da noch welche auftreten. Auch Wähler dann da sind, die glauben, ja, wenn gerade die andere Politik, dann wird sich alles ändern. Darum geht es aber jetzt nicht um die Politik und Rechtsruck oder so, sondern es geht tatsächlich um die Kunstfreiheit. Die wird ja hoch geschätzt im Land. Meinungsfreiheit, Kunstfreiheit, auch die Frage braucht man eigentlich beides. Wenn man die Meinungsfreiheit hat, ist da nicht die Kunst mit inkludiert. Na ja, wie ist es aber dann mit Figurenrede, könnte man ja fragen, wenn die das eine oder das andere sagen, ist das auch dann einfach Meinungsfreiheit. Na ja, was in Anführungszeichen steht, könnte ja auch nochmal anders bewertet werden. Das heißt, wir sind also in einem erstmal schon gar nicht so einfachen Gebiet. Besonders schwierig wird es aber jetzt so dadurch, dass wir ja in der Vergangenheit der Ampelregierung, vor allem aber auch der jetzigen Regierung erleben, dass dann gesagt wird, so etwas wie die Documenta 15 darf sich nicht wiederholen. Also, dass dort Werke ausgestellt wurden, von denen manche als antisemitisch eingestuft wurden, von manchen. Ja, also auch da ist man natürlich wieder bei der Frage, ist es so oder nicht? Ich würde bei einigen Werken sagen, sie sind antisemitisch ganz.
Da war die Meinung dann doch einhellig. Also wir sind schon viel näher dran als.
Ja, also bei einigen der Werke war tatsächlich das so. Aber wie geht man dann damit um? Was darf also der Staat machen? Er kann sich vielleicht distanzieren. Ja, aber inwieweit darf er eingreifen? Und wann beschränkt er damit die Kunstfreiheit? Denn die Sache ist ja so, dass auch die Kunstfreiheit, wenn jetzt nicht Volksverhetzung stattfindet, zum Beispiel ja auch antisemitische Kunst in gewisser Weise schützt. Ja, also auch das ist ja interessant, auf wie weit die Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland geht. Ist ja immer wieder erstaunlich, nochmal festzuhalten. Das heißt aber, es gibt ja doch was anderes, wie wenn der Staat plötzlich diese Kunst unterstützt, weil der Staat sich ja zugleich verpflichtet hat mit dem Grundgesetz, dass er gegen Antisemitismus und gegen Rassismus ist. Also er kann ja nicht zum einen antisemitische Kunst fördern und zum anderen sagen, er wendet sich dezidiert gegen Antisemitismus, bekämpft diesen.
Jetzt bist du ja schon sehr tief drin. Ja. Ich versuche nochmal die Fragestellung, die ich hier so interessant fand. Wenn Kunst ist ein Gegenstand, kann man jetzt nicht sagen, Kunst ist eine Sache, die sich nicht von alleine trägt. Kunst muss immer ein bisschen finanziert, kuratiert, vielleicht sogar beauftragt werden, wie auch immer. Manche Kunst erkennt man gar nicht, solange sie nicht wo hängt, wo typischerweise Kunst hängt. Also wir haben einen Künstler. Im besten Fall wird er kuratiert, dann hängt er in eine Ausstellung. Die Ausstellung selbst ist schon eine Organisation, in der also Menschen arbeiten, die sich darum kümmern, dass da Kunstwerke hängen. Wir haben es also hier schon mit einer Treffhaltigkeit zu tun. Jetzt kommt noch die Frage dazu, wer finanziert das? Ist es ein Gebäude, das schon staatlich finanziert ist, aber die Kunstausstellung ist dann eine unter vielen? Oder ist es ein Gebäude, das eigentlich nicht für Kunst gemacht ist, aber dann kommt plötzlich der Staat und fördert, dass man da jetzt Kunst hinhängt, wie bei der Documenta, die findet ja auch auf Plätzen statt, die typischerweise nicht für die Kunst da sind. Und dann ist noch die große Frage, spielt es eine Rolle, wer das finanziert? Wenn der Staat es finanziert, hat er dann besonders Zugriff. Wenn der Staat es nicht finanziert, ist es dann nicht trotzdem Antisemitismus, aber auch noch Kunst. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Text zu tun, der so kompliziert ist. Und na klar, medial aufgeladen durch die Vorfälle, die es gab, die natürlich über Antisemitismus Vorwurf immer eine hohe Attraktivität haben, uns alle erreicht haben. Aber das macht es ja nicht einfacher.
Ja, und die beiden Autoren machen es sich nicht einfach. Sie versuchen auch jetzt nicht einfach zu sagen, ihr ist die Handlungsanweisung, danach müsst ihr euch richten, sondern sie zeigen und man ist erstaunt, wie weit doch geht, wie sehr, also wie weit man gehen kann. Man ist doch erstaunt darüber, denn sie zeigen, der Staat kann sehr wohl sehr viel einfordern, festschreiben, muss aber dann auch darüber nachdenken, wie will er das eigentlich kontrollieren? Wer beaufsichtigt das alles? Die Frage, die die Autoren stellen werden, ist auch, ist das sinnvoll, das zu tun? Ist das verhältnismäßig, das zu tun? Aber wir können hier auch einen Text lesen, der uns sagt, die Verfassung lässt relativ viel zu, was man nicht dann als das Ende der Kunstfreiheit beschreiben kann, weil der Staat diese Möglichkeiten hat, solange er fördernd auftritt. Das bedeutet aber dann auch, dass wir hier einen Text haben, der uns sagt, die Politisierung, all dessen was wird gefördert, wer sitzt in welchen Juries, wer bekommt welchen Preis, dass diese Politisierung vermutlich, auch wenn die Autoren es nicht empfehlen, zunehmen wird. Das heißt, über diese konkreten Fälle, und vor allem geht es ja hier um die tatsächlich dann antisemitisch einzustufenden Werke auf der Documenta, zweigen sich von dort sehr viele Linien ab, die hinführen zu einer Politisierung allgemein, sodass man sagen kann, diese Kämpfe auch in Form von Kulturkämpfen, auch von all dem, was wir jetzt bei Wolfram Weimar ja schon erleben, werden sich eher zuspitzen. Und je mehr Reglement man jetzt eigentlich schaffen will, um dies oder das zu verhindern, wird man also immer mehr diese erbitterten Debatten haben, diese Kulturkämpfe haben. Der Staat kann da sehr weit, beziehungsweise die Politik kann da sehr weit gehen. Man ist echt, ja, in gewisser Weise auch alarmiert durch diesen Text.
Ja, also ja, der Staat kann sehr weit gehen. Aber ich bin erstmal nicht alarmiert, sondern am Anfang habe ich dann doch gedacht, ah ja, stimmt, das ist so eine Sache, die hat man gar nicht auf dem Schirm. Denn es ist ja nicht alles nur Dokumente und Antisemitismus und der Staat hängt dann da so Bilder ab und so, sondern die Besonderheit, die hier beschrieben wird für die Kunst, ist, dass wir eine Kunstlandschaft haben, die in der Bundesrepublik maßgeblich von staatlich eingerichteten Akteuren und Institutionen geprägt und durch öffentliche Mittel finanziert ist. Was jetzt bedeutet, so wie wir es auch schon in die Einflugsschneise gefunden haben, über, da darf der Staat da eingreifen, wie ist das Verhältnis und so. Zentral in diesem Text finde ich, ist auch der Umstand, und den kennen wir so sonst nicht, dass der Staat hier nicht unter, ich greife mal ein, um Gefahren abzuwenden oder Gesetze auch immer durchzubrennen, sondern der Staat kommt in eine besondere Rolle, da er relativ viel Freiheit für Künstler überhaupt erst selbst erschafft. Dadurch, dass sehr viele Einrichtungen einfach in staatlicher Obhut sind, sei es, dass ein Liegenschaft gegeben wird, sei es, dass eine Genehmigung erteilt wird, ja, da dürfte er jetzt ja Pop-Up Kino machen oder so auf der Baustelle, sei es, dass direkt finanziert wird. Und dadurch ist der Staat in einer Rolle, die sich nicht einfach ableiten lässt, aus anderen juristischen Regionen, weil hier nicht so sehr das Verbot, sondern mehr die Ermöglichung im Raum steht.
Und was ist, wenn die Ermöglichung nicht mehr gegeben wird?
Genau. Wir haben verfassungsrechtlich da gar keinen, ich erinnere daran, dass wir einmal, ich habe es schon mal reportiert, im Städel die Kultusministerin aus Baden-Württemberg hatten, die meinte, ja, also da kommen halt so Anträge von verschiedenen Häusern, hier in Frankfurt wäre das das Städel, das würde dann bei uns in Wiesbaden in dem Falle vorstellig werden und dann entscheide ich mit dem Ministerpräsidenten, wie viel Geld es gibt. Richtig. Zwei Leute.
Ja.
So, jetzt ist natürlich zum einen die Gefahr, was ist, wenn die AfD und so, aber das ist ja auch schon ohne AfD, einfach so eine Gemengelage, wo man sich denkt, okay, die beiden entscheiden jetzt über die Freiheitsräume der Kunst, denn wenn die sie nicht geben, gibt sie nicht. Aber sie wurden ja da nicht weggenommen, sondern sozusagen nicht gegeben und da gibt es gar keine verfassungsrechtliche Übung, wie man das als Kampfplatz versteht, weil wenn der Staat das nicht finanziert, ist halt nichts.
Ja und man kann dann verfassungsrechtlich gesehen nicht von Zensur sprechen, denn es wird ja einfach Mittel nicht gegeben, das heißt, etwas wird nicht ermöglicht, aber es wird ja was anderes dafür ermöglicht. Es wird nicht eine Zensur vollzogen. Man kann natürlich jetzt umgangssprachlich trotzdem sagen, es gibt so etwas wie Zensur durch Mittelentzug. Ja, also offenbar gibt es, damit ausgedrückt, wenn ich sowas sagen würde, meine ich, es gibt also politische Ideen, Ideologien, die durchgesetzt werden und die dann die eine Kunst ermöglichen, die andere verunmöglichen. Der Punkt ist aber, wie du sagst, da heißt es dann, der Staat der Leistungen gewährt, auf die im Grundsatz kein individueller Anspruch besteht, sieht sich selten gerichtlich auszufechten, denn Verteilungskonflikte ausgesetzt. Empfangende haben daran kein Interesse, andere Wettbewerber darauf keinen Anspruch. Das heißt, wenn nun jetzt zum Beispiel der Kultursommer Rheinland-Pfalz ist und dort ganz viele Bewerbungen eingehen, welche Projekte gefördert werden sollten, dann gibt es eine Auswahl, die, die nicht gefördert werden, haben keinen Anspruch darauf, zu sagen, ich muss aber gefördert werden, das ist jetzt Zensur. Jetzt als ganz einfaches Beispiel genannt. Und das bringt natürlich die Schwierigkeit mit sich, dass man auch darüber nachdenken muss. Wenn man also für die Kunstfreiheit ist, kann man sich dann ständig nur auf den Staat, sollte man sich die ganze Zeit auf den Staat und damit auf die dann gerade herrschenden Politik verlassen. Für mich ist das auch, auch wenn das gar nicht da thematisiert wird, noch mal ein Text, der darüber fragen lässt, inwieweit kann man noch mal andere finanzielle Spielräume schaffen. Und da kommt das Metsenatentum vor, aber vielleicht auch ein anderes crowdfinanziertes Modell, um andere Kunst möglich zu machen, die dann nicht in dieser Weise politisch abgesegnet werden muss. Aber hier bleiben wir jetzt erstmal bei diesem staatlichen Thema, bei dem sich dann aber auch ganz klar zeigt, der politische Diskurs ist unglaublich dumm. Gerade wenn Politiker zum Beispiel sagen, so etwas wie die Berlinale darf sich nicht wiederholen. Wenn da Preisträger auf der Bühne stehen und dann sagen, es gibt gerade ein Genozid und Deutschland unterstützt Israel bei dem Genozid. Dafür irgendjemanden zur Verantwortung zu ziehen, also zu sagen, die Leiterin ist schuld oder der Kulturminister, der die Leiterin beauftragt hat oder so, ist vollkommener Unsinn. Denn so eine Leiterin, die hat natürlich dann eine Verantwortung gegenüber dem, was sie da auswählt und auch Personen. Aber sie kann nicht schon vorher eigentlich klar bestimmen, was werden die im Falle eines Falles auf irgendeiner Bühne öffentlich sagen. Das heißt, wenn der politische Diskurs so alarmistisch, wie er gerade ist, geführt wird, dann wird es sehr dumm. Und deswegen bin ich froh, dass wir hier so ein sachlich ruhiges, sehr difficiles Buch haben, das ein bisschen Klarheit oder viel Klarheit in eine doch sehr komische Gemenge nagebringt.
Du sagst jetzt Klarheit, wir gehen jetzt natürlich gleich durch, kapitelweise, meine Präferenz, weil er ist ja doch immer sehr zugeschnitten. Aber ich erinnere daran, dass wir mal zum Thema, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, irgendwas Leben und Tod, Gewissensfragen, ach ja, Verjährung von Mord und so weiter. Und dann war die Frage der Deutschlandfunkjournalistin an den Juristen, wie ist das der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln? Und er sagte gar nicht. Und hier gibt es einige Textstellen, die darauf hinweisen, also Kunstfreiheit auch für, klar, antisemitische Kunst. Ist das zu der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln? Nein, gar nicht. Dass etwas auf Festivals passiert und es eine Festivalleitung gibt und man sie aber freisprechen muss davon, was da passiert, weil nämlich der Einzelne auch Rechte hat, um auf einer Bühne einfach eine Dankesrede zu sagen, was er halt sagen will. Das ist, wie wir jetzt gesehen haben, also mir wäre das zu vermitteln, aber sehr vielen Teilen der Öffentlichkeit nicht.
Und leider vielen Politikern auch nicht.
Und vielen Politikern auch nicht, genau. Und so schreiben sie hier auch ganz klar das klassische Verständnis der Grundrechte als Abwehrrechte, die ja relativ häufig nicht gegeben sind, wenn es darum geht, dass der Staat ja was ermöglichen soll, dass, wenn es nicht tut, einfach eine Duldung von nichts ist. Und damit sind wir schon auf ganz jedem Gelände. Also das klassische Verständnis der Grundrechte als Abwehrrechte gegen staatliche Interventionen stößt in diesem Dreieck von der Staat, die Kulturinstitution und die Künstlerin schnell an seine Grenzen. Also auch bei der Frage, wie mächtig ist der Staat? Und wenn wir jetzt die Kunst wieder als Zivilgesellschaft daneben stellen und wir dann wieder sagen, ne, der Staat ist so super mächtig, der kann so viel und so, aber hier wird dann doch relativ viel Freiheit auch den Künstlern gewährt. Die Klammer ist nur, sie brauchen halt Geld und Räume.
Das ist das Ding.
Und damit sind wir aber eben nicht bei Abwehrrechten der Staat, die Polizei darf reinreiten und irgendwas machen und so, sondern da sind wir einfach bei wirtschaftlichen Fragen. Wenn das alles mit Zehntum wäre, das Städte will jetzt sicher zu umstellen, auf Stiftung, jeder darf so mit Geld reinstiften, um auch eine dauerhafte, auch finanzielle, staatsferne Finanzierung herzustellen.
Frankfurt hat ja eh eine sehr finanzkräftige und aber auch kunstliebende Bürgerschaft, wo das ja eine lange Tradition hat. Das ist ja eher die Ausnahme, wenn man sich das für die Bundesrepublik ansieht. Aber das ist ja auch ein Punkt, den ich aus dem Buch mitnehme. Man muss über das Ökonomische sehr sprechen, wenn man über Freiheit sprechen will. Das gilt nicht nur für uns alle, wenn wir sagen, ja, wir sind natürlich frei, aber sind wir auch wirklich im Sinne von ökonomischen Unabhängigkeit, weil diese ökonomische Unabhängigkeit, die wir jetzt zum Beispiel haben, wir müssen jetzt nicht reportieren und hoffen, dass Friede Springer noch einverstanden ist mit uns, sonst lässt sie uns diese ökonomische Freiheit und bringt es natürlich damit, dass man sich auch, was die Meinungsfreiheit anbelangt, viel mehr rausnehmen kann, denn da ist der Staat dann eher nicht gleich zu befürchten, sondern eher, dass ökonomische Repression kommt. Das war ja auch was, was wir bei der Meinungsfreiheit hatten, bei dem Buch von Precht, dass er sagte, wenn die Kosten hoch werden, die Meinung zu äußern, dann wird es ein Problem. Und hier reden wir eigentlich auch sehr viel über Kosten, also müssen wir über das Ökonomische bei der Kunstfreiheit auch sprechen.
Also Kapitel eins. Ja. Die Frage hier ist, wer genießt eigentlich Kunstfreiheit, wenn noch der Künstler immer eine Institution um sich braucht und diese Institution vielleicht sogar noch eine öffentliche Kulturinstitution ist? Und da ist aber die Antwort ganz klar nur der Künstler. Wenn irgendwer hier was administriert oder so, dann denke ich mir auch schon wieder, das ist juristisch hier bei denen so eindeutig und klar, aber durch dieses Bedingungsverhältnis, dass der Künstler überhaupt nur zu seinem, ich sag jetzt mal, künstlerischem Recht kommt, ist es, also da ergibt sich dann doch ein recht hoher, also eine recht hohe Gefahr eingreifen zu können, um Kunst zu verhindern, bevor es um die Kunst geht.
Überbande gespielt.
Überbande, genau.
Denn man kann natürlich sagen, wir sind mit der Personalpolitik im administrativen Bereich, nun befinden wir uns ja da, nicht einverstanden. Wir müssen da eine neue Stelle ausschreiben oder irgendeine Stelle kürzen. Dann sagt man nicht, wir tun das, weil wir eigentlich mit der inhaltlichen Position des Dramatogen oder Regisseurs nicht einverstanden sind. So, und wir machen das einfach so. Dann ist das ein Beschluss der Politik, der vom Gemeinderat beispielsweise gefasst wird, der hinzunehmen ist, weil man sich da im administrativen Bereich aufhält. Wenn der Gemeinderat jetzt sagen würde, die Inszenierung vom Don Giovanni hat uns nicht gefallen, das Bühnenbild soll geändert werden, dann würden die in die Kunstfreiheit eingreifen. Das könnten sie nicht. Aber vielleicht dafür sorgen, dass jener Hausregisseur nicht den Vertrag verlängert bekommt. Das geht schon, dann sind wir auf der administrativen Ebene. Interessant ist ja auch, dass wir gerade bei dieser Ebene, wenn wir mal im Theaterhaus bleiben, sehr häufig den Fall haben, dass administratives und künstlerisches Schaffen zusammen geht. In Frankfurt ist es anders in der Oper. Da haben wir einen Intendanten, der macht nur Administration. Das heißt also, der entscheidet natürlich, welche Künstler kommen und so weiter. Aber der ist zum Beispiel nicht nochmal selbst als Regisseur tätig. In sehr vielen Häusern in Deutschland ist das ja anders. Das heißt, hier gilt einmal, wenn er sich künstlerisch betätigt, die Kunstfreiheit bei dem Intendant, der auch Regie führt, ist er aber Intendant. Als solcher muss er sich in ganz anderer Weise, weil er da administrativ tätig ist, dem staatlichen Unterwerfen, bedeutet er muss zum Beispiel die Haushaltsdisziplin einhalten. Denn wäre nicht diese Trennung da zwischen Administrativen und Kunst, dann müsste man ja auch sagen können, also meine künstlerische Freiheit besteht darin, dass wir einfach in diesem Jahr 5 Millionen mehr ausgeben. Ich brauche das für meinen künstlerischen Werdegang oder was auch immer. Das heißt, es muss diese Trennung geben.
Ganz interessant ist hier, ich kann natürlich jetzt nur rätseln, wie es gemeint ist, aber wir kommen nicht umhin, Institutionen zu sehen. Und wir kennen das aus anderen Bereichen. Also sie nennen die Kirchen, die Universitäten und die Rundfunkanstalten, die durchaus selbst Grundrechtsträger sind. Und entweder ist es eine Forderung oder sie empfehlen das oder wie auch immer, aber im Ergebnis, so wie sei vorweggenommen, also in der späteren Argumentation, dürfen sich sowohl die öffentlichen Kunstinstitutionen als auch die angestellten Künstler auf die Kunstfreiheit des Artikel 5 im Grundgesetz berufen. Also daraus lese ich ja, dass sie es bisher vielleicht noch nicht so dürfen, wie die empfehlen, dass man es ja deswegen ja auch Gutachtenarbeit mal anpassen sollte, um zum Beispiel wie in den Dokumenten, der sie auch sagen, dass sie gescheitert ist. Und die Frage ist dann, warum, woran ist sie genau gescheitert? Dass man hier vielleicht Linien einzieht, von denen ich wieder denke, das wäre aber der Öffentlichkeit schwer zu verkaufen. Denn am Ende würde die Empfehlung ja lauten, ja, das ist schon Antisemitismus, aber deswegen heißt das jetzt nicht, dass die ganze Dokumenta und so weiter, sondern da spannen wir jetzt einen Schutzschirm drüber. Ja.
Hat ein Theater Grundrechtsanspruch? Ausgeschlossen vom Grundrechtsschutz bleiben alle staatlichen Strukturen, die Kunst ermöglichen sollen, ohne selbst künstlerisch tätig zu werden. Zu diesen Träger- und Verwaltungsstrukturen gehören beispielsweise die Kulturstiftung des Bundes und die Kulturstiftung der Länder oder die Organe der Dokumenter GmbH. Diese und vergleichbare Organisationen sind nicht durch die Kunstfreiheit berechtigt, sondern auf sie verpflichtet. Das ist der entscheidende Unterschied. Das heißt, sie dürfen Kunst nicht aus politischen oder ideologischen Gründen steuern, wenn dies dann die Kunstfreiheit verletzt. Das heißt also, sie unterliegen damit erstmal politischen Anweisungen, wenn wir jetzt über die Verwaltungsstruktur reden.
Sie dürfen aber die Kunst nicht illegitim verhindern, wenn ihr Auftrag ist, sie zu organisieren. Also, die verweisen ja hier auch auf Debatten außerhalb Deutschlands, dass diese Frage, also konkret Stadttheater als kommunaler Eigenbetrieb Grundrechtsschutz, in der wissenschaftlichen Debatte lebhaft umstritten und nicht gerichtlich geklärt. Also, ich wusste das nicht, dass das hier so offenes Feld ist.
Offenbar. Und sie betonen ja an mehreren Stellen, dass selbst wenn eine künstlerische Einmischung stattfinden soll, also eigentlich eine Zensur, dann würde man dies selten erleben, dass das direkt ausgeübt wird, sondern man versucht das immer über Bande zu spielen. Was also das Feld sowieso sehr schwierig macht. Also wenn man da sich jetzt mal das ansieht mit einer AfD-Regierung, kann man sich ja denken, was dann alles in Bewegung gesetzt wird.
Du sagst jetzt über Bande und sie nennen ja die Bande, also der Wissenschaftsbetrieb zum Beispiel. Es gibt eine Zitat, anerkannte Ähnlichkeit. Und ich würde sagen, die Wissenschaftsfreiheit war ja mal, also dass Universitäten wirklich machen können, was sie wollen, nur jetzt gehen ja die Länder da auch richtig rein, bis hin zu Personalpolitik und so. Also wenn man jetzt gerade in der Schwäche der Wissenschaft sagt, jetzt ist hier eine Ähnlichkeit gegeben, dann ist das ja für den Kunstbetrieb jetzt auch nicht so verlockend, bald unter die nicht allzu dichten Fittiche der Kulturwissenschafts, also wie wir es bei der Wissenschaft machen zu kommen.
Ja. Um zu diesem Kapitel, Implikation der Kunstfreiheit, zu kommen, da heißt es dann, der Gemeinderat kann nicht beschließen, dass ein Stück vom Spielplan genommen werden soll, aber was möglich ist, ist zum Beispiel, dass man Haushaltsdisziplin einfordert. Also das ist ja etwas, was wir auch immer wieder erleben können an deutschen Theatern, dass dann Intendanten nicht entsprechend wirtschaften. Dann gibt es verschiedene Maßnahmen, die getroffen werden. Dann wird ihnen vielleicht noch ein weiterer Geschäftsführer zur Seite gestellt. Oder sie werden dann nicht verlängert. Oder im schlimmsten Fall werden sie dann vorzeitig entlassen.
Genau. Wir haben keine historisch verwurzelte Selbstverwaltungsstruktur, dass ein Theater einfach sagen kann, haben wir immer so gemacht, muss so weitergehen. Sondern da kann es einfach, und das erleben wir jetzt flächendeckend, von außen passieren, das einfach heißt minus 20 Prozent. Berlin spart jetzt minus 20 Prozent. Also dann haben wir im Rasenmeer drüber gefahren.
Und das ist ein Angriff, sagen wir jetzt hier, wenn wir umgangssprachlich reden, auf die Kunst. So würde ich das auch immer beschreiben. Aber wenn man jetzt verfassungsrechtlich draufblickt, ist das einwandfrei. Also es steht nirgends in der Verfassung, muss mindestens so und so viel Milliarden bekommen oder Kunstfreiheit bedeutet, dass der Staat mit der großen Schöpfkelle durch die Gegend läuft. Das ist alles verfassungsrechtlich gedeckt. Und darum geht es ja in diesem Gutachten.
Und dann haben sie aber, und das finde ich jetzt interessant, die Mephisto-Formel, Herleitung weiß ich gerade nicht so genau, aber es geht um die Frage des...
Es geht um den Roman von Klaus Mann, Mephisto. Ich glaube daraus leitet sich das ab, oder?
Und wie kommt da der angestellte Kulturschaffende als, also wie auch immer, aber der angestellte Kulturschaffende, der also in der Institution, aber nicht mit auf der Bühne, aber so, also es gibt in der Administration Menschen, die dann doch Kunstfreiheit genießen, und zwar auch gegenüber der eigenen Leitung.
Genau, der Kurator und der Museumsdirektor, der Kurator genießt diese Freiheit, der Museumsdirektor muss sie gewährleisten.
Genau, aber an denen wird ja eine Finanznot trotzdem weitergereicht. Ja. Also wenn dem Generalmusikdirektor in der Frankfurter Oper, der ganz klar zum Kunstbetrieb gehört, vom Intendanten, der sich da raushält, gesagt wird, die Stadt finanziert jetzt so viel weniger, dann ist das ja das Durchreichen mit genau diesem, ah, wir fördern nicht mehr. Das hat Einfluss auf den Kulturbetrieb. Also kann dann einfach einen Tag die Woche weniger gespielt werden oder wie auch immer. Die Kulisse ist kleiner. Obwohl da Kunstfreiheit genossen wird.
Ja, um das mal deutlich zu machen. Nehmen wir an, man hat einen Regisseurbeauftragter, der macht ein Stück gegen die CDU Stadtregierung. Ja, wäre ja möglich. Mit sehr vielen Spitzen und der CDU Stadtregierung gefällt das aber jetzt gar nicht. Dann haben die keine Möglichkeit, darauf Einfluss zu nehmen. Was sie aber können, ist quasi sich rechnen über den ökonomischen Weg und bei der nächsten Möglichkeit sagen, das Haus muss 20 Prozent einsparen. Das bekommt der Intendant, der das einfach dann umsetzen muss, der da nicht sagen kann, aber künstlerische Freiheit, bekommt er gesagt. Der kann dann natürlich für sich seine Rückschlüsse ziehen und sagen, oh, ich habe vielleicht durch diesen Regisseur, den ich da hatte, die Politiker so sehr geärgert, dass sie jetzt Mittelkürzungen vornehmen. Aber da das nicht in einem direkten Zusammenhang steht und die Politiker auch genau dies nicht herstellen werden, dann wären sie ja doof, kann natürlich in dieser Weise auf die Kunst Einfluss genommen werden. Verfassungsrechtlich ist das kein Problem. Es heißt hier, der Staat kann grundsätzlich keine Vorgaben zu Programmen oder zur Auswahl von Künstlerinnen in eingerichteten Institutionen wie Theatern oder Museen machen. Etwas anderes gilt, wie sich zeigen wird bei der abstrakteren Planung spezifischer Förderprogramme oder bei der Einstellung von Leitungspersonal. Dazu kommen wir gleich, welche Programme können aufgelegt werden. Aber da sagen die Autoren auch jetzt schon hier in Bezug auf die Gelder, die bewilligt werden oder nicht, sehr viel passiert auf einem informellen Weg. Das heißt, das Rathaus ruft dann auch mal direkt an und fragt nach. Und sie machen das, machen jetzt wieder mit dem Regisseur so ein Stück. Das kann natürlich irgendwie stattfinden, sollte nicht, aber naja, also wir sind die ja wirklich die ganze Zeit in Grauzonen unterwegs.
Im internationalen Vergleich, der im zweiten Kapitel aufgemacht wird, ist es nicht Grauzone, sondern Mittelweg. Ich wusste das nicht in Frankreich, aber da gibt es ein regelrechtiges Verbot der Kulturinstitutionen, wenn sie staatliche Gelder oder wie auch immer, also durch den Staat organisiert sind, gefördert, dass da gar keine Zweigleisigkeit gibt. Außer der Ticketsverkauf wahrscheinlich. Aber da kann jetzt nicht parallel noch ein Mezzäen so ein bisschen rumfingern, während man gleichzeitig in Amerika ausschließlich dieses Mezzäen tun hat, auch in den Kirchen. Das ist ja auch so eine Ferne, weshalb ja die Kirchen selbst mittlerweile zu so Föllefanz-Musical-Veranstaltungsorten werden. Also, wenn man das sich so anschaut, in Frankreich, die Museen, klar, die sind riesengroß und können sich das eben leisten, da einfach Kram zu machen, bis es schief geht, also im Louvre. So. In Amerika alles auf eigene Faust. Und wir sehen ja jetzt gerade die Museen, die vom Staat betrieben werden. Also das Smithsonian ist ja richtig im Einflussgebiet des Weißen Hauses. Also, da werden ja Galerien abgehangen, um nicht zu zeigen, dass hier auch mal nicht weißhäutige Menschen irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt haben. Und da sagen die hier macht Deutschland nicht nur einen Mittelweg, sondern bedient sich aus den besten Sachen beider Welten. Also es ist nach dem Chaos in Kapitel 1, dass man im Grunde nicht so richtig, also man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, im Kunstbetrieb da zu arbeiten, weil man jedes Jahr wieder davon abhängt, dass die nächste Spielzeit oder nach der Landtagswahl nicht alles über den Haufen geworfen wird. Und jetzt heißt es plötzlich, naja, weder sind sie ganz dem Staat ausgeliefert noch. Also man kann immer so hin und her spielen. Und so macht es ja dann auch die Museenlandschaft, dass man versucht, über Friends- und Förderer-Vereine, sich da irgendwie zumindest zur Hälfte auf eigene Füße zu stellen. Ja. Also da fand ich es dann wieder, okay, ja, dann machen wir in Deutschland vielleicht doch nicht so alles ganz falsch und droht immer nur Chaos.
Ja, verankert sich damit ja auch in gewisser Weise in der Zivilgesellschaft dadurch. Sagt damit auch der Politik, ja, wir haben hier aber schon auch Rückhalt, zum Beispiel auch von fördernden Unternehmen oder von Vereinen, die sich gegründet haben zur Unterstützung. Das heißt, so ganz falsch kann ja nicht sein, was wir machen. Also wäre doch auch sinnvoll, dass ihr wiederum seitens des Staates oder Kommune, Land, was auch immer dann eine Unterstützung bietet. Wenn wir jetzt über die Kunstfreiheit sprechen, dann wird zunächst mal gesagt, dass man da es mit einer Auslegung von Mehrdeutigkeit zu tun hat. Es geht natürlich, wenn man über Kunstfreiheit spricht, auch um Persönlichkeitsrechte. Dann wird noch mal das Beispiel des Romans Esra angeführt von Maxim Biller, der nicht publiziert werden durfte, weil die dort porträtierte Frau sehr nahe, sehr sich erkannt fand und dann dagegen geklagt hat. Also ein Roman von Maxim Biller oder auch damals der Fall Mephisto, ein Roman von Klaus Mann, der sich kritisch mit Gustav Gründkens Verhalten im Nationalsozialismus auseinandersetzt.
Ich kenne den Film.
Genau, der sehr, sehr gute Film dazu auch. Und da wird ein wunderbarer Satz zitiert von Rup von Prünek, der damals sagte zu diesem Fall Mephisto, Dies führt zu dem seltsamen und widersprüchlichen Ergebnis, dass dem Autor einerseits der Vorwurf gemacht wird, er habe zu wenig verfremdet. Das heißt, er habe seinen Romanhelden Gründkens zu ähnlich, also zu wirklichkeitsgetreu nachgebildet. Andererseits wird ihm vorgeworfen, er habe zu stark verfremdet, nämlich seinen Helden mit erdichteten negativen Verhaltensweisen und Charakterzügen ausgestattet, die dem Lebensbild von Gründkens nicht entsprechen.
Tja, was machen wir nun?
Das Dilemma ist, glaube ich, klar.
Ja, vor allem das Dilemma ist ja auch, am Ende entscheiden darüber ihr Richter.
Ja.
Also sozusagen, nur als Problem aufzuwerfen, holt es schon raus aus dem Kunstbetrieb. Dann sind erst mal alle Waffen gestreckt und alle warten auf die Verkündung und dann kommt sowas zurück.
Ja, und dann sagen ja auch mancher, sie zitieren ja sehr viel Forschung hier. Oftmals ist es ja so, dass eine halbe Seite der Text ist, der Autoren und der Rest ist dann Fußnote. Und da heißt es ja dann auch, dass manche sagen, ja man braucht dann vielleicht literaturwissenschaftliche Experten, die da nochmal Klarheit einbringen, wo aber dann auch die Autoren darauf verweisen, dass literaturwissenschaftliche Expertise ja gerade häufig dann nicht eine Klarheit bringt, sondern man dann alle Ambivalenzen plötzlich noch deutlicher zutragen getreten hat und eigentlich nicht umhin kommt, als dann irgendeine Entscheidung zu treffen.
Ja genau, also man hat ein Dilemma, ruft deswegen an und dann kommt ein Auslegungs-Dilemma einfach nur zurückgeliefert. Das hilft ja niemandem weiter. In der Hinsicht schwierig. Aber hier muss ich sagen, der Text war mir dann auch zu... Also ich habe mir natürlich Notizen gemacht, ne? Und während ich das so las, dachte ich, das ist eigentlich der typische Text mittlerweile und das finde ich ist auch ein wichtiges Buchgenre, dass man sagt, man gibt einer KI eine Auswertungshilfe, also ein konkretes Anwendungsgebot eines Textes in Bezug auf eine Fragestellung. Also man hat wieder einen Ausstellungsgegenstand, der in einer Sammlung vorkommt, die kuratiert wurde in einem Haus, das staatliche Fördergelder. Also man hat die ganze Kette. Und dann ist dieser Text einfach ganz hervorragend, glaube ich, um Claude zu sagen, finde mir die Argumentation, die dem nahe kommt, in diesem Buch. Was aber für uns Leser, die das einfach von oben nach unten durchlesen, bedeutet, wow, die springen echt zack, zack, zack, zack, durch die Empirie und zeigen dann, was es alles gibt. Aber in dem Moment nützt einem das gar nichts, zu lesen, was es alles gibt. Das ist, wie wenn man durch die Senckenberg Museums Vogelsammlung geht und einfach nur noch hört, ja, die wollten einfach jeden Vogel sammeln damals. Und dann, ah, okay.
Das ist ein Text für Eingeweihte, um das ganz klar zu machen. Der ist ja auch in der Sokamp Wissenschaftsreihe erschienen. Also das ist jetzt nicht so für die Allgemeinheit gedacht. Sie schreiben, wenn sich demokratische Organe dafür entscheiden, bestimmte künstlerische Projekte zu fördern, müssen sie im zweiten Schritt sicherstellen, dass bei der Umsetzung einer solchen Entscheidung kunstimmanente Kriterien zur Anwendung kommen. Also wenn sie A sagen, müssen sie auch B sagen. Sie können dann nicht sagen, jetzt würden wir aber mal überall gerne mitreden.
Also die esthetische Form und ihre Relevanz muss mit betrachtet werden, was ja bedeutet, die Richter müssen in dem Maße auch ein bisschen Künstler, zumindest Kunstpublikum sein, das nicht völlig neu und dann keinen Kontext kennt, also bilden kann, da Ableitung zu finden.
Der Kontext sowieso, das werden wir dann auch an anderen Stellen, ist enorm wichtig. Einfaches Beispiel wäre jetzt, wenn man ein Stück aufhört, das sich kritisch mit dem Nationalsozialismus auseinandersetzt und dort wird jetzt ein HJ-Lied gesungen oder da ist eine Hakenkreuzflagge auf der Bühne, würde man ja nicht sagen, oh, das ist aber ein verbotenes Zeichen, das geht ja nicht, sondern man sagt dann im Rahmen der Kunst, ist das genau gewollt, dass es so da ist. Dann wird es also erkannt und das sind ja dann auch solche Ausnahmen, die gemacht werden bzw. die dann zu Gerichtsprozessen führen können. Manche werden sich erinnern, Jonathan Mese hat ja bei Performances immer mal wieder den Hitler-Cruz gezeigt, hat aber auch zum Beispiel mal auf einer Bühne bei einer Podiumsdiskussion den Cruz gemacht und wurde daraufhin dann verklagt. Dann war eben die Frage, hat Jonathan Mese hier als Bürger diesen Hitler-Cruz gemacht oder war das auch immer Kunst-Performance, wenn Jonathan Mese auftritt? Also das sind dann diese Fragen, die sich stellen. Interessant ist hier noch, wenn es um diese kunstimmanenten Kriterien geht, dass wir da einen Unterschied haben zum Rundfunk. Hier heißt es, es besteht kein verfassungsrechtliches Gebot, gesellschaftliche Gruppen angemessen zu repräsentieren, sondern vielmehr besteht die Pflicht, auch kunstimmanente Kriterien zur Anwendung zu bringen.
Aber trotzdem, und wir haben ja immer nur Zyklen, also alles hat ja immer ein Ablaufdatum, aus der Kunstfreiheit, wenn sie dann einmal festgestellt ist, ergibt sich, das ist nahezu unbestritten, schreiben sie, kein Anspruch auf staatliche Förderung künstlerischer Projekte, auch nicht auf die Fortsetzung einer bereits gewährten Unterstützung. Was ja bedeutet, wenn man tolle Kunst macht und man liegt sogar im Recht damit, dass man sie zeigen darf, dass man damit konfrontieren darf, was auch immer, und dann kommt die Haushaltsentscheidung, muss man trotzdem für gutes Wetter sorgen vorher. Und das ist natürlich eine sehr kunst-eigene Bedrohung, die hier immer mitschwebt.
Also das ist wirkliche Präkarität im Sinne von, der Status ist immer ein Prekärer.
Solange die Finanzierung aber läuft, gelten diese Kunst eminenten Kriterien. Die Politik kann dann nicht einfach sagen, mag sie nicht oder was auch immer, sondern dann aber, das ist eben, wie kommt man zu der Entscheidung, dass man gefördert wird, wenn danach droht, dass man sich doch zu weit davon entfernt, was da eigentlich gefördert werden wollte. Ja.
Die künstlerische Unabhängigkeit von Institutionen, die nicht projektförmig operieren, hängt zum ersten auf von den Laufzeiten der Beschäftigungsverhältnisse ab. Der Staat ist hier durchaus frei, sollte aber im Regelfall beachten, dass die Verwirklichung einer künstlerischen Programmatik einer bestimmten Dauer bedarf. Das heißt aber auch, über die Beendigung eines Vertrages oder Nicht-Fortsetzung kann befunden werden und das ist kein Eingriff auf die Kunstfreiheit. Weiter heißt es, zum zweiten werden Eingriffe in die Kunstfreiheit oft nicht direkt, sondern verdeckt erfolgen namentlich im Gewand der Einhaltung allgemeiner Regeln. Das können wir häufig sehen, wenn man mal so ein bisschen bei Nachtkritik oder so irgendwelche Debatten verfolgt um Theater, dann kommen meistens, wenn da Einwände geltend gemacht werden, immer wieder Verweise auf allgemeine Regeln, die nicht eingehalten wurden, Selten wird ein Politiker so blöde sein und sagen, mir hat die Inszenierung aber nicht gefallen und meiner Frau auch nicht.
Ja, genau, weil am Ende über die Geldsachen entscheidet der administrative Teil, der auf die Kunstfreiheit verpflichtet, aber nicht ihr, nicht auf sie berechtigt ist. Ja, alles so kompliziert. Und damit ist diese Einwanderung, also ich würde jetzt sagen, OK, das allergrößte Problem, nämlich die Finanzierungsfrage, ist für mich hier so geklärt, dass ich das nicht sehr gut finde.
Nee, das ist ein Problem.
Weil man könnte das auch anders organisieren, das hat sie ja damals im Städtl auch, dass man sagt, die Finanzierung von Kunst und Kultur obliegt einem eigens geschaffenen Gremium, das schon allein in der Einsetzung, dem Zeitrhythmus der Politik enthoben ist. Also keiner könnte Wahlkampf machen, wenn wir gewählt werden, weil erst drei Jahre später dieses Gremium wieder zur Debatte steht oder was auch immer. Oder wie bei den Richtern, dass es immer eine Parlamentsentscheidung geben muss für die hohen Richterämter. Und lauter solche Sachen, aber das haben wir alles überhaupt gar nicht. Also es ist einfach diese Geldentscheidung. Von daher, hier fehlt dem Buch auch sozusagen dieser Kommentar zum Thema Geldquelle.
Will das Buch natürlich bewusst nicht leisten, aber ich empfehle das nicht allen zu lesen, weil es zu kompliziert ist und auch zu spezialistisch bestimmt. Aber für Leute, die sich wirklich im Bereich der Kunst aufhalten und darüber nachdenken, was wäre denn eigentlich zu tun. Oder auch so in Bezug auf zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement, eben weil wir jetzt gerade von Arne Semsrott gesprochen haben, ist es eine sehr dringend notwendige Lektüre, weil sich genau dann solche Fragen ergeben und möglicherweise muss man andere Antworten finden.
Diese Demokratieprojekte, die jetzt zur Disposition stehen, werden genau so finanziert. Das sind im Grunde Kunstprojekte.
Ja, so muss man es begreifen, ja. Das kann man also wunderbar übertragen. Dann Kapitel zur Eingriffsverwaltung.
Da sagen wir kurz, es gibt die Eingriffsverwaltung. Das nächste Kapitel ist dann die Leistungsverwaltung. Da wird also genau die Differenz gemacht zwischen die Eingriffsverwaltung ist die, die sozusagen, so wie wir es immer, oder also wirklich eingreift, während die Leistungsverwaltung dieses Paradoxe, wie vorhin schon, erst dadurch, dass sie fördern, gestalten sie mit. Ja, also wir haben hier zwei Sachen. Zum einen bei der Eingriffsverwaltung. Also dass der Staat eingreift, das macht er im Straßen und Verkehr auch. Also hier haben wir noch eine relativ hohe Nähe. So insgesamt zu Gefahr im Vollzug. Ja, also wenn jemand von einem antisemitischen Werk oder einem sitenwidrigen Werk oder was auch immer, dann darf durchaus die Polizei da mal rein und schon mal für Klarheit sorgen, auch wenn es danach noch debattiert und vielleicht auch rückgängig gemacht wird. Also Revisionen sind da schon möglich. Aber hier geht es um die Eingriffe des Staates. Und was meistens unter dem großen Interesse läuft, wenn der Staat nämlich dann mal eine Demo auflöst, in dem Gebiet oder hier ein Museum abriegelt oder sich sonst da einmischt.
Dabei wird unterschieden, weil das immer jetzt so im politischen Diskurs oder mit dem medialen Diskurs zusammengebracht wird, zwischen Dokumenta und Berlinale. Bei der Dokumenta sprechen wir davon, dass wir dort Werke hatten, die als antisemitisch eingestuft wurden von Experten auch und man hat auch eine Allgemeinheit gefunden, die das so sieht. Kurz und gut, wir hatten da zum Teil Werke, die Juden als Schweine gemalt haben. Dann glaube ich, muss man jetzt nicht allzu lange darüber diskutieren, wie das wohl einzuordnen ist.
Ja, die allerdings, das muss man dann dazu sagen, nur in Deutschland als antisemitisch gelten, wären sie woanders auf der Welt natürlich schon ausgestellt wurden.
In Indonesien war das Beispiel. So, und das ist aber so, also dass wir unterschiedliche nationalstaatliche Regeln haben. Das haben wir aber auch in Bezug auf sexuelle Darstellungen oder so. Da können wir das auch finden. Jetzt der Unterschied Berlinale Dokumenta. In einem Satz ganz klar benannt, die Intendantin der Berlinale verantwortet die eingeladenen Filme. Das heißt, wählt sie antisemitische Filme aus, dann muss man sie fragen, also hören Sie, was machen Sie da eigentlich? Die Sache ist aber, der Satz geht weiter, die Intendantin der Berlinale verantwortet die eingeladenen Filme. Aber nicht mehr die Dankesrede eines preisgekrönten Regisseurs.
Der hat ja eigene Rechte.
Die ich jetzt ohnehin nicht als antisemitisch auffassen würde, aber die hat dem Staatsräson Gedanken widersprochen. Aber das ist unsinnig. Bei der Dokumenta ist es ja so, dass man dort diese indonesische Gruppe hatte, die die Leitung quasi wiederum an eine andere Leitung delegiert hat. Also das war so eine doppelte Delegation, die da stattgefunden hat. Aber die Auswahl der Künstler und der Werke unterliegt dann schon der künstlerischen Verantwortung. Die Politik, wenn sie jetzt in künstlerischen Fragen interveniert, handelt sich damit aber auch eine Verantwortung ein, die sie eigentlich gar nicht übernehmen müsste. Nämlich, was hier deutlich gemacht wird, sobald die Politik auch einschreitet, sagt sie, ach so, wir sind jetzt auch hierfür das Künstlerische zuständig. Und das müsste die Politik eigentlich so gar nicht tun. Das heißt, die Politik selbst gerät in ein Dilemma, wenn sie dort hineingeht.
Oder dürfte es vielleicht gar nicht tun.
Oder dürfte es.
Also der Text ist ja hier doch recht deutlich. Der prominente Platz, den der Kampf gegen Antisemitismus in Deutschland einnimmt, ist weniger verfassungsrechtlich als politisch gegeben. Also die Politik macht halt Sachen. Was ich ja auch immer kritisiere, Steinmeier als große Hassfigur macht dann ne große Rede zum Antisemitismus und motiviert im Grunde alle seine Gegner, Antisemiten zu werden. Also ist auch unter den sozialen Gegebenheiten mal problematisch. Und dann schreiben sie ganz deutlich, antisemitische Kunst ist Kunst. Und wird daher von Artikel 5 Absatz 3 Grundgesetz geschützt. Das muss man ja auch erst mal verdauen, so als Kulturkampfminister, dass man da vielleicht...
Und das gilt ja auch, was wir jetzt bei den Zeitschriften haben, mit Jürgen Els ist das kompakt. Man ist erstaunt, wie viel in Deutschland dann doch gesagt werden kann, was erstmal von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt ist. Wir hatten mal so ein Clip, glaube ich, von Wolfgang Ambos, der bei Markus Lanz saß und dann sagte, welch rechtsradikale Positionen durchaus einfach unter Meinungsfreiheit fallen. Die Sache ist nur, dass das Grundgesetz auch Menschen vor Diskriminierung schützt, also zum Beispiel vor antisemitischen Anfeindungen. Und deshalb darf der Staat natürlich nicht gezielt antisemitische Kunst fördern. Das heißt, nur weil die Kunstfreiheit gilt für auch ein Kunstwerk, das man als antisemitisch bezeichnen kann, kann der Staat dann nicht sagen, genau, dann fördern wir das. Oder könnte, also das Obskursste wäre es, wenn der Staat eine Ausschreibung machen würde, in dem steht, wir wünschen uns zehn neue antisemitische Gemälde für das Rathaus. Und zugleich kämpfen wir gegen Antisemitismus. Das geht nicht. So, jetzt aber nochmal zu diesem Staatsräson Gedanke. Wenn die drei letzten Bundesregierung eine besondere historische Verpflichtung der Bundesrepublik gegenüber dem Staat Israel formulieren, dann wird eine solche außenpolitische Entscheidung auch nicht dadurch in Verfassungsrang gehoben, dass die Anerkennung des Existenzrechts Israels als Staatsräson bezeichnet wird. Denn die Bundesregierung kann sich nicht des vorrechtsstaatlichen Begriffs der Staatsräson bedienen, um sich von Bedingungen zu befreien und eine kalte materielle Verfassungsänderung zu bewirken. Wenn man das will, dann muss man das mit Verfassungsänderungen, weiß-oder-ich, muss man irgendwo hingehen. Aber man kann nicht sagen, wir rufen das jetzt einfach aus. Deswegen sind auch diese Anti-Antisemitismus-Beschlüsse, die von Parlamenten dort stattgefunden haben, auch vom Bundestag, keine Gesetzesbeschlüsse. Das muss einem klar sein.
Genau, das sind parlamentarische Meinungen.
Ja, das sind Meinungsäußerungen. Aber sie sagen natürlich auch, dass die eine Wirkung haben. Das sieht man dann auch, dass manche Künstler ausgeladen wurden, weil man zum Beispiel auch so was Diffuses angab, wie eine Nähe zu BDS, also zu dem Boykott Israel, was ist das, eine Verein, eine Organisation oder eine Bewegung, ja. Aber eine Nähe ist nun jetzt keine hinreichende Begründung. Und die Autoren verweisen natürlich darauf, dass diese Meinungsbekundungen von Parlamenten natürlich einen Chilling-Effekt haben, also einen Abschreckungseffekt haben können. Obwohl das Bundesverwaltungsgericht diesen Aspekt nicht ansprechen musste, ist nicht auszuschließen, dass solche Beschlüsse, insbesondere wenn sie nicht nur politische Überzeugungen zum Ausdruck bringen, sondern mit konkreten Aufforderungen, die einen unter den Bindungsleitenden Charakter beanspruchen, auch für sich gegen Grundrechte verstoßen können. Denn auch wenn sie keine rechtliche Bindungswirkung haben, verleiht die politische Herausgehobenheit und die Befugnis des Parlaments als Gesetzgeber dessen Beschlüssen eine Wirkung, die sich auch zu einem faktischen Grundrechtseingriff verdichten kann. Also das ist dann die Frage, ob man, wenn man so vehement plötzlich eine parlamentarische Meinung begründet, ob man da nicht doch sagen kann, naja, also eigentlich ist das schon verfassungswidrig, dass ihr glaubt, so hart da eingreifen zu können. Fest steht, es ist eine politische Entscheidung, genauso wie es auch eine politische Entscheidung ist, Antisemitismus und Rassismus in der deutschen Kulturlandschaft entgegenzutreten. Aber es bleibt dann mal eine politische Entscheidung.
Also ich habe es mir hier so in drei Sprüngen rausgeschrieben. Zum einen, der Staat darf nicht fördern, wenn zum Beispiel Antisemitismus oder Volksverhetzung oder sowas droht. Denn weder darf der Staat das selbst, ist ja klar, aber er darf auch nicht private als Werkzeug einsetzen. Was ja bedeutet, falls mal die AfD da ans Ruder kommt, kann sie das nicht einfach fördern. Das sind keine da geltenden Regeln. Wenn aber der Förderbescheid einmal erteilt ist, ist es ganz schwer im Nachhinein staatlich wieder rechtlich zu beschränken. Was eben bedeutet, in dem Moment, wo man diese Gefahr sieht, dass ein vorher gefördertes Projekt da aus dem Ruder läuft, kann der Staat diese politischen Äußerungen des Parlaments als Parlamentsbeschluss vorlegen. Aber, und das schreiben sie ja nicht, das sind eben schlichte Parlamentsbeschlüsse, ohne normative Bindungswirkung. Ja. Und das muss man sich doch erstmal, also das ist ja völlig... Ja.
Also ein Unterschied ist, wenn jetzt Kunstwerke einen Straftatbestand darstellen, dann kommt die Polizei und... Man könnte ja jetzt auch von dem Antisemitismus-Thema weggehen, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Darstellung von Minderjährigen, die einen Straftatbestand darstellen, aufhängen würde, dann darf da die Polizei einschreiten. Aber wenn es nicht diesen Straftatbestand gibt, dann nicht. Da heißt es, der Staat wird seiner Pflicht, antisemitische Äußerungen nicht zu fördern, dadurch gerecht, dass er sich von ihnen distanziert. Das heißt, hat so etwas dann stattgefunden, ist da ein solches Werk aufgehangen und kann der Staat sagen, ich mache das, wir distanzieren uns davon. Wenn gleich er finanziell tatsächlich gefördert hat, bleibt ihm ein anschließendes Einschreiten verwehrt. Hier zeigt sich ganz konkret der Konflikt zwischen der Kunstfreiheit und dem verfassungsrechtlichen Diskriminierungsverbot.
Ja, also wenn die Polizei kommt und wegen, so wie sie es hier schreiben, ähm, wie heißt es? Volksverhetzung einschreitet, dann wird immer mit Schutzbereichen argumentiert und er sagt, naja, das ist so eine Gefahr im Vollzug, aber es ist ja niemand, der jetzt ernsthaft an Leib und Leben geht und damit rutschen die Sachen später immer in Abwägung. Also aus den Schutzbereichen raus in Abwägung. Was bedeutet, in dem Moment, wo der Staat, ob er selber gefördert hat oder nicht, da eingreift und es wird aber von den Gerichten als naja gut, das ist jetzt nicht weiter zu klären, sondern es wird gesehen, das ist ein Kunst- und Kulturbereich. Dann ist der Staat, da bindet sich dann sozusagen eine Diskussion ans Bein. Ja. Er kann nicht einfach sagen, die Polizei hat das schon richtig gemacht und so, sondern dann wird abgewogen. Und dann hat man genau den Scheiß wie überall. Also dass der Kulturkampfminister derzeit überall Kämpfe ausführt, ja, ist genau das. Berlinale, ah nee, kann er gar nicht abberufen, was auch immer und so.
Aber man probiert mal.
Buchhandlung, ah kann er gar nicht schließen und so. Und dann geht alles los. Also in erster Sicht kann auch die Kulturkampfminister hier noch mal lesen und seine Mitarbeiter, wo ist eigentlich, wo die Tretmin.
Es ist ein kleines Handbuch zur Mäßigung, würde ich mal behaupten.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen.
Ganz toll fand ich die Formulierung der freiheitliche Skandal. Denn dieses Buch ist natürlich reich an juristischen Formulierungen und mitunter kämpft man sich durch. Aber das ist eine so tolle Formulierung, ich will es vorlesen. Die Freiheit der Kunst kann auch in Fällen rassistischer und antisemitischer Inhalte vor staatlichen Zugriffen schützen. Die Freiheit der Kunst kann also einen schützen, auch wenn die Inhalte rassistisch antisemitisch sind. Das ist der freiheitliche Skandal der grundgesetzlichen Ordnung. Doch kann die staatliche Kulturverwaltung die Pflicht treffen, mit der künstlerischen Seite das Gespräch zu suchen und sich öffentlich zu distanzieren. Direkte Eingriffe in künstlerische Vorgänge sind, wenn die Strafbarkeitsgrenze nicht überschritten ist, nicht zu rechtfertigen. Und Skandal meint hier eigentlich das Positive oder das, was uns jetzt erschüttert oder uns so anspringt. Aha, das ist also auch von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt. Das ist der freiheitliche Skandal, dass das beides so zusammengeht und dass der Staat dann Möglichkeiten der Distanzierung, aber nicht der wirklichen Zensur hat. Und das ist sehr schön auf den Punkt gebracht.
Ja, die einzig verfassungsrechtliche Pflicht des Staates ist Antisemitismus und Rassismus, wie sie schreiben, zumindest nicht zu fördern.
Ja, ja.
Das ist natürlich sehr schön um die Ecke. Genauso wie sie auch schön formulieren, dass Theater und Museen keine Stadtteilen sind. Weil in eine Stadtteile kann ja jeder reingehen und dort einfach sagen, ich mache hier mit, egal was hier ist, ein Flohmarkt oder so. Und das gilt ja für Orte, denen eine Kuration vorausgeht, nicht. Weshalb man jetzt Anhängern von, wie sie hier schreiben, der BDS, also Anhängern, dass man denen das verwehren darf, allein weil man grundsätzlich verwehren darf. Also hier ist auch wieder eine Einflugsschneise, jenseits von Geld zu sagen, es ist ja ein öffentlicher Raum, aber es ist nicht so öffentlich. Du darfst nur auf Publikumseite durch die Hallen gehen, aber du darfst jetzt nicht hier Bilder aufhängen.
Ja. Kommen wir zu der Leistungsverwaltung.
Ja, das ist ja das Knifflige, was sie oben schon markiert haben als, was ist, wenn der Staat einfach förderbescheide nicht, also wie geht man da juristisch gegen vor, wenn man glaubt, man sei hier benachteiligt worden. Und ich finde nicht, dass es jetzt Lösung gibt für diese Probleme, von denen ich so denke, die sollte man da mal irgendwie. Also sie sehen jetzt keine diese Ideen von Gremien hier, Geldtöpfe da oder so demokratische Öffnungen. Würde ich sagen, ist jetzt nichts im Text.
Nee, das ist überhaupt nicht vorzufinden.
Aber schön, dass sie das Problem nochmal so beschreiben.
Da geht es ja um die Frage auch, was kann also für eine Projektförderung als Leistung eingeschrieben werden? Da wird zum Beispiel genannt, die schleswig-holsteinische Regierungsfraktion brachte im Juli 2024 einen Gesetzentwurf in den Landtag ein, dem zufolge die Landeshals-Halsordnung, die Behörden ermächtigen soll, Zuwendungen nur unter der Voraussetzung zu gewähren, dass der Zuwendungsempfänger erklärt, sich zu einer vielfältigen Gesellschaft zu bekennen, sich gegen jedwede Diskriminierung zu stellen und jede Form von Antisemitismus abzulehnen. In Berlin sollten Zuwendungsbescheide um eine Klausel ergänzt werden, die die Zuwendungsempfängerin darauf verpflichtet, sich gegen israelbezogenen Antisemitismus zu stellen. Die Stadt Leipzig wollte wieder was anderes. Was hier erst mal festgehalten wird, ist, dass diese Art der Maßnahmen der Leistungsverwaltung tendenziell einen illiberalen Charakter tragen, weil man damit Bekenntnisse abfordert. Und kunstfremde Kriterien spielen plötzlich eine größere Rolle. Und sie spielen aber auch, sagen die Autoren, durchaus eine Rolle bei der Vergabe von Mitteln. Zudem gibt es natürlich auch Programmatiken, zum Beispiel von Museen, die sich dem Kampf gegen oder für etwas widmen. Oder auch zum Beispiel solche Kulturfestivals, die unter einem Motto stehen und dann häufig auch unter einer Programmatik.
Also wie sie es schreiben, punktuell finde ich sehr gut, auch wenn ich den Scope dann nicht sehe insgesamt. Aber das Grundgesetz baut zwar auf der Erwartung auf, dass die Bürger die allgemeinen Werte der Verfassung akzeptieren und verwirklichen. Er zwingt diese Wertelojalität aber nicht. Zum einen. Und dann, und es ist, also ich lese mal vor, wie es hier steht, verlangt der Staat ein Bekenntnis gegen jede Form von Antisemitismus, gemäß der IHRA-Definition, auf die man sich ja so global geeinigt hat, obwohl wir jetzt auch wissen, das war halt auch ein Vorschlag von so einem Wissenschaftler, der mal so, dann hat man sich bei sich dran, ja, verpflichtet er Private auf eine wissenschaftlich umstrittene Meinung, Zitat, die Adressaten werden genötig zu behaupten, für wahrzuhalten, was sie wissenschaftlich für falsch halten. Solch eine Pflicht ist verfassungswidrig. Ja. Also man kann genau die Definition, die im Bundestag immer ganz virulent ist, weil sich keiner traut, davon abzuweichen, ja, nicht abverlangen, weil es verfassungswidrig wäre, wie die beiden hier schreiben. Ja. Und das ist natürlich unter diesem Bekenntnis, pornografischen Einflug, den hier gerade alle so ein bisschen probieren. Das ist schon, also hier ist ja wirklich, also wird ja weirischer Kontrapunkt gesetzt. Gegen den Lauf der Dinge.
Wer ein ausdrückliches Bekenntnis gegen Rassismus und Antisemitismus abzugeben, verpflichtet ist, um die staatliche Kunstförderung zu erhalten, muss seine innere Einstellung preisgeben. Der Staat zielt darauf, solche Künstler nicht zu fördern, die eine antisemitische oder rassistische Einstellung haben. Dies stellt er sicher, indem er die Förderung unter die Bedingungen stellt, sich gegen Antisemitismus und Rassismus zu bekennen. Der Begriff der Bedingung ist dabei tendenziell irreführend. Es handelt sich nicht um eine Bedingung im Sinne von Nebenbestimmung, sondern um die Voraussetzung eines erfolgreichen Förderantrags. Bedingungen und Voraussetzungen sind juristisch nicht dasselbe.
Genau, und die Alternative wäre hier einfach zu sagen, wir binden einen Förderbescheid daran, dass du dich nicht antisemitisch äußerst. Also, der geht dann nicht auf die inneren Überzeugungen und Abwägungen aus wissenschaftlicher Wahrheit, die man und so weiter, sondern da geht es ja nur darum im Rahmen der geförderten Arbeit, was sehr vielen Leuten, glaube ich, sehr leicht viele, das zu unterschreiben. Aber so, wie es derzeit gehandhabt wird, ist es halt wirklich absurd und, wie wir jetzt wissen, verfassungswidrig.
Ja, und auch gibt es ja noch ein europäisches Antidiskriminierungsrecht, das kommt ja dann auch noch damit rein, da heißt es, zielt der Gesetzgeber durch eine Ermächtigung zur Einfügung einer Bekenntnisklausel, darauf ab, Personen von der Förderung auszuschließen, die antisemitische oder anderweitig rassistische Einstellungen hegen, können sich Grenzen aus dem europäischen Antidiskriminierungsrecht ergeben. Die sogenannte Rahmenrichtlinie untersagt Diskriminierung unter anderem wegen der Weltanschauung. Sie regelt das Diskriminierungsverbot im Arbeitsleben. Also spielt das dann plötzlich rein, was da politisch so ad hoc mal gefordert wird, hat doch einige Konsequenzen. Die Frage ist dann ja, wie politisch ist das dann alles, beziehungsweise ja, alles ist politisch, ist schon die Antwort. Denn die Frage ist ja auch, was definiert man dann wie? So kommen sie ja darauf zu sprechen, dass es von der Bundesregierung eine Einigung 2017 gab auf diese IHRA, ihrer Definition von Antisemitismus. Aber das war im Zusammenhang mit deutscher Vergangenheitspolitik und auch mit außenpolitischen Implikationen. Überträgt man jetzt also diese Antisemitismus-Definition auf alles, wohin führt das dann hinaus? Da heißt es hinsichtlich der Geeignetheit, scheint eine Definition, die den israelbezogenen Antisemitismus ausdrücklich umfasst, auf den ersten Blick den Zweck zu erreichen, eben einen israelbezogenen Antisemitismus zu bekämpfen. Doch verfährt diese Argumentation zirkelschlüssig, setzt sie doch gerade eine Stellungnahme in der wissenschaftlichen Debatte und den Begriff des Antisemitismus voraus. Selbstverständlich darf der Staat in einer wissenschaftlichen Debatte eine Stellung beziehen und muss dies manchmal auch. Doch hier verpflichtet der Privatperson, sich eine wissenschaftlich umstrittene Meinung zu eigen zu machen. Und das ist dann eine Frage der Verhältnismäßigkeit. Kann man jemandem Lehrmeinungen aufzwingen?
Genau. Sie werben hier auch dafür, dass man ja auch vertrauen könnte, dass geförderte Institutionen und Personen nicht ständig dem Staat was Schlechtes wollen und man sich gegen Antisemitismus bei ihnen versichern möchte, mit inneren Bekenntnissen. Deshalb hier auch so ein schöner Satz steht, auch in der Rechtspolitik ist gut gemeint das Gegenteil von Kunst.
Ja.
Ich sag gut.
Das ist ja schön. Jetzt mal noch zu dieser Frage, die Verpflichtung zu irgendetwas. Inwieweit ist das ein Eingriff auf die Kunstwahl? Möllers räumt ja zunächst ein, dass eine solche gesetzliche Vorgabe überhaupt den Schutzbereich der Kunstfreiheit berührt. Also das muss man erstmal festhalten. Und die öffentlichen Kulturinstitutionen besitzen dann eine funktionale Kunstfreiheit. Das heißt, sie sind nicht einfach wie normale Behörden zu behandeln. Und deshalb überhaupt kann man dann von so einem Eingriff sprechen, weil man sie offenbar anders behandelt. Da heißt es dann, der Gesetzgeber trifft mit einer solchen Entscheidung keine spezifischen Programmenentscheidungen über einen Spielplan oder ein Ausstellungsprogramm. Also hier heißt es, es gibt eine allgemeine Zielvorgabe vielleicht in einem Förderprojekt. Aber das ist dann nicht ein Eingriff in die konkrete Programmsteuerung. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein Festival organisiere, das heißt Unsere Schöne Kultur in Frankfurt, und schreibe in die Programmatik die Zielvorgabe rein, dieses Festival will dezidiert Antisemitismus und Rassismus bekämpfen, dann habe ich damit keine konkrete Programmsteuerung vorgenommen. Denn dann obliegt es den Angestellten für dieses Festival immer noch, diese oder jene einzuladen. Das sind doch nicht Leute, die dieser Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus und Rassismus im Wege stünden.
Ja, was die beiden natürlich nicht machen, weil es dem Charakter des Textes widerspricht, aber es gibt eine historische Erfahrung, auf die wir nachher bei Stefan Kühl zu sprechen kommen. Der Staat musste ja in der Nachkriegszeit eine Verwaltung aufbauen, die in einem demokratischen Gefüge stattfindet. Und das Einzige, was man sicher wusste, ist, alles Nazis. So, wie hat man das gemacht? Man hat den Leuten einfach gesagt, das ist die Vorgabe. Wenn du dich daran hältst, ist uns alles weitere egal. Aber wenn du durchscheinen lässt, dass du es doch anders besser mögst, dann gibt es hier keine Karriere, kein Budget und kein Dings. Und das hat die Leute sehr diszipliniert. Und hier steht ja dieser Satz drin, die Künstlerin dürfte sich weiterhin privat antisemitisch, also wohlgemerkt nicht in strafbarer Weise äußern, sobald sie jedoch als staatsstaatlicherseits geförderter Künstlerin auftritt, muss sie Zurückhaltung wahren. Was ja bedeutet, und das kommt mir sehr entgegen, jenseits des Bewusstseins der echten Einsicht, wo man eine innere Bekenntnis ablegt, was halt verfassungswidrig wäre, kann man ja einen Rahmen schaffen, in dem der Staat sich dann doch relativ absichern kann, dass es hier im Rahmen des Verfassungsrechtes zugeht. So. Nur statt das positiv zu beschreiben, schreibt er vorher eine Negativliste, was man alles nicht darf. So. Das heißt, der Staat unter dem, also es ist ja wirklich ein super Paradox, dass er zum einen fördert und damit Aufmerksamkeit legt und gleichzeitig aber eine Liste von Themen mitliefert, die genau diesem, worauf man Aufmerksamkeit legen möchte, widerspricht. Also der Staat kommt die ganze Zeit mit. Wir sind voll für die Demokratie und deswegen reden wir jetzt erst mal über Antisemitismus und Nerven alle. Weil Kunst darf nämlich keine Freude machen und Kunst darf auch niemals ohne Antisemitismus betont werden. Und so steht einfach jedes staatlich geförderte Kunstprojekt immer im Kontext von Antisemitismus. Und das ist natürlich dumm.
Sie sprechen ja davon, dass diese Programmsteuerung, die stattfindet, die verfassungsrechtlich einwandfrei ist, zu einem Kontrollprogramm führen könnte.
Genau.
Es heißt da, es ist auch nicht zu bestreiten, dass diese Grenzziehung vage und missbrauchsanfällig ist. Sie lädt zu politischer Einflussnahme ein. Sie gibt dem politischen Prozess die Gelegenheit, Grenzen auszutesten und eine Praxis der Freiheit und des Vertrauens durch eine der Kontrolle und des politischen Misstrauens zu ersetzen. Mit anderen Worten Wolfram Weimar.
Das ändert rechtlich aber nichts daran, dass die Spielräume, die der demokratische Prozess bei der Verbindung von Zwecken der Kulturförderung mit anderen Zwecken hat, durch den funktional geschützten Grundrechtsstatus der öffentlichen Kulturinstitutionen nicht aufgehoben werden. Wenn der Gesetzgeber die Möglichkeit hat, andere als reine Kunstinstitutionen zu errichten, dann hat er auch die Möglichkeit, die Arbeit von Kunstinstitutionen auf andere Zwecke festzulegen. Das heißt, wenn man solche Programmatiken dann in Anschlag bringen will, dann kann man das. Das bedeutet jetzt, wenn wir mal vom Thema Antisemitismus weggehen und sagen, eine AfD-Regierung macht jetzt Förderprogrammatiken, die so aussehen, dass sie sagen, es muss das deutsche Liedgut, überhaupt die deutsche Kultur und vor allem die des 19. Jahrhunderts hervorgehoben werden und gestärkt werden und alles, was sich kritisch mit einem Nationalismus auseinandersetzt, ist nicht zu fördern, dann ist das verfassungsrechtlich möglich. So wäre jetzt meine Interpretation des Ganzen. Wir sehen also, wohin das alles so führen kann. Die Sache, die jetzt hier Möllers und Weinberg ja auch deutlich machen, ist, wie will man es umsetzen? Das heißt, man braucht ja, wenn man so ein Kontrollprogramm hat, auch Kontrolleure. Und da sprechen sie über die Vollziehbarkeit und stellen fest, dass hier sehr viele beträchtliche, schreiben sie beträchtliche, nachgelagerte Kontrolle droht und auch ein nachvollziehbares Unbehagen sicherlich da eintritt. Dass man dieses Unbehagen dadurch vertreibt, dass die Vollzugsprobleme unerwähnt bleiben, ist nur aus politischer Logik zu erklären. Wenn man umgekehrt nicht bereit ist, eine Regel durchzusetzen, sollte man sich Rechenschaft darüber ablegen können, warum man sie verrechtlichen will. Von durchdachten Regelungen kann man soweit auch bei Sympathie für das Anliegen in der Sache nicht sprechen. Das heißt, was hier gemacht wird, ist mit all diesen sehr ad hoc ins Parlament gebrachten Beschlüsse und Ideen und jede Prüfungskommission soll jetzt mal noch irgendeine andere Programmatik bekommen, ist, dass man unglaublich viele Räume des Unbehagens schafft, wo die ganze Zeit Kampf und wie du jetzt eben sagen würdest, schlechte Laune droht.
Schlechte Laune. Also sie schreiben ja auch relativ gegen Ende dann. In diesem Konflikt bilden sich schnell zwei unversöhnliche Lager. Kunstfreiheit oder Kampf gegen Antisemitismus. Das Verfassungsrecht verweigert beiden Positionen in ihrer Absolutheit die Zustimmung. Konflikte um antisemitische und rassistische Kunst sind selten geeigneter Gegenstand von Rechtsstreitigkeiten, sondern in erster Linie politisch und ästhetisch zu verantworten. Was bedeutet, in Deutschland wäre, glaube ich, niemand in einen Antisemiten verwandelt worden, wenn man die Dokumenta einfach unter in Deutschland ist das, was wir hier zeigen, Antisemitismus in anderen Orten der Welt aber nicht. Wir verstehen uns hier in einem globalen Dialog. Wir erklären ihnen das jetzt. Es gibt einen Beipackzettel. Wir verstecken es aber nicht, damit sie wissen, worüber wir hier reden. So, da ist ja niemand, also da hat ja keiner eine Gaskammer aufgebaut und hat gezeigt, wie man Juden tötet. Wir sind ja bei der Kunst relativ häufig in einem Metadiskurs. So, dieser Metadiskurs, finde ich, setzt voraus, dass Menschen bei Bewusstsein sind, wenn sie da sind. Jetzt würde ich sagen, Menschen, die sich ein Dokumentarticket kaufen, operieren auf dieser Metaebene.
Ja, das ist ja auch meine Haltung gegenüber der Vorbehaltsfilme. Also wir haben Vorbehaltsfilme, das heißt also Filme, die nationalsozialistisches Gedankengut transportieren, die bis heute unter Verschluss sind und nur in Sondervorstellungen gezeigt werden. Als würde jemand, der jetzt sich von der Monau-Stiftung, wenn die das aufbereiten würden, diese DVD kauft, würde dann auf die Idee kommen, Antisemit zu werden, weil er Jutz Süß gesehen hat.
Genau.
Das ist völliger Unsinn. Was schafft man stattdessen, eine Aura um dieses Werk und denkt, meine Güte, der verbotene Film und all das.
Sieht man sich dieses Melodram dann mal an, würde man wahrscheinlich merken, naja, OK, es ist auch viel Zeit vergangen und so.
Es ist kein Paradox, einfach nur eine Parodie, dass man, wie Harald Schmitt damals drauf hinwies, wenn auf RTL 2 22.30 ein Film beginnt, in dem vorher gesagt wird, der folgende Film ist für unter 16-Jährige nicht geeignet. Dann ist das genau der Moment, den man braucht, um die Hose schon mal zu öffnen. Genau so geht man hier auch wieder kurzum. Das ist einfach nicht gut.
Ein Fazit, was wir uns im Kopf behalten müssen, für so vieles, über die Kunst auch hinaus. Nicht alles, was verfassungsrechtlich möglich ist, ist verfassungspolitisch klug. Das sollten wir uns merken. Ein wichtiges Gutachten, wie ich finde. Hoffentlich findet es die richtigen Leser.
Ja, das stimmt.
Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit heißt das Buch von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Ein zugegeben schwierig zu lesendes Buch, aber ein Buch, das sehr wichtig ist. Vor allem hofft man, dass es die richtigen Personen lesen. Denn alles, was so verfassungsrechtlich möglich ist, erfahren wir, das ist verfassungspolitisch nicht unbedingt gut. Manches mag auch gut gemeint sein, aber der Sache dient es nicht. Wie geht man eigentlich um mit der Kunstfreiheit? Vor allem dann, wenn sie öffentlich gefördert ist. Darf der Staat Kunstwerke fördern, die antisemitisch sind? Sind antisemitische Werke von der Kunstfreiheit geschützt? Welche Rolle spielt der Staat? Wir müssen sehr viel über Ökonomie reden. Es ist ein Buch, das auf zwei Gutachten beruht und uns zu einem doch sehr tiefgehenden Gespräch gebracht hat.
Wir sind die ganze Kette einmal durchgegangen. Vom Künstler, der eine Einladung bekommt, von einer Kuratorin, die eine Einladung bekommt, von einer Institution, die eingeladen wurde oder beauftragt wurde von der Politik. Und dann stehen Juristen daneben und überprüfen, ob die Polizei zu Recht da reingerannt ist, um ein Bild zu verhüllen. Und ich denke mir, all diesen Völefanz bräuchte man gar nicht. Würde die dumme Politik nur manchmal ein bisschen sehen, dass das Publikum gar nicht so dumm ist wie die Politik, sondern dass eigentlich ja doch Leute, die sich ein Ticket gekauft haben, damit auch gezeigt haben, es ist ihnen wichtig, sie haben darüber nachgedacht und Geld ausgegeben. Damit kann man ihnen etwas zumuten. Entweder die Kunst oder, und dann finde ich ja, wird es besonders interessant, die Diskussion um ein Kunstwerk.
Ja, wir haben aber sehr viel Klarheit hier bekommen. Wir wissen jetzt auch mal, was sind eigentlich Aufgaben zum Beispiel von Intendenzen? Wo sind auch ihre Grenzen? An was müssen sie sich politisch halten? Und wo haben sie tatsächliche künstlerische Freiheit, wo der Gemeinderat jetzt nicht noch mal drauf einwirken kann? Literarische Essays will ich vorstellen. Judith Schalansky, eine großartige deutschsprachige Autorin, geboren in Greifswald, hat ein neues Buch vorgelegt, das heißt Marmor, Quecksilber, Nebel, Woraus die Welt gemacht ist. Sie beschäftigt sich also in drei Essays mit Marmor, Quecksilber, Nebel. Zum Beispiel bei Nebel, da wird das nebulös. Aber nebulös ist doch eigentlich gar nicht etwas Positives. Also wenn man Literatur als nebulös bezeichnet oder wolkig, dann ist das doch eigentlich nichts Positives. Sie geht dem nach, sie zitiert sehr viel. Sie findet in der Enzyklopädie von Diderot sehr Eigenartiges zu Nebel. Da ist ein Eintrag, der so nebulös ist, dass man sich denkt, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass das in einer Enzyklopädie steht, aber es passt doch dann wiederum ganz gut. Da heißt es dann tatsächlich an einer Stelle, am Ende des bemerkenswert schwammigen Lexikon-Artikels heißt es noch, siehe Wolke, siehe Seevermögen und siehe Hering, da man zum Fangen desselbigen eine neblige Zeit wählt. Ehe die Herausgeber nonchalant vermerken, wir verdanken diesen Artikel fast komplett Herrn Formay, der ihn größtenteils von Herrn Muschenbrock übernommen hat. Ja, wenn das nicht nebulöses Lexikon verfassen ist, aber wir beginnen mal mit Marmor und ich will auf diesen Text eingehen. Dieser Nebeltext geht sehr weit in den Bereich der KI. Es geht um die Maschine von Alan Turing und so, aber wir bleiben mal beim so klar Anfassbaren, dem Marmor. Der Text dazu beginnt so. Es beginnt nicht mit einem weißen Blatt, sondern mit einem weißen Block. Ich entdecke ihn, als ich mit einem Becher Kaffee auf dem Außendeck der Fähre an die Reling trete und auf das tragische Meer schaue. Ein strahlender Fleck am unteren Gesichtsfeld. Es dauert einen Moment, bis ich verstehe, frei dich ohne irgendetwas zu kapieren. Es ist ein Brocken, ein aberwitzig großer Brocken aus massiven Marmor, die Seiten annähernd rechtwinklig, beinahe ein Quader, ungeschlacht und perfekt. Man kann sich seine Erscheinungen nicht aussuchen. Sie ereilen ein wie Verliebtheiten aus dem Augenwinkel jäh unversehens Hinterrücks. Und diese Erscheinung bringt die Autorin dann zu Überlegungen über das Wesen des Marmors, obwohl sie Marmor eigentlich gar nicht mag. Ist das nicht ein Ausweis von dekadentem Prunk? Denken wir nicht dabei an irgendwelche Leute wie Donald Trump vielleicht? Wie aber können wir uns dem Marmor anders nähern? Es wird auch eine Reflexion über das Schreiben, über die Zeit, über die Gewalt, die aufgewendet werden muss, um überhaupt Marmor zu gewinnen. Da heißt es, genau genommen sind es Stücke jener Insel, die hinter uns liegt. Es sind Teile von Tassos, die hier verschifft werden und, so vieles gewiss, niemals zurückkehren werden an den Ort ihrer Entstehung. Nichts an ihre Erstaatheit erinnert an die lückenlose Handlungsfolge der Erdgeschichte, die dieses Gestein hervorbrachte. Das metaphorische Treiben im Erdinnern, ein flaches unterseisches Becken und kalkige Ablagerungen von verpflichtendem Meeresgetier. Da zu enormer Druck und Hitze sowie Zeit. So unendlich viel Zeit. Das Tempo von Neonen, in dem unter der Last der Sedimente, Kalkstein zu Marmor wird. Wer daran zweifelt, dass er wächst, muss nur 15 bis 20 Millionen Jahre warten. Was hier bei dieser Literatur auffällt ist, dass sie sich erstmal sehr gut auskennt mit den Dingen, die sie beschreibt. Also auch eine Wissenschaft hervorbringt, beziehungsweise epistemische Literatur ist, die Wissen uns direkt vermittelt. Aber auch eine Literatur ist, die dann zu dem Philosophischen übergeht. Wie stehen wir eigentlich so einem Marmorbrocken gegenüber, wenn wir wissen, zwar er ist gewachsen, aber um das sehen zu müssen, müssen wir uns 15 bis 20 Millionen Jahre Zeit nehmen, um das Wachsen zu erkennen. Wir müssten auch dann erkennen, welche enorme Gewalt es braucht, um überhaupt Marmor dann losreißen zu können. Dabei geht es dieser Autorin nicht um jetzt transzendente Erfahrungen. Es geht auch nicht um irgendeine Bekehrung. Sie schreibt, der Brocken vor mir spricht nicht. Er flüstert doch nicht einmal oder murmelt. Er sagt nicht, kehr um oder du musst dein Leben ändern. Alles perlt an ihm ab. Der attraktivste Schwarm ist immer noch jener, der niemals spricht. Und es bleibt unerheblich, ob aus Einfalt oder Sitzamkeit. Was habe ich erwartet? Selbst im Märchen bleiben Steine stumm. Und so gehen wir von der konkreten Betrachtung aus zu grundsätzlichen Fragen, auch der Literatur. Wie schreibt man sie? Wie lachhaft ist vielleicht auch das eigene Schreiben, wenn man diese Ewigkeit des Gesteins bedenkt? Es geht darum, über die eigene Lebenszeit nachzudenken, aber auch diese Lust an Rätseln zu schauen, was man eigentlich entdecken kann. Es ist ein Staunen über die verrätselte Welt und unser rätselhaftes Dasein. Und zugleich aber auch der Spaß daran, Teile zu enträtseln, wie Hieroglyphen zu entschlüsseln. Das ist also eine Literatur, die sich sehr assoziativ den Sachen hingibt, dann ins Konkrete, wieder ins Abstrakte wandert und dabei uns Mitte eigentlich auf eine Reise nimmt, durch die doch sehr analoge Welt, wenngleich Bezüge zur KI immer wieder deutlich gemacht werden oder wenn es auch nur die Frage gestellt wird, wie ist es eigentlich, wenn man einzelne Beschreibungen mit der KI übersetzt, was kommt da eigentlich bei raus und welche Assoziation führt einem dann zum nächsten, wenn man zum Beispiel den schneeweißen Marmor übersetzt und da wird dann plötzlich Schneewittchen Marmor, Snow White, aus Schneewittchen Marmor draus, wohin führt uns eigentlich dieser Gedanke und diese Assoziationen sind wirklich zauberhaft von Judith Schalansky umgesetzt bzw. Judith Schalansky ist eine Autorin, die uns zu den Sachen hinführt, die sicherlich eigentlich etwas sind, was wir so kennen. Ja, also Marmor haben wir alle schonmal irgendwie angefasst. Aber dann wird uns doch auch vieles fremdurch, die Literatur und manches erkennen wir aber in uns.
Solange der Marmor schneeweiß bleibt, egal wie man virtuell darüber spricht, ist ja alles egal. Die Welt ist widerspenstisch. So auch hier. Stefan Kühl, Führung und Gefolgschaft. Ich sage jetzt ein wirklich ganz hervorragendes Lehrbuch für angehende Soziologen, die nämlich überraschenderweise, wie auch allgemeines Publikum, so schreibt ja Kühl immer, abgeholt werden, wo man ist, in der echten Welt, wo man nicht soziologisch abstrahiert, wo es also Geschichte und Personen gibt, um es sozusagen. Und hier in Führung und Gefolgschaft ein Diktum aus der NS-Zeit, Führung und Gefolgschaft, so stand es damals im Gesetz, um Management-Fragen und Organisationsfragen zu klären, ist die Geschichte von Bedeutung, Management-Moden von der Kaiserzeit, Weimarer Republik, NS-Zeit, Nachkriegszeit, dann neue Management-Methoden ab dem 70ern mit der Globalisierung bis heute und das festgemacht an einer Person, Reinhard Höhn. Damals in der NS-Zeit, nachdem er ausgebildet wurde in der Weimarer Zeit, also die Kaiserzeit ist schon vergangen, der Staat wollte schon auf Selbstorganisation sozusagen umstellen, die Bürgerschaft ertüchtigen, dann kam plötzlich die NS-Zeit, die aber nicht einfach die Kaiserzeit wiederholte, das ist ja völlig absurd, das so zu denken, also da Ähnlichkeiten zu vermuten. Und Reinhard Höhn war ausgebildet in der Weimarer Republik, historisch geprägt von der Kaiserzeit, SS-Oberführer, um den NS-Staat zu organisieren, in der Nachkriegszeit, nach kurzer Zeit als anonymer Heilpraktiker, der sich versteckt hielt, eine Amnesty, ja Amnesty, nicht Amnesie, Amnesty, Amnesty, ja. eine Amnesty erfuhr, rutschte er zurück in die alte Aufgabe und bildete 600.000, also in seinem Harzburger Institut, 600.000 angehende Führungskräfte der aufstrebenden Bundesrepublik aus. Also selten so viel Geschichte und so viel Kram innerhalb einer Biografie. Und die hat nun Stefan Kühl aufgeschrieben, um eine sozio-logische Lehre daraus zu ziehen, die einige Pointen hat, die wirklich ganz toll sind. Weshalb sich das als erstes sozio-logisches Buch, das man liest, wirklich sehr einladend ist. Also wir haben es mit einem Problem zu tun, das wir heute wie folgt beschreiben. Ich sehe im Fernsehen Politiker, die mir die ganze Zeit vom Bürokratismus abraten und dass man da mal was dagegen machen sollte. Dann gibt es Podcasts, in denen noch mal Wolfgang Kubicki als die neue Koryphäe vorgestellt wird. Also der charismatische Führer, der eine Partei aus dem Sumpf ziehen kann und so weiter. Und nichts von dem ist ja neu, sondern das entspricht halt so Moden, die gerade dem Zeitgeist entsprechen. Wir können uns fragen, wo kommt denn das eigentlich her? Und jetzt sagt Kühl, ja dann schauen wir uns das doch mal an. Wie war das damals im NS-Reich? Also Reinhard Höhn hat damals Modelle entwickelt. Kühl sagt heute, dass Modell I im Vergleich zum Modell F, also Modell F steht für Formalstruktur. Alles wird geregelt. Niemand darf hier machen, was man will. Es wird delegiert und kontrolliert. Und alle sind Zahnräder im großen Getriebe, egal ob oben oder unten. Hierarchie ist sozusagen eine Verwaltungslaufbahn, die man macht, aber keine Selbstverwirklichung. Und dann das Modell I, die Informalität, das, was man im NS-Reich hatte. Als es hieß, die Führung ergibt sich doch aus der Gemeinschaft. Die Gemeinschaft setzt sich ab von der Gesellschaft. Sie ist nämlich biologisch fast göttlich natürlich begründet. Und wer die Gemeinschaft richtig in sich inkorporiert, verwirklicht sich in der Gemeinschaft und dient ihr dann vielleicht auch mal als Führer. Und so galt es dann nicht nur von ganz oben, also Hitler der große Führer, wie wir es heute immer haben, sondern im Grunde wurde die ganze Verwaltung so kleine Führerschaften, das große Revier des kleinen Führers sozusagen, aufgebaut. Und all diese Ideen kamen damals von Reinhard Höhn. Und heute möchte man sich natürlich nicht mehr so gern daran erinnern, weshalb man das schnell mal verwechselt. Man denkt so Hierarchie, der strikte Befehl, das muss Hitler gewesen sein. Und Kühl, nein, und er geht wirklich ins Detail. Und die Texte und was Höhn damals riet und schrieb und als oberster Verwaltungs, also direkt der Administration in Berlin darunter stellt, eben Verwaltungstyp so vorstellte. Und nein, es war nicht der Befehl und nicht die Hierarchie und so weiter, sondern es war dieses kleine, und das eben auch aus der Kaiserzeit damals geronne und dann später im Ersten Weltkrieg und so. Wir müssen dem kleinen Soldaten nicht einfach nur Befehl geben, sondern er sollte aus eigener Kraft das machen. Er sollte einfach verstehen, worum es hier geht. Und dann sozusagen zweckprogrammiert alle gemeinsam zum großen Sieg führen. So, das ist die Idee. Die Rettung daraus war dann...
Was heißt dann eigenmächtiges Handeln?
Genau, die Begriffe werden alle im Detail beschrieben. Also da ist dann die Auftrags... Mal gucken, ob es hier ein Notizzettel noch mal drüber stolpern, aber es ist sozusagen empirisch sehr nah, sehr gut argumentiert. Man versteht sofort, was hier gemeint ist. So, dann haben wir also die große Katastrophe, die daraus erwächst, dass irgendwelche Leute propagiert haben, dass hier eine große Volksgemeinschaft entsteht, in der die Führung als Dienen... Hitler hat da natürlich drüber gebaut, dass wir hier eine Popularität haben, die wir mit Macht unterfüttern müssen, ihr dann eine Tradition andichten und daraus dann so ein Geschichtsbild entwickeln, in dem jeder seinen eigenen Platz findet. Und klar, die Führung, von der wir heute sagen, das ist die Führung, die hat natürlich dekadent einfach dagegen gelebt. Also den waren die Soldaten und dass man mit denen vielleicht was gemeinsam hat oder so, das war da natürlich alles egal, aber das ist natürlich, so funktioniert es ja immer. So, und dann passiert unter dieser Gemengelage die charismatische Führung hier, Führerprinzip da, biologische, bis hin zu euthanasie, rassistische, wie ist der andere Begriff? Na wie auch immer, also ein Rassismus, der wirklich tötet. Man hat es ja dann auf die Spitze getrieben. Dann geht aber der Krieg verloren und man muss ein neues Modell entwickeln. Und sehr viele Autoren, gegen die sich Kühl auch explizit wendet, vor allem aus Frankreich, sehen hier eine Kontinuität, weil es ja dieselbe Person war. Reinhard Höhn, der dann das Harzburger Modell, so sagen wir mal zehn bis zwanzig Jahre, war das ja richtig erfolgreich. Also das zentrale Ding, wo man die Verwaltungslaufbahn einmal hingeschickt wurde, um zu lernen, wie man das jetzt macht. So und dieselbe Person...
Ach ja, da war so ein Buch erschienen vor ein paar Jahren, das das sehr stark machte, diese Kontinuität, das in einem Publikumsverlag erschienen ist. Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Also aus Frankreich diese Idee, dass da eine sehr große persönliche, also über die Person gezogene Kontinuität herrscht. Weshalb ja bis heute immer kolportiert wird, ja, alles Nazis und so, ja. Und jetzt kommt Kühl und sagt, nee, wenn man sich das soziologisch anschaut, es hat dann doch einen großen Umschwenk gegeben, nämlich von der I auf die F-Organisation. Also der bundesrepublikanische Staat, der sich damals sowohl von seiner eigenen Vergangenheit distanzieren wollte, als auch selbst erlebt hat, dass man hier gerade ein Wirtschaftswachstum organisiert und vielleicht auch eine freundschaftliche Bande. Wir entscheiden uns für die Freiheit, wir machen die Westbindung und der ganze Kramme, dass man es vielleicht auch anders machen kann und dass es auch Vorteile gibt, zum Beispiel Profite, die eingefahren werden können, wenn nur die Regeln klar sind, das Rechtsgefüge klar, so man nicht immer irgendein so ein kleinen Miniführer irgendwo ausgeliefert ist, entwickelt dann das Harzburger Modell, dass ich eben dadurch auszeichne, dass es Konditionalprogrammierung gibt. Also niemand hat mehr das große Ziel vor Augen und versucht dann den Volkswillen im persönlichen Alltag durchzusetzen und dafür den großen Dank des Führers zu erfahren, sondern man guckt mal so nach, was die Stellenbeschreibung sagt, die Stellenbeschreibung als die Reviermarkierung. Und da steht zum Beispiel auch drin, also wenn der Chef kommt und ich darum bitte, dass du heute eine Stunde länger bleibst, so auf Seite 17 steht, ich habe jetzt Feierabend, Punkt. Also plötzlich ist alles geregelt. Keiner erreicht eine Hierarchiestufe, auf der er einfach Befehle geben darf, sondern man kriegt halt eine neue Stellenbeschreibung. Die einzigen Vorteile, die man hat, ist vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Geld und so. Aber das große Gefüge-Start ist ganz klar hierarchisch strukturiert. Und damit ist genau nicht gemeint, was man immer dem NS-Stand unterstellt, sondern einfach eine Wenn-Dann-Regelung. So. Und jetzt ist es aber derselbe Typ, der das aufschreibt.
Das heißt, es sind formalisierte Abläufe. Und wir hatten im Nationalsozialismus zwar die Hierarchie im Sinne des Führerprinzips, aber es war so, dass dann die einzelnen Stellen sehr viel Handlungsspielraum plötzlich haben und nach gut Dünken die nationalsozialistische Ideologie erfüllen oder übererfüllen sollen, wodurch dann sich eine ganz andere Dynamik ergibt, die genau dann nach 45 eingehegt werden soll. Dass also dann nicht, wie ich ja eben auch schon mal so erwähnte, nach Gnadenmaßnahmen oder sonst wie nach eigenem gut Dünken heraus entschieden werden kann, sondern Formalien sind einzuhalten.
Genau. Also im Buch steht jetzt nicht drin diese Pointe, aber im Radiogespräch habe ich kühnmal gehört, wie er meinte, 20 Seiten Stellenbeschreibung, um zu markieren, was ist ihr erlaubt, wenn Zweckprogrammierung ist. Also man hat dann so die Wahl der Mittel begrenzt oder nicht, aber es ist immer geregelt, um was es geht. Es gibt genau nicht mehr diese große, grundlegende Idee der Volksgemeinschaft, aus der sich Sachen selbst ergeben, sondern was nicht beschrieben wurde, gibt es einfach nicht. Und so endet einfach diese Verwaltungswelt da, wo die Verwaltung endet und hat nicht so eine Idee von der obere Führer der Verwaltung, die auch nachmittags noch zuständig für den Straßenverkehr und lauter solche Sachen ist, dass man da große Eingriffe hat. Sondern alles ist plötzlich geregelt. Und bei so Autoren wie Max Weber kann man es dann auch wieder rauslesen. Also er postuliert diese charismatische Führung, aber eben auch jede andere Art von Führung. Und da findet einfach ein richtiger Shift statt. So, wir haben also diese harte Programmierung. Und dann haben wir eine ganz besondere Dramaturgie, dass nämlich dieses Harzburger Modell irgendwann an Interesse verliert. Also der Höhen baut das auch entsprechend seines Publikums. Er weiß ja, ab jetzt kommen Leute zu mir, die nicht nur Verwaltung organisieren, sondern vielleicht auch so private Organisationen. Die haben natürlich Profitinteresse. Und die wollen auch nicht, dass irgendwas im juristischen Limbo ist, sondern das muss halt alles geregelt sein. Also richtet er sich genau darauf auf. Und in Amerika zeitgleich schreibt Peter Drucker, also macht im Grunde ist so sein Pendant ähnliche Verwaltungsgrundlagenarbeit, an dem man dann, also die in Schule als Lehre durchgereicht wird, in die Gesellschaft nur stellt man dann fest, dieses Harzburger Modell verliert dann so an Bedeutung. Das hat zum einen damit zu tun, dass der, also die die Nachwehen des Nationalsozialismus, also alles Nazis, dass sie dann den sozialen Tod sterben, also selber aus der Verwaltung als Rentner rausrutschen und gar nicht mehr den großen Bedarf haben, an was eigentlich und es ist wirklich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, ein Modell für sich zu finden, mit dem sie klar machen können, dass sie keine Nazis mehr sind, indem sie jetzt Verwaltungsvorschriften akzeptieren, indem sie jetzt Zielprogrammierung akzeptieren, indem sie die Wahl der Mittel sich vorgeben lassen, indem sie sich delegieren lassen, aber auch delegieren, aber sich auch kontrollieren lassen und kontrollieren und nicht jeder einfach machen darf. So, und die Frage ist jetzt, wie ging das eigentlich verloren? Und eine der großen Pointen hier im Buch ist, in dem Moment, als die amerikanische Welt ihre Management-Methode einfach weiterentwickeln konnte, nämlich wieder zu, ja, wir haben jetzt so viele Aufgaben, wir brauchen jetzt auch mal einen Manager, der, obwohl die Werkbank 20.000 Meilen weit weg ist in China, trotzdem, also da kann man ja nicht mit Verwaltungsvorschriften kommen, sondern da muss jetzt mal schon wieder ein bisschen Beinfreiheit gegeben werden. So, und der Höhen wollte das nicht sehen. Warum? Weil ihn das an seine alten Lehren zu sehr erinnert hat. Also das übertreibe ich jetzt ein bisschen. Kühl machte es nicht, und er wollte das nicht sehen, sondern er hat es einfach nicht gesehen, weil er, nachdem er den großen Sprung weggemacht hat von diesen charismatischen, wir müssen jetzt mal Beinfreiheit haben und hier selber bestimmen dürfen und so, einfach den Shift nicht machen konnte, weil das zu nahe wieder an der mühsam verabschiedeten NS-Ideologie, wie man Management macht, dranrückte.
Das heißt, die jetzt im Diskurs häufig bemühte Idee, wir brauchen mal wieder jemand, der das einfach mal macht, ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Auch wenn es aus einem links-liberalen Diskurs kommt, wir brauchen jetzt einfach mal wieder Macher, die nicht so lange zögern und warten. Ich weiß, wir haben hier über das Buch von Esra Klein gesprochen, sondern da gab es so eine Passage, wo er einfach erzählte, wie ein Bürgermeister sich über irgendwelche Vorschriften hinwegsitzt und sagt, wir bauen jetzt die Brücke einfach mal so. Da hast du schon auf kühl verwiesen und da beobacht. Das kann doch fatale Konsequenzen haben.
Ich sage jetzt auf das, was du sagst, man kann das nicht übertreiben, diese Bedeutung von genau dieser Beobachtung. Denn es waren damals, zu Kaiserszeiten, einfach preußische Auftragstaktiken, die den Soldaten erlaubt haben, nicht auf den Befehl warten zu müssen, sondern zu tun, was richtig ist. Da taucht jemand auf, ich warte nicht auf den Befehl, ich schieße sofort tot, ja, so ungefähr. So, es gab also ganz kleine elementare Notwendigkeiten im Krieg, den einzelnen Soldaten Handlungsfreiheit einzuräumen. Und wenn man vom Papst gehört, wenn Krise und Gier zusammentreffen, dann sind so ganz kleine Momente und dann 20 Jahre später das Weltkrieg. Ja. Und jeder tut mal das Beste für sein Schutzen graben.
Jeder drohen Pilot, um das aufs Heute zu übertragen, sagt auch, ich habe da schon mal geschossen. Da war mir völlig klar, dass das sein muss.
Also wir kommen hier, und das bindet er eben, und deswegen ist es sozio-logisch so interessant, daran, dass wir es grundsätzlich mit Management-Moden zu tun haben. Also eine Reform verändert immer, was vorher war, und dann kommt eine neue Reform, und die Reform kann schon wieder wiederholen, was vor zwei Etappen war, weil das ja vergessen wurde durch die vorherige Reform. Das heißt, die amerikanische Management-Logik, dass man jetzt wieder charismatische Führer, die ihr Unternehmen einpeitschen, wir verstehen uns ja alle als Familie und so weiter, der ganze Kram, also dass es so eine Art Gemeinschaft gibt und so. Die Amerikaner konnten es einfach machen, weil sie natürlich nicht anschlossen an eine gar nicht so leicht zu vergessene, haben wir ja schon mal gemacht, ging nicht gut aus. Und diesen Bogenschlag konnte der Höhen dann nicht mitmachen. Weshalb sich der Drucker in Amerika, und wir wissen ja, Amerika ist immer der Vorarbeit, damit durchsetzt, dass jetzt wieder hieß, nee, da muss jetzt sich jetzt mal, also lebenslanges Lernen, jeder bringt sich jetzt mal selber auf, man wartet nicht auf den Befehl, man macht jetzt mal. Und es wäre auch richtig gut, wenn man von unten nach oben so Empfehlungen weiterreicht, weil man in seinem Gebiet was entdeckt hat, was ja dem Chef mal, damit das Unternehmen weiterkommt und so. Also da schließt sich einfach ein Kreis. Und ja, da würde ich jetzt sagen, man muss es selber lesen. Ich würde die Gefahr als sehr groß sehen, dass wir einfach über so eine Segewohnheit, die uns gerade wieder erzählt wird, dass die FDP von einem einsamen charismatischen Führer, der einfach der Partei sagt, also was jetzt irgendwelche anderen Leute, denen interessiert mich nicht, ich kenne den richtigen Weg.
Naja, ich würde sagen, das ist doch nochmal etwas anderes in der Partei. Ich glaube, das Problem, das sich ja hier stellt, ist ja, wenn man eigentlich so wie Schirach oder so sagt, wir brauchen jetzt mal so Kanzlergesetze, der Kanzler kann jetzt mal von all diesen Vorschriften unbehelligt mal irgendwas machen. Das ist ja eigentlich der Punkt, an dem man da gelangt.
Es geht nicht darum, dass von Wolfgang Kubicki konkret eine Gefahr ausgeht, jetzt Nationalsozialismus wieder aufzubauen.
Das habe ich auch nicht gemeint, aber ich sehe es.
Aber in diesen kleinen Dingen, in diesen kleinen Artefakten des medialen Fortentwickelns bundesrepublikanischer Schicksalhaftigkeit, wird dieser Klebstoff, dass es jetzt auf die Kultur der FDP wieder ankommt oder einer Partei allgemein, also dass diese Kultur fragen, dass wir diese Renaissance des Führers haben, dass wir eben wirklich diese Reaktivierung der Ideen der charismatischen Führung, aber durch neue Begriffe, dass wir so transformational das Führen plötzlich haben, dass wir auch eine Renaissance von religiösen Gedanken grundsätzlich haben, also dass diese Idee wieder aufkommt, dass wir Migranten heute abwehren, obwohl wir ökonomisch nicht auf sie verzichten können, weil wir einfach kulturell darauf angewiesen sind, so einen Diskurs zu führen. Ja, das führt alles zu Sachen. Und Kühl macht nun selber, finde ich, also zieht da einfach sehr große Konsequenzen draus, was den Text angeht. Denn wir hatten die Erfahrung, dass man mal etwas nicht sehen wollte, nämlich 15 Jahre strategisches Beschweigen des Nationalsozialismus, um den Leuten die Chance zu geben, sich nochmal neu zu erfinden und ihnen auch eine Bewährung zu ermöglichen. Sie konnten wirklich zeigen, dass sie abgeschworen haben. Und zwar nicht, indem man die immer wieder fragt, bist du eigentlich noch Antisemit und so? Sondern nein, man hat ihnen einfach die Chance gegeben, sich in so einem Gefüge zurechtzufinden, gute Arbeit zu leisten und entsprechende Ziele zu erreichen. Und es wurde sozusagen angenommen und plötzlich wurden die Menschen neu erfunden. Das gibt es natürlich auch umgedreht. Also, dass man wieder durch strategisches Beschweigen jetzt eine Gefahr einfach nicht thematisiert, obwohl man so zoologisch daneben steht und sagt, also wollen wir jetzt einfach nur sagen, wir haben Glück, dass Wolfgang Kubicki 74 ist und vielleicht doch nicht so auf der Höhe. Aber ansonsten finden wir das mit diesem charismatischen und die Ein-Mann-Partei schon ganz okay. Ja, also diese Gefahr. Und da sagt Kühl hier eben relativ deutlich am Ende, unter der Gefahr, dass jetzt immer alle hier die AfD ist die große Gefahr des Neuen, sondern wir haben ja von Arne Semsrott und unser eigenes Postulat, nee, die AfD schiebt es nur an, aber es kommt von überall her. Schreibt Kühl, wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass eine breitgeteilte Gemeinschaftsideologie von einem charismatischen Führer fast unmerklich mit autoritären, totalitären und rassistischen Komponenten aufgeladen wird und deren Ähnlichkeit zur nationalsozialistischen Ideologie einen dann fast schon überraschen, also dass es sich einschleicht. Weshalb er sagt, die Gefahr kommt nicht von hinten, sondern von vorne. Also wir kommen in eine Zeit, in der nicht die AfD nochmal die Renaissance, der NSDAP und so weiter und dann ist es einfach klar, sondern nein, das Problem sind diese Verwandlungen der Institutionen, die wir haben, die durch Reformen neue Managementmethoden annehmen, die uns dann in so Denkgebäude und so weiter reinbringen, die dann plötzlich sagen, ja natürlich bauen wir Asylantenzentren außerhalb der EU, wo sollen wir die sonst hinbringen? Ja und dann sind wir aber schon kurz vorm Lager, also vom Konzentrationslager, wo einfach Menschen, ja was machen wir jetzt mit denen und so? Ja und dann, na gut, die sind ja weit weg. Also das finde ich schon, ist ganz gut. Ich hier, also die Proante ist einfach sehr trifftig. Sie ist, wenn man den Text liest, einfach kommt man nicht umhin. So, es ist wirklich sehr schlüssig argumentiert. Und was ich sehr gut finde, ist, dass wir ein Buch haben, das ist eine Plausibilität aus historischen Anmerkungen. Also, einfach dieses Kaiserzeit, NS-Zeit, dazwischen Weimarer Republik, dann diese Nachkriegszeit als Besondere und dann durch den Bedarf der Globalisierung eine Reform des Nachkriegsmanagements, sozusagen als Erinnerung, das wieder zu vitalisieren, was vorher schon mal war. Also, es einfach historisch aufzuziehen und dann aber anhand des Handelns von diesem Reinhard Höhn, der ja, das ist in seiner Arbeit gewesen, viele Texte geschrieben hat, also es lässt sich einfach da ablesen, weshalb es auch so klug ist, dass Stefan Kühl nochmal dem, wie heißt er denn, dieser französische Autor, der eben unterstellte, dass es da eine große Kontinuität gab, weil er einfach dieselbe Person war und Kühl sagt, nee, da muss man, wir müssen da zwei Brüche sehen und der eine war halt super erfolgreich und der andere nicht. Und dann fragt man sich, warum eigentlich? Ja, weil man er das nicht nochmal machen wollte. So, da kann man ein bisschen offen lassen, ob er aus sozusagen arbeitetischer Überzeugung gesagt hat, diesen Shift mache ich nicht mit oder ob er es wirklich nicht gesehen hat, also ob es was mit inneren Einstellungen zu tun hat. Das offen zu lassen, finde ich ja wieder, ist ein toller heimlicher Humor, weil man in der Soziologie genau das ja offen lassen darf.
Ja, ich will einen hervorragenden Roman empfehlen, den man noch lange mit sich herumträgt, wenn man ihn gelesen hat, beziehungsweise die Perspektive des Protagonisten trägt man lange mit sich herum. Ein schweigsamer Mann ist nämlich dieser und diese Schweigsamkeit irritierte einen auf den ersten Seiten. Aber dann irgendwann merkt man, was damit eigentlich alles ausgedrückt wird, wenn jemand ganz wortkark nur antwortet. David Szalay hat den Roman geschrieben, das heißt, was nicht gesagt werden kann, ist bei Klaassen erschienen. Dieser Roman handelt von Istvan. Er beginnt in Ungarn. Dort lebt dieser 15-jährige Istvan mit seiner Mutter in einem Plattenbau, eine kleine Wohnung. Da gibt es einen guten Freund, mit dem hat er aber dann keinen Kontakt mehr, als der gute Freund will, dass Istvan auch mal mit der Freundin schläft. Das verunglückt aber, das funktioniert nicht so ganz. Istvan wird die Nachbarin der Mutter kennenlernen, ihr bei Einkäufen behilflich sein, eine deutlich ältere Frau, mit der er dann seine ersten sexuellen Erlebnisse hat. Diese ist verheiratet. Irgendwann kommt es zu einer Rempelei auf einer Treppe. Genau wird uns das in diesem Wortkragenroman gar nicht so beschrieben. Aber dann gibt es wohl eine Rempelei. Schlagartig herrscht tiefe Stille, heißt es dann. Er hört Stimmen. Weiter unten im Treppenhaus. Als er begreift, dass der Mann nicht mehr aufstehen wird, geht er die Stufen hinunter. Seine Beine zittern. Sie zittern so stark, dass er kaum laufen kann. Auf halber Treppe geht er an den Mann vorbei. Ein paar Töpfe sind umgekippt. Erde liegt auf dem Boden und dann weiter nach unten. Im nächsten unteren Stockwerk sind die Wohnungstüren offen. Dort stehen mehrere Leute. Er geht wortlos an ihnen vorbei und sie sprechen ihn nicht an. Vielleicht glauben sie, er hätte nichts mit dem zu tun, was passiert ist, was immer es sei. Sie haben etwas gehört, Rufe und das laute Geräusch, mit dem der Kopf des Mannes gegen den Handlauf geknallt ist. Sie starren nach oben, als fragten sie sich, was geschehen ist. Er geht auf dem Weg nach unten an ihnen vorbei und tritt in den warmen Abend. Draußen ist es noch ziemlich hell. Er geht weiter, er hat kein Ziel, er geht einfach. Er weiß nicht, wie lange er schon unterwegs ist, stellt nur fest, dass es dunkel geworden ist, als in einer stillen Straße ein Polizeiauto an ihm vorbeifährt und weiter vorn vor einem kleinen Eckladen hält. Zwei Polizisten steigen aus. Ungarn wird er verlassen, nachdem er in Haft war. Er wird in das Meditea gehen, er wird in Kuwait sein, er wird nach London ziehen. Dort schlägt er sich erst einmal mit Gelegenheitsjobs durch. Dann ist da ein Mann, Marvin, den er kennenlernt, der denkt, der könnte mir helfen. Marvin, ein sehr reicher Geschäftsmann mit einer sehr viel jüngeren Frau, ein Londoner Geschäftsmann, wie man ihn sich vorstellt. Und dieser Istvan, dieser Wortkarge lässt sich darauf ein, lässt sich erziehen von diesem Marvin, um dann Chauffeur zu werden. Diese Erziehung sieht wie folgt aus, dialogisch wird sie hergestellt für uns. Essen sie nicht so schnell, sagt Marvin lächelnd. Wozu die Eile? Verzeihung, sagt Istvan. Wozu die Eile? Ja. Ich möchte, dass sie nicht aufgegessen haben, bevor ich aufgegessen habe, sagt Marvin. OK. Marvin isst sehr langsam. Istvan zwingt sich genauso langsam zu essen. Sie müssen üben, langsam zu essen, sagt Marvin.
OK, sagt Istvan. Später, sagt Marvin, versuchen sie beim Sprechen nicht mit den Händen zu fruchteln. Gut. Ich möchte, dass sie still da sitzen. OK. Legen sie die Hände an die Seiten. OK. Haben sie ein Feuerzeug, fragt Marvin. Klar. Ja, sagt Marvin. Ja, sagt Istvan. Ganz reduzierte Dialoge. Man denkt, wo soll das hinführen? Aber es tun sich wirklich Atmosphären auf, wo man gar nicht es für möglich hält, dass das mit so wenig Sprache geht. Da ist ein Dialog später, wenn Istvan aufsteigt in der Upper Class, dann er wird nicht dieser Chauffeur bleiben. Und er wird sich auf eine andere Frauengeschichte einlassen, die ihn sehr weit nach oben bringt. Und er wird aber immer der sein, der nur so karge Antworten gibt, der am meisten mit OK antwortet oder fast alles auch bejaht, was man von ihm will. Und dieser Mann ohne Eigenschaften wäre falsch gesagt, denn dieser hat Eigenschaften und sie blitzen nur manchmal auf und ganz kurz gibt es dann eine erschütternde Innenschau und dann geht es wieder weiter. Das ist so unglaublich gut gebaut, weil man denkt, wie kommt man eigentlich hier in ein Prosa-Schreiben hinein? Da ist eine Auseinandersetzung mit einem Sohn, den er dann später hat, mit seinem Sohn. Und diese Auseinandersetzung ist nur dialogisch und nur ganz kurz. Kurze Repliken, aber einmal gibt es dann ein Ping, eine Handynachricht und es steht auch noch so mittendrin in diesem Dialog. Und damit merken wir plötzlich, wir können uns sofort das Szenario vorstellen, in dem diese Unterhaltungen stattfinden. Es ist so interessant, mit wie wenig man so dicht eigentlich beschreiben kann, auch wenn häufig nur Ja, Ja, Okay, Nein, ich weiß, aber Ja steht, dann merken wir plötzlich, dass das einen Sog entwickelt und dass wir viel über uns tatsächlich in dieser Figur sehen. Denn hier stolpert ja jemand durch die Zeit in eine globale Ökonomie hinein, bis ganz nach oben. Und nun ja, ob er oben bleiben wird, das will ich jetzt nicht verraten. Und dann gibt es die Innenschau, die erschüttert, wenn es da heißt, es ist ein regnerischer Sonntag. Er mag es, wie der Regen auf die Dachfenster prasselt, vor allem am Morgen eines Tages, der keine Verpflichtung mit sich bringt. Er hat die Nacht mit der kanadischen Nanny genossen. Er selbst hält es für keinen Fehler. Er hätte sie wiedergesehen, wenn sie gewollt hätte. Dass sie es nicht will, ist auch okay. Was Frauen angeht, hatte das Gefühl, kaum noch Erfahrungen machen zu können, die sich vollkommen neu anfühlen, die keinen früheren Erfahrungen gleichen oder am Ende demgleichen werden, was er auch in Zukunft erleben wird. Und deshalb hat er nie den Eindruck, es wäre irgendwie etwas Ernstes. Meist überwiegt ein Gefühl wie, klar, ich mag dich, aber andere mag ich auch. Ich mag sie gar nicht mal mehr als dich, aber halt auch nicht weniger. Deshalb kommt es ihm irgendwie beliebig vor, bei einer Frau zu sein, egal wer sie ist. Und dieses Gefühl der Beliebigkeit beginnt seine Sehnsucht, nach einer Person zu tilgen, für die er sozusagen bestimmt ist. Am späteren Nachmittag hört es auf zu regnen und er beschließt, doch noch auszugehen. Er weiß nicht genau wohin. Diese Unbestimmtheit, nicht klaren zu wissen, wo man hin will. Das Leben passiert einem, auch mit all den Unfällen. Es ist, wenn man so möchte, auch eine Unfalls- oder Zufallstramaturgie, die hier aufgespannt wird. Dabei muss man mitunter an der Fremde von Camus denken. Aber es ist nicht jetzt ein Nacherzählen solch eines existenzialistischen Konflikts, sondern die Frage ist vielmehr, inwieweit man sein Leben selbst in der Hand hat und wie auch man quasi unempfindlich werden muss in einer Welt wie dieser, die dort beschrieben wird. Und wo ist dann doch noch so etwas wie Empfindsamkeit, wo es irgendein halt oder ist man am Ende ganz allein und ist deshalb auch so schweigsam, weil man dieses Alleinsein zwar genau kennt, aber doch nicht mit Worten benennen kann. Das heißt, man schweigt nicht, weil man nichts zu sagen hat, sondern weil eigentlich das, was alles zu sagen wäre, gar nicht gesagt werden kann. Wie es heißt im Titel, was nicht gesagt werden kann. Ich bin wahnsinnig begeistert von diesem Roman, David Szalay, was nicht gesagt werden kann.
Da hat einfach einer keine Kinder, würde ich sagen.
Doch, doch, doch. Er bekommt auch Kinder.
Ah ja, OK.
Ein Sohn.
After Automation, nach der Automatisierung, ist ein Text, der auf der Webseite des Unternehmens Every erschien, geschrieben vom Chefe dort. Und dann Schipper heißt er. Und ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, denn er schließt zum einen an die Enzyklika an, obwohl er fünf Tage vorher publiziert wurde. Und zum anderen spricht er mir ein bisschen aus dem Herzen. Also ich habe mich sehr aufgehoben gefühlt, denn diesen Technik-Tagebucheintrag hätte ich im Grunde genauso geschrieben, auch wenn ich jetzt kein Softwareunternehmen habe, in dem 30 Menschen Software produzieren und so. Aber so wie er das beschreibt, ist doch ganz interessant. Also wir nehmen mal mit, dass er ein Business hat, das davon profitiert, dass die Welt vielleicht sich darauf einigt, wie er die Welt sieht und so. Aber das nur nebenbei. Denn die Lage ist ja viel schlimmer. Wir haben es ja mit, wie wir wissen, Amo.di zu tun, der jetzt irgendwie so ein Moratorium der KI-Forschung fordert als Anthropic-Chef und gleichzeitig da schon waren, dass die Einstiegsjobs nicht mehr gibt. Und dann kommt Meta und Zuckerberg sagt, ihr werdet jetzt alle nur noch ausspioniert von mir, damit ich meine Maschine lerne und 8000 von euch müssen jetzt auch schon mal gehen. Und diese ganze Dramatik. Und jetzt sagt er hier, wir sind, wir verstehen uns selber als Early Adopter Labor. Wir gestalten hier mit in dieser Welt, in der wir leben. Und das bedeutet alles, was sich automatisieren lässt, haben wir bei uns schon automatisiert. Das heißt 95 Prozent der E-Mails von ihm wurden schon von einer KI beantwortet in seinem Namen. Er geht aber trotzdem immer noch selber drüber und er schreibt, je mehr wir automatisieren, desto mehr fachkundige menschliche Arbeit gibt es zu tun. Und ich finde es ganz gut, weil es jetzt hier ins Metier gibt, wo es nicht mehr darum geht, was ist ein Einstiegsjob, sollte jemand noch mal grundsätzlich lernen, wenn man genau so feststellt, die Leute, die gerade angeblich keine Einstiegsjobs mehr haben, kommen ja aus einem Uni-Betrieb, in dem sie jede Hausaufgabe selbst schon mit KI gemacht haben. Also die sind sozusagen schon KI-Literat, aber noch nicht Fachliterat. Und das ist ja vielleicht auch ein Vorteil, den man nutzen kann. Wie also ich auch hat man es hier mit einer Unternehmung zu tun, in der ich klar jetzt keine menschlichen Mitarbeiter habe, aber sehr viele KI-Mitarbeiter, denen auch Namen gebe, so wie hier auch. Also sie heißen Claudi, Andi, Victor, Finn. Und die erste Lernerfahrung, die das Unternehmen gemacht hat, ist, man gibt diesen KI's Aufgaben. Man geht nicht mit dem Trend, wie das jetzt Microsoft gestern auf der Bühne gemacht hat, bei ihrer Bildkonferenz zu sagen, jeder von uns kriegt jetzt so einen Agent und das ist dann dein Assistenz-Lebenshilfer für alle Aufgaben und so, sondern die Erfahrung hier ist und das ist meine auch. Nee, man widmet, also ich gebe nicht dir einen KI-Agenten, der dann zehn Aufgaben für dich übernimmt, sondern jemand baut einen KI-Agenten, der eine Aufgabe besonders gut kann und an den wendet man sich, wenn man diese Aufgabe zu erledigen hat. Und das ist ein sehr anderes Paradigma, denn das bedeutet, in dieser Firma arbeiten nicht 30 Leute, die alle KI-Assistenzen haben, sondern in dieser Firma arbeiten einfach 60 Mitarbeiter, 30 davon menschlich, 30 sind KI-Agenten. Und jeder Mitarbeiter kann mit jedem reden. Also jeder KI-Agent kann mit jedem Menschen interagieren und so weiter. Wodurch sich Sandwich-Systeme ergeben. Am Anfang steht immer ein Mensch, der entweder den KI-Agenten eine Aufgabe gibt, also ihr wirklich eine Aufgabe delegiert, und danach muss er das Ergebnis annehmen, überprüfen, weiterverarbeiten. Also am Anfang, am Ende steht ein Mensch. Oder es ist halt grundsätzlich jemand für diesen KI-Agenten zuständig, denn er muss ja ständig betreut werden. Eine ganz wichtige Erfahrung hier, dass man, das sind keine Selbstlernenden-Systeme, sondern die machen eine Datenverarbeitung im Rahmen eines bestimmten Framings, für das vollständig der Mensch zuständig ist. Man kann zwar den KI-Agenten-Challenge errormäßig was machen lassen, aber man muss immer wieder selber sagen, was man eigentlich will, weil die KI will ja nichts. Also ein sehr hartes Plädoyer für diese reine Datenverarbeitung, wie das der Papst beschrieben hat. Er selbst, also der Shipper, sitzt den ganzen Tag im Terminal, wie so viele. Man benutzt also nicht mehr so richtig Software und bedient Oberflächen, sondern man sagt jetzt dem Computer, was man will, was für ihn bedeutet. Das ist dann auch interessant zu lesen, finde ich. Er sitzt halt da, schreibt diesen Text auch im Terminal, sei dann einfach den Codex-Browser offen, sagt, was er will, gestaltet, schreibt aber nicht jeden Satz selbst, so wie auch die Leute, die Software nicht mal selber schreiben, sondern sich einfach blockweise angucken, was da so passiert und das dann so ein bisschen machen. So, man darf die KI nicht verweisen lassen. Also wenn sich keiner um sie kümmert, ist sie sofort unbrauchbar. Sie muss betreut werden, so wie alle Mitarbeiter betreut werden müssen. Wichtige Lernerfahrung. Bedeutet aber für ihn, also wenn er E-Mails schreibt, er sitzt da, liest eine E-Mail, fängt dann an, über diese E-Mail zu reden. Das wird dann in einen Transkript verwandelt und die KI weiß dann, was zu tun ist. Er auch schon überlegt, ob ich nicht meine eigenen Notizzettel, bevor ich hier in den Podcast komme, nicht selber nochmal mündlich durchgehe, um dann klo zu sagen, und daraus organisierst du jetzt die Anpassung, damit es dann im Podcastgespräch nicht erst nochmal über nachgedacht werden muss, so, sondern dann auch die Namen an der richtigen Stelle sind oder so. Wenn ich jetzt bei Stefan Kühl so, wo steht nochmal der Name und entfinden man es nicht in dem Moment, sondern kann man das nicht einfach nur durch Gespräch nochmal leisten. So, diese Wartung bedeutet Arbeit. KI-Agenten machen Arbeit und das, sagt er, ist die neue Arbeit. Also man geht nicht in eine Fabrik und ist die ganze Zeit erschüttert darüber, dass die Maschinen viel stärker sind als die Menschen, sondern man versucht dieses Verhältnis aus menschlicher und maschineller Arbeit jetzt zu organisieren, was selbst Arbeit ist, aber halt andere und neue Arbeit. Aber Arbeit. Und hier sagt er auch, und das habe ich heute morgen wieder gelesen, dass Antropik, also Antropik hat heute morgen eine Insta-Kachel gemacht, mehrere, so eine Insta-Story, aber als dauerhaftes Ding, wo sie sagen, sie sind kurz davor, den Loop zu schließen, dass sich die KI selbst weiterentwickelt. Ich denke, das glaube ich nicht. Also schreiben ja eh viele mir gegenüber, dass Clot Mythos ist schon wieder eine Werbekampagne oder was auch immer. Da würde ich sagen, das vielleicht nicht. Also da gilt einfach das Fleißdiktum. Die Maschine ist einfach gut, weil sie so fleißig ist. Bei diesem, den Loop zu schließen, glaube ich das aber schon.
Ich halte das auch für unsinnig.
Denn Amo.die wird niemals seine Entwickler entlassen, weil sich Clot selber entwickelt. Niemals. Also wird einfach nicht passieren. So und so schreiben die das hier nämlich auch.
Vielleicht könnte Clot dann auch Amo.die entlassen.
Genau. Das wäre dann sozusagen die Konsequenz. Genau. Also, dass wir heute diesen ganzen Slop erleben, bedeutet ja nur, dass sehr viele Menschen wiederholen, was andere Menschen schon gemacht haben. Das wird natürlich dann variiert auf die eigenen Inhalte und so. Aber es ist im Grunde eine Wiederholung, der das andere, das Lebendige und vor allem, das Situationspassende fehlt. Also man nimmt sich Vorlagen, die man zwar inhaltlich unterfüttert mit den eigenen Anliegen, aber die man, wenn man ehrlich ist, auch ästhetisch nochmal anpassen könnte. Nur man hat ja gar keine Ahnung wie. Dann sagt man, der Klot, machen wir einen zweiten Vorschlag, ja? So, und dann ist man sozusagen im Endlosen. So, also das andere, das Lebendige, das Situationsgenaue, das geht verloren. Das wird aber immer mehr gefragt dadurch, dass immer mehr Leute sowas im Grunde machen können. Also du hast immer diesen letzten Schritt, der zehn Prozent, mit dem du dich dann abhebst. Wenn Arbeit im Überfluss vorhanden ist und überall gleich aussieht, wird die Arbeit, die nicht in das Muster passt, zur seltenen, wertvollen und hochragigen Sache, da würde ich sogar sagen, für die Künstler bedeutet das, menschliche Arbeit kann sich da jetzt besondere Plätze erarbeiten. Denn der Mehrwert in künstlerischen, ästhetischen oder auch gesellschaftlichen Sachen ist ja nicht, dass eine KI irgendwas gemacht hat, sondern dass es überhaupt Beiträge gibt, von denen, würde ich sagen, abgesehen von den Fleißarbeiten, also wirklich genug übrig bleibt, um Beiträge zu leisten. Die Nachfrage nach dem, was anders ist, ist die Nachfrage nach menschlichen Experten, selbst wenn wir uns der künstlichen Allgemeinintelligenz nähern. Also selbst eine allgemeine künstliche Intelligenzdefinition, wie er sie findet, nämlich, dass die Maschinen können dauerhaft arbeiten und haben immer was zu tun, heißt noch lange nicht, dass man sie nicht zumindest mal am Lenkrad kurz betätigen muss, um zu sagen, wir biegen ihr Zimmer um oder so. Also das ist wirklich ganz wichtig. Er hatte gleich eine super coole, also wirklich eine ganz tolle, eine ganz tolle Pointe. KI ersetzt die Wissensarbeit menschlicher Experten nicht. Sie erhöht das Arbeitsvolumen dramatisch, Schluss war mit er heute, und keine dieser Arbeiten ist wertvoll, wenn kein Mensch daran beteiligt ist. Also das können wir, glaube ich, also bei dem, was wir als Internetinhalte heute vor allem auf Meta-Plattformen sehen, Slop ist ein echtes, ernsthaftes Problem. Und ich würde auch ein Human Label jetzt erfinden, nach dem man filtern kann und sagen, ne, mich interessiert das mal vor, eigentlich ist es von den Menschen gemacht, weil ansonsten hat man echt mit so einer Bedeutungslosigkeit zu tun. Also eine Million Dollar für Clips. Also wie viel Podcastgrundlage hat er denn geschaffen, um für eine Million Clips zu machen? Ja, dass das versloppung ist, ist ja völlig klar. Nun gut, eine Sache, die er beschreibt, die ich ganz interessant finde, ist, das habe ich auch schon mal angesprochen, im Text beschreibt er das auch. Wir müssen uns ein bisschen selber noch aus dem Spiel nehmen, denn man versucht immer, so ein Paradigme aufzubauen, dass wir heute einfach nur der Maschine sagen müssen, was sie machen soll und dann macht sie es. Die Maschine muss aber selber verstehen, was eigentlich das Problem ist, weil sie dann die Lösung ableiten kann, die sehr viel besser zu dem Problem passt, weil die Maschine das Problem verstanden hat. Und das würde ich auch immer wieder als Tipp geben, nicht Claude einfach sagen, was man will, sondern Claude fragen, ob er das Problem verstanden hat, also ihn so ein bisschen auf, also elementare Beziehungsgestaltung machen, ein Fundament schaffen, auf dem Claude dann die Fleißarbeit machen kann. Aber wenn man zu spezifisch Claude sagt, was er machen soll, dann kennt er die Richtung nicht. Also man muss hier fast ein bisschen Management, methodenmäßig Claude wieder Beinfreiheit geben, statt ihn so in so ein Assistenzding rein zu navigieren. Also das ist bei ihm gut beschrieben. Und jetzt hat er hier diese Pointe, die ich wirklich sehr, sehr gut finde. Zum einen, die KIs sind autonom, aber sind keine Agenten. Sie haben einfach nur eine Autonomie. Und wir kommen da schnell in Verwechslung. Und jetzt wirklich, als würde das vom Papst beauftragt sein, das Argument, macht er folgende Pointe. Er beschreibt, und hier hat er dieses Zenos Paradox vorher aufgegriffen. Also zwei ungleich schnelle Läufer, aber der eine kriegt einen Vorsprung. In dem Falle eine Schildkröte. Also das Märchen kennen alle so ein bisschen. Ich kannte es auch aus irgendwie Kinderbüchern. Und dann versucht man, die Schildkröte einzuholen. Aber die Schildkröte macht ja auch, wenn langsamer, immer auch einen Fortschritt. Also diese Distanz ist einfach immer unklar. Irgendwann wird man überholt in diesem Märchen dann nicht, weil, im Moment, wo man Strecke gemacht hat, hat die Schildkröte auch wieder Strecke gemacht. Und hier sagt er jetzt, und hier bricht das Zenos Paradox der KI zusammen. Also da wird unsere Verwechslung jetzt offenbar. Es ist ein verworrenes Gedankenexperiment. Die Metapher, die wir aufstellen, zeigt eine KI, die gegen uns antritt und uns dicht auf den Fersen ist. Soweit so klar. Du gibst einem Modell eine Eingabe, es läuft ein Rennen, das du gewohnt bist, selbst zu laufen. Also hier beginnt die Verwechslung. Das Modell startet blitzschnell aus den Startblöcken, erschreckend schnell. Es ist leistungsstark, unermüdlich und seltsam organisch. Das macht das Rennen für dich noch wichtiger. Du würdest niemals, sagt er jetzt, gegen ein Auto antreten. Aber das hier, was jetzt gerade stattfindet, das kommt dir vertraut vor. Also niemand würde mit einem Auto um die Wette rennen, weil er war völlig glas. Ja, es ist ein Auto. Aber jetzt rennen wir aber gegen die KI um die Wette, statt unsere neuen Positionen da zu finden. Du sitzt da und beobachtest, wie die Token hypnotisierend hereinströbeln und du beginnst dir vorzustellen, wie du selbst in diesem Rennen mitläufst. Ein Geist deiner selbst, der sich auf die Bahn legt, mal vor, mal gleich auf mit dem Modell. Also man versucht da so eine Konkurrenzsituation. Und ehe du dich versiehst, ist das Modell voraus. Du schwitzt und dann ist das Rennen vorbei. Man spürt fast, wie die Muskeln zu verkümmern beginnen, nutzlos angesichts dieser mechanischen Kopie von einem selbst und allem und allen, die man je getroffen hat, der gesamten Menschheit. Ein Geist, der einen Geist jagt und gewinnt. So, also wenn wir einfach die Welt weiter so sehen wie bisher. Wir gehen in die Schule, lernen dort schreiben, dann das leicht wissenschaftliche Schreiben, um in der Uni das richtig wissenschaftliche Schreiben zu lernen und dann am Arbeitsplatz eine wissenschaftliche Auswertung machen zu müssen. Und dann stellen wir fest, dass kann die KI viel besser. Dann darf man dieses Rennen ruhig verloren geben, weil es gibt ja noch andere Arbeit zu erledigen. Gerade dadurch, dass jetzt die Bedingung dadurch, dass man immer einen guten Wissenschaftler ja bei sich hat und man es nicht mehr selber so penibel sein muss, findet man ja auch ein neues Fundament für die Arbeit, die man tut. Bedeutet aber, in Schlussfolgerung, man kann das halt nicht mehr ohne KI machen. Das ist das eigentliche Novum. Aber wenn man es mit KI macht, darf man sich nicht in Konkurrenz zur KI versetzen, sondern muss die Potenziale der KI als Grundlage nehmen. Man kann sich dann sogar noch darüber freuen, dass man einschätzen kann, was die KI macht, weil man sozusagen auf selben Gebiete ausgebildet ist. Und dann macht man einfach die Sachen, die die KI nicht kann. Und dann sagt er völlig zurecht, davon bleibt ja viel übrig, weil die KI kann ja gar nichts. Also ich sage ihr, was ihr machen soll. Und bei der Frage, was soll sie machen, definiert man ja die Ausgangssituation, das Ziel und der ganze andere Kram. Und das finde ich einen sehr klugen Gedanken. Kommt natürlich ein bisschen verschmitzt daher, niemand würde mit einem Autom die Wette reden, weil es auf der einen Seite so albern wirkt, aber es ist eben, genau das ist das Argument. Und die Menschheit hat es sehr gut geschafft, die körperliche Überlegenheit von Maschinen zu bewältigen. Also wir fühlen uns heute wirklich nicht mehr gekränkt, wenn wir einfach eine Maschine in Anspruch nehmen, so Fahrstuhl fahren. Keiner sagt dann, ey, ich kann so viel besser Treppen laufen, ich bin viel schneller als der Fahrstuhl. Ja, keiner macht es, das wäre einfach völlig dumm. Und so kann man das jetzt auch mit den kognitiven Arbeit machen. Also diesen Kränkungsmoment jetzt mal überwinden, aber da würde ich eben sagen, muss man halt den Papst richtig ernst nehmen. Da darf man nicht einfach drüber hinwegnehmen, wenn der Papst sagt, das ist Datenverarbeitung, da ist nichts Lebendiges drin, da ist keine Orientierung drin und da kommt auch nichts bei rum, außer man will was von der Maschine und fordert es von ihr auch ein.
Die Bundesvorsitzende der Grünen, Franziska Brantner, hat sich gedacht, ich muss mal aufschreiben, was ich über den Liberalismus denke, bzw. muss für einen neuen Liberalismus plädieren. So ist auch dann der Text überschrieben, der in den Blättern erschienen ist. Das heißt, hier schreibt eine Politikerin eine Programmatik auf. Jetzt ja nicht so sehr nur an Wähler gerichtet, sondern an eigene Leute, die die Blätter lesen, beziehungsweise andere, die möglicherweise jetzt enttäuscht sind, dass Strack Zimmermann es nicht geworden sind, gibt es hier vielleicht ein Angebot. Also war ich erst einmal neugierig, wie ist das mit einem Text, der heißt Für einen neuen Liberalismus, warum Freiheit, Gerechtigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit zusammengehören? Gerechtigkeit, würde ich jetzt aus einer linken Perspektive sagen, ist ja schon das falsche Wort. Es müsste um Gleichheit gehen. Gerechtigkeit, damit kann man alles Mögliche machen. Beziehungsweise was ist der gerechte Lohn? Ja, da können wir lange diskutieren. Das sind also müßige, recht bürgerliche Debatten. Aber ich erwarte jetzt auch da gar nichts anderes. Worum geht es hier? Also der Text beginnt mit, wer angesichts der gewaltigen Herausforderungen der Gegenwart über die Aufgaben der Politik grundsätzlicher nachdenkt, stößt unweigerlich auf die Grundideen unserer Moderne, vor allem auf Liberalismus, Konservatismus und Sozialismus, aber inzwischen auch auf einen vergleichsweise jungen Mitspieler, das ökologische Denken. Dann fasst sie zusammen, dass das ökologische Denken wichtig ist. Sozialismus wird dann auch nicht mehr aufgegriffen, sondern dann ist von Sozialdemokratie die Rede. Die Grünen seien ja auch lang nicht mehr nur eine Partei, die auf das Thema Ökologie konzentriert sei, sondern vieles ergebe sich ja jetzt nun in einem Zusammenspiel. Und ja, da gibt es auch Wertkonservatismus. Zum Beispiel wird nochmal deutlich hervorgehoben die Ideen von Winfried Kretschmann, die man beherzigen kann. Kretschmann macht das Konservare, das heute nötig ist, vor allem am Erhalt der Schöpfung und Demokratiefest parallel zu…
Und an der Autoindustrie.
parallel zu seinen eher konservativ orientierten Überlegungen, kann es der Grünen Debatte aber nur gut tun, wenn sie auch ihre Bezüge zum Liberalismus genauer durchdenkt. Also hier fällt schon mal auf, zum Sozialismus brauchen wir uns nicht zu bekennen. Das ist egal. Zum Konservativen, das macht also Kretschmann jetzt. Kretschmann, jetzt brauchen wir also noch den Liberalismus. Das bedeutet, dass man sich erst einmal von dem Liberalismus abgrenzt, wenn man nicht will, namentlich von Christian Lindner. Dessen FDP wird ja hier nochmal dann beschrieben, wie das so war mit dem D-Day-Papier und überhaupt mit so einer Forderung mehr Millet und Mask wagen. Selbstredend ist das nicht gemeint. Von Liberalismus will sie aber sprechen deshalb, weil ja gerade auch gegenteilige Positionen stark sind, nämlich zum Beispiel Viktor Orban, der die illiberale Demokratie sich wünscht. Dieses Konzept will die Gewaltenteilung und die Freiheitsgarantien der liberalen Demokratie außer Kraft setzen. Mit der Politik Donald Trumps nagt ein solcher Illiberalismus heute direkt am Herzen der westlichen Demokratie. Auch um die liberale Demokratie wieder für große Mehrheiten attraktiv zu machen, benötigen wir die inspirierende Idee eines neuen Liberalismus. Leider geht sie an keiner Stelle darauf ein, was dann eigentlich eine illiberale Demokratie genau ist. Auch beschreibt sie nicht, was ich ja mit dem Buch von Jörg Barbarowski sehr deutlich gemacht habe oder auch schon mit älteren Sachen von Manu, die ich hier vorgestellt habe, dass der Demokratie und Liberalismus nicht notwendig miteinander zusammengehen müssen. Aber das wird hier dann nicht übersehen, sondern es genügt, wenn man sagt, ja, also so wie Orban natürlich nicht. Und wer will dem widersprechen? Aber damit ist ja eigentlich relativ wenig gesagt. Was ist dann damit gemeint? Was will man noch nicht? Also die Exzesse des Neoliberalismus. Das wird dann hier auch nochmal beschrieben, bei denen ich ja sagen würde, tragen die Grünen ja immer noch diese Exzesse mit. Beziehungsweise haben ja nicht eine radikal andere anti-neoliberale Politik gemacht, als sie regiert haben. Und immerhin sitzt ja Franziska Brantner seit 2013, im Bundestag. Jetzt plädiert sie für einen ökologischen und sozialen Liberalismus. Da heißt es, die liberale Idee befindet sich heute in einer tiefen Krise, doch sie ist keinesfalls tot. Sie benötigt dringend eine neue Formulierung, keine verengte, sondern eine attraktive und zukunftsfähige Version, die bei der Lösung der Probleme unserer Zeit helfen und orientieren kann. Und da die Wirklichkeit sich nicht unter eine einzige Idee bringen lässt, geht es dabei nicht um Schlagworte und Spielkarten in einer PR-Show, sondern um eine tragfähige Verbindung von Ideen und Konzepten, um unsere komplexe Wirklichkeit zu bewältigen. Die Lösung kann meines Erachtens nur in einer klugen Verbindung von ökologischen, sozialen und liberalen Orientierungen liegen, die Freiheit, Gerechtigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit zusammendenkt. Was damit jetzt aber genau gemeint ist, beschreibt sie nicht näher, sondern das wird irgendwie alles so miteinander verbunden. Das heißt, man sagt hier, wir sind die Partei der Mitte und alles, was ihnen wichtig ist, ein bisschen konservativ, ein bisschen Sozialdemokratie und natürlich der Liberalismus, das haben wir alles auf dem Schirm. Wir müssen nur dafür sorgen, dass wir nicht so einen Neoliberalismus machen wie Christian Lindner. Stattdessen will sie Leitplanken für eine kluge Ordnungspolitik, also ordoliberal, will sie eigentlich aber ein bisschen mehr Leitplanke. Denn dann könne man die Kräfte des Marktes zu einem mächtigen Hebel für Umweltschutz machen. Da sehen wir jetzt an keiner Stelle, wo das wirklich stattfindet. Eine Kernaufgabe des neuen Liberalismus besteht deshalb darin, die Markkräfte gerade an dieser Stelle geballt und gezielt zu mobilisieren, um so mehr Umweltschutz zu erreichen. Nun, das ist ja immer noch diese Idee, wenn man es mit ein bisschen Preisen und so macht, dann wird sich das schon alles mobilisieren. Das findet ja nicht statt. Also, das ist ja jetzt nochmal zu sagen, die Markkräfte werden den ökologischen Wandel herbeiführen. Wo, frage ich mich, wo findet das statt? Sie sagt dann, aber klar ist auch, der Staat kann selbst nicht alles richten. Wir brauchen einen neuen Fokus auf Innovation und eine Politik, die hilft, neue Ideen in der Wirtschaft zu verwirklichen. Und streckenweise muss der Staat sich auch zurücknehmen. Wir brauchen eine grüne Entbürokratisierung, die künstlichen, aus Überregulierungen oder endlosen Genehmigungsverfahren entstehenden Verknappungen auf den Märkten entgegentritt. Nötig ist auch mehr Wettbewerb, vor allem auch gegen einen wieder auflebenden Oligarchismus und Monopolismus. Dann kommt sie auf die Tech-Pros zu sprechen. Ja, der Wettbewerb ist ja ein internationaler. Wie stellt man sich jetzt dem entgegen? Das würde ja bedeuten, man muss also die Tech-Konzerne aussperren. Da bin ich gespannt auf diese transatlantische Auseinandersetzung.
Welche auf den gegen?
Ja, ich frage mich wirklich, was soll das sein? Es heißt dann, dass wir einen liberalen Internationalismus brauchen, um private Supermächte zu kontrollieren. Wohl ist der Internationalismus jetzt gerade mit Deutschland, das nicht mal in den Sicherheitsrat da kommt. Wo ist der herzustellen? Dazu brauchen wir keinen neuen Neoliberalismus, sondern Wettbewerb als Instrument für die Freiheit der einzelnen und für marktorientierte Unternehmen gegen Monopolismus und Oligarchismus. Ich glaube, das ist so diese Idee. Ich greife mal so einen Gedanken von Amy Klobuchar auf und glaube, dass ich den jetzt von Deutschland aus ventilieren kann, um dann Tech-Konzernen im Silicon Valley zu zerstören. Das geht von Amerika aus. Kann man das versuchen, wie Klobuchar und andere das tun? Aber von hier aus bin ich sehr gespannt. Wo Kindern und Jugendlichen der Zugang zu Bildung erschwert wird, wird auch die Freiheit im zukünftigen Leben selbstbestimmter Wege zu gehen, zutiefst beschnitten. Da können wir zustimmen. Sie plädiert dafür, dass man die Ganztagsangebote ausweitet, dass die Schüler nicht getrennt werden nach der vierten Klasse. Das ist ja eine uralte Forderung der Grünen, hat jetzt mit Liberalismus wenig zu tun. Ein zeitgemäßer und moderner Liberalismus steht aber zugleich gegen etatistische und kollektivistische Konzepte, womit also sehr klar gesagt wird, hier bitte nicht Enteignung, bitte nicht Wohnungsbau. Nicht volkseigene Betriebe, keine Kollektivierung. Also alles, was für Gesellschaft und meint, dann nicht. Er setzt auf die Verantwortung und Selbstwirksamkeit der Bürgerinnen und Bürger. Also eigentlich doch das neoliberale Selbst, nur ein bisschen besser abgefedert, beziehungsweise nicht in so einer Kettensägen-Rhetorik vorgebracht. Hier heißt es dann weiter, man will, sie beruft sich nochmal auf Winfried Kretschmann, eine Politik des Gehörtwerdens. Wirst du gehört, Stefan?
Ich fühle mich vor den Grünen vor allem, dass sie mir zuhören.
Soll ich dich rufen, dann wirst du gehört. Ein neuer Liberalismus führt auch die Arbeit der großen Liberalen Gerhard Baum fort. Ihr könnt, sie hat jetzt nicht hingeschrieben, Strack Zimmermann, aber Gerhard Baum und Strack Zimmermann ist ja so eine Linie. Der sich zeitlebens für Bürger- und Menschenrechte und gegen den Überwachungsstaat engagierte, der starke Grundrechte als Bollwerk gegen staatliche Willkür verstand und den Liberalismus kämpferisch gegen einen erstarkten Populismus in Stellung brachte. So, das bedeutet dann...
Ich finde, sowas dürfen die Grünen gar nicht schreiben, solange sie Palantir-Entscheidungen treffen. Also einfach richtig verbotend, das zu schreiben, weil sie können ausschließlich lügen.
Ja. Also ich bin wirklich sehr... Also ich verstehe gar nicht, wie man darauf kommen kann. Dann beschwört sie den föderalen Wettbewerb, dass der doch was bringen könnte. Immer wieder kommt sie darauf zurück, dass das, was die Neoliberalen wollen, vulgärliberal ist. Aber dann redet sie die ganze Zeit von Wettbewerb, wo man sagen muss, ja Wettbewerb funktioniert so, dass Verlierer produziert werden. Wenn ich aber hier im Ganzen über einen Staat nachdenke und will das für alle gut machen, dann kann der Wettbewerb vielleicht wenig dienlich sein, sondern kontraproduktiv sein. Wenn ich mich aber von dieser Wettbewerbsideologie nicht löse, dann komme ich natürlich sehr schnell dahin, dass ich eigentlich all diese Versprechen, die ich da machen will, gar nicht halten kann. Beziehungsweise, naja, sie macht ja eigentlich auch noch kaum Versprechen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist. Das ist ein Text, der dann zum Schluss auf die Verteidigung der Freiheit eingeht. Und damit meint sie dann in erster Linie Aufrüstung. Und da sagt sie auch nochmal, manche werden sich vielleicht gewundert haben, warum die Grünen so sehr für Aufrüstung sind. Aber das sei ja vollkommen klar, weil ja die Grünen immer für Selbstbestimmungsrechte waren. Bei den Frauen, bei den Homosexuellen und jetzt eben auch für die Ukraine und Selbstbestimmung für Europa im militärischer Hinsicht. Also jetzt wird einfach unter diesem Begriff Selbstbestimmung so getan, als sei man immer in diese Richtung marschiert. Da heißt es dann, die Fähigkeit, sich selbst schützen zu können, gilt schließlich auch gegenüber den Populisten und Extremisten im Inneren. Und ich meine, wir reden jetzt hier über einen Text, der das Thema Liberalismus hat und Meinungsfreiheit kommt bislang nicht vor. Wir sehen jetzt beim zweitletzten Abschnitt des Textes. Und dann heißt es da, über diese Extremisten im Inneren, diese sehen ihren Hauptfeind in der liberalen Mitte, in der Demokratie, in Presse- und Meinungsfreiheit und Gewaltenteilung. Diese Institutionen wollen sie überwinden, um für den Illiberalismus und Autokratismus, den sie anstreben, Platz zu schaffen. OK, kann man jetzt so mitgehen? Wenn man sich auch fragen muss, wollen die alle jetzt die Pressefreiheit abschaffen? Dann heißt es hier eine neue Formulierung der liberalen Idee. Muss diesen national wie international agierenden Gegner ja Feind der Freiheit klar adressieren? Denn genau hier finden die liberale Toleranz und der Kampf für Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung eine Grenze. Keine Toleranz für die Intoleranz. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, das ist ja in dem Sinne unsinnig. Also ich weiß natürlich, ich kann natürlich sagen, ja, es gibt eine Form von Verfassungsfeindschaft oder so, die ist nicht mit Meinungsfreiheit oder so gedeckt. Aber ganz viel, was gerade an Meinung artikuliert ist, ist Meinungsfreiheit und das mag man nicht gerne hören. Und wir wissen aber, wie weit die Meinungsfreiheit gehen kann. Und dann muss man genau, und das gehört zur freiheitlichen Grundordnung dazu, eine Toleranz gegenüber auch Leuten haben. Und selbst wenn sie sagen, ich hätte gerne lieber die Monarchie, dann ist das so. Da kann ich nicht sagen, keine Toleranz, weil das würde ja den Rückschluss sehen. Dann verbieten wir da das Kunstfestival, schließen dort die Redaktion bei Jürgen Elsesser oder was weiß ich wem. Und das geht einfach nicht, dann ist man nicht liberal. Also dann ist mal was anderes, aber dann ist man nicht liberal. Und das finde ich wirklich erstaunlich, dass wir hier, wenn es um die Pressefreiheit geht, eigentlich nur nochmal erklärt bekommen, keine Toleranz für Intoleranz. Wobei ja dann immer zu fragen ist, wer legt dann fest, was denn hier gerade eine intolerante Meinung ist. Da sind wir ja schon wieder bei unserem Buch, das wir besprochen haben. Die Losung muss heute alle Parteien im Verfassungsbogen der liberalen Demokratien vereinen. Sie muss auch ihren kollegialen Umgang untereinander bestimmen. Also alle sollen sich jetzt quasi zu so einer Front verbinden gegen die AfD. Auch angesichts einer extremistischen Gefahr wie der AfD bleibt in den Parlamenten wie in der Zivilgesellschaft viel Platz für die kritische und harte Debatte im Sinne von Darendorf aber kein Platz für eine wechselseitige Ausgrenzung, Diffamierung der Demokraten untereinander. Und so möchte sie einen ökologisch und sozial sensiblen Liberalismus haben.
Ja, Darendorf Baum, hat sie keine eigene Parteiengeschichte?
Winfried Kretschmann.
Ah ja, Winfried Kretschmann. Also ich finde solche Politiker, bei denen völlig klar ist, dass sie wenig Zeit haben, sollten vielleicht die Blätter mehr lesen als schreiben?
Zehn Seiten schreibt sie da. Warum meinst du, schreibt sie, ich hab's mir auch noch nicht beantworten können, schreibt sie zehn Seiten über diesen Liberalismus? Ist das jetzt so, dass man sagt, die einen versuchen, die CDU reinzuholen? Das macht jetzt mal so Cem Özdemir.
Also die Blätter haben 11.000 Abonnenten. Ich glaube nicht, dass jenseits dir, außerdem läuft es selbst in den Blättern noch unter Marginalien. Was ich einen sehr witzigen, äh...
Nee, nee, das läuft nicht unter Marginalien.
Ist nicht Marginalien?
Unter Analysen und Alternativen.
Ah ja, OK. Aber im neuen Format gibt es immer noch Marginalien, ne? Ich hab auch mal Marginalien geschrieben. Ich find's eigentlich witzig, dass man das so Marginalien nennt.
Debatte gibt es.
Gibt's keine Marginalien mehr? Ach, schade. Nein, nein, nein. Ist ja nur...
Aber du kannst es dir auch nicht erklären, warum sie das verpassen.
Nein, das kann niemand erklären.
Ich denke aber, es sind ja so programmatische Texte für die interne Bubble, dass jetzt ein paar Journalisten das mitbekommen. Das ist dann so, wie Banaschak schon mal sagt, ja, Kündigungsschutz, da müssen wir wirklich mal ein bisschen lockern. Also jeder sagt jetzt mal gerade so ein bisschen was, was in die Mitte sich bewegen soll.
Also vielleicht ist das das Beste an dem Text, das sie noch glaubt, jemand liest. Nicht mal Studenten in der Prüfungswoche im Seminar lesen die Texte, die ihnen aufgetragen wurde, von denen sie wissen, wir sind hier nur fünf Leute. Wenn keiner gelesen hat, wird es ein bisschen awkward. Von daher.
Also meinst du, ich bin der einzige Leser dieses Textes vielleicht am Ende.
Die Idee, dass Franziska Brantner mit Journalisten zusammen ist, die ihren Text gelesen haben, ist völlig wahnsinnig.
Ja, es könnte sein. Ja, also dieser neue Liberalismus wartet auf dich, Stefan.
Kommen wir zur Bachelorarbeit von Sebastian Huber. Ich möchte hier dazusagen vorher, dass es ja bei jungen aufstrebenden, sehr guten Wissenschaftlern immer so, dass sie natürlich sehr ambitioniert sind. Ich werde also nicht die ganze Arbeit vorstellen, lieber Sebastian, sondern nur den Teil, der für den Herr Hegemon und für uns super interessant ist. Trotzdem die Empfehlung, es genau so zu machen. Also Hausarbeiten so über die Stränge schlagen zu schreiben, dass ich jetzt mit dem Einstiegskommentar komme. Du hast ja gerade Gramsci, den immer alle wieder mit und so. Die Teufel sind da, aber die neue Welt ist noch nicht geboren, wie auch immer.
Die Monster sind es.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, wenn man behauptet, die neue Welt sei noch nicht geboren, hat man vielleicht nicht richtig hingeschaut. Das könnte man aber sich dann als Auftrag nehmen und genau so herangehen, wie Sebastian das hier macht. Also einfach eine Sache beschreiben, auch wenn sie nicht so aussieht, wie das davor. Sondern genau diese Differenz dann markieren. Und das hat er hier hervorragend gemacht. Es geht also um Charlie Kirk, der am 10. September 2025 erschossen wird und offenbar ein Herrn Hegemon war. Weshalb über den Begriff der narrativen Hegemonie, die er für sich reklamierte, die ihm angedichtet wurde, von der ich sage, genau das macht es interessant, das mal zu hinterfragen. Also Charlie Kirk wird erschossen während eines Prove-me-wrong-Events an der Utah Valley University. Und die Berichterstattung kippt in mehrere Phasen danach. Klar gibt es erst die Trauerschock und so weiter. Und dann ist so eine Aufarbeitung, mit was haben wir es jetzt eigentlich zu tun? Und genau dieser Diskussion wendet er sich zu und versucht auch zu beschreiben, was man hier vor sich hat. Ähm, vielleicht ist nicht ein zu wenig an Diskurs das Problem. Also man sieht da Brantner, die dann schon den nächsten Text schreibt, das wir jetzt wieder mal diskutieren sollten oder was auch immer. Sondern die Möglichkeit, Diskursformen zu zeigen, ohne Diskursbedingungen einzulösen. Also vielleicht ist ja ganz viel Diskurs da, aber nicht nach den Bedingungen, nach denen wir bisher gesagt haben, das ist ein Diskurs. Ähm, Leute gucken heute zehn Stunden am Tag YouTube Shorts und alle so, das interessiert mich nicht, weil das ist ja da kein Diskurs. Können wir bitte eine Nachkritik schreiben, was Sandra Maischberger gestern debattierte und so alle, aber das hat doch keiner gesehen. Ja, also man kann sich ja auch dem einfach zuwenden. So, es hat er also gemacht. Es gibt 19 TikTok-Clips, die er ausgewertet hat, die unter The Charlie Kirk Show liefen, also von ihm selbst publiziert. 383 Millionen Views, also pro Clip 20 Millionen. Da würde ich sagen, daraus ergibt sich Diskurs. Also das bedeutet einfach Diskurs. Jetzt kann man einfach sagen, also anhand der Reichweite ist das Diskurs. Wir schauen uns jetzt an, was da war, egal ob welchen Bedingungen das entgegenkommt oder nicht. Und hier ist nun das Postulat der Narrativen Hegemonie, die zu finden ist, wo sie ist, egal ob es nach gewohnten Sehkriterien, Sehgewohnheiten abläuft oder nicht. Die narrativen Strukturen ordnen Klassifikationen und Phänomen Dimensionen so, dass ein dominanter Frame entsteht und damit institutionsähnlich wird, was vor allem bedeutet, es ist stabil. Die Leute sehen Charlie Kirk Clip und wissen, was das ist. Anders als Medienwissenschaftler, die sich fragen, wo sind das? Sondern allein, wenn man es schon so oft gesehen hatte, weiß man, was es ist und bleibt dran. Das heißt, hier wirken neue, wenn auch erst mal nur implizite Regeln auch der Interpretation. Was bedeutet, wir haben es hier mit Diskurs zu tun, auch wenn er, wie er das entfaltet, ganz wunderbar, simulierter Diskurs ist. Also wir sehen einige Sachen, die wir wiedererkennen, zum Beispiel zwei Leute im Disput. Aber nicht im Fernsehstudio, sondern da steht da jemand so zufällig gerade, warum auch immer, da sind 10.000 Leute und einer geht halt ans Mikrofon. Aber es ist trotzdem Disput, auch wenn völlig zufällig. Das heißt, es stehen Begründungen inhaltlich im Raum, es gibt eine Gegenrede, es gibt Revisionsoptionen. Aber dann ist die Frage, wie ist das eigentlich verteilt? Also Charlie Kirk bleibt auf seinem Sitz sitzen und das Mikrofon muss halt geräumt werden nach zwei Minuten. Der Clip geht 20 Sekunden. Also alles, das mal rein betrachtet, wird von ihm einfach toll analysiert. Und dann, und das finde ich dann interessant, weil es jetzt sehr nah an die Herr Hegemon Diskussion ranrückt, die wir alle mal führen müssten. Wie sieht diese neue Selbstinstitutionalisierung aus? Warum ist für Leute, die das als Clip kurz sehen, plötzlich die Bedeutung so hoch, als würden sie heute schon allgucken? Weil, Turning Point USA, Charlie Kirk, kenn ich doch, Format geil, da öffnet jemand Diskurse. Später wird Esra Klein schreiben, der hat Politik genau richtig gemacht und so. Also das ist ja, so hat man auch nicht übers heute schon all geredet. Das ist ja kurz vor Staatsfundament. So, und genau das muss man ernst nehmen und dann auswerten. Und da geht es dann der Reihe nach durch und schaut sich dieses Mechanismenbündel einfach an, wie dieser simulierte Diskurs und grifflich finde ich auch sehr gut, einfach zustande kommt. Gemeinsinn Formate, die deliberative Signale senden. Da würde ich auch sagen, also mein soziologisches Interesse ist ja sozusagen Diskurs jenseits von Deliberation. Wenn Menschen zusammentreffen und Gespräche führen, ist es ja für mich schon wieder uninteressant. Ich will ja wissen, wie Sachen passieren, ohne dass man ins Gespräch kommt. Also man hat hier offene Mikrofone, diese Debatten-Touren, Publikumseinbindung, damit auch wieder Publikumsanbindung von Zuschauern, weil die ja in dem Moment, wo es kein Monolog ist des Professoren, sondern ein Disput zwischen zwei gleichaltrigen Identifikationen stattfinden, man schlägt sich auf irgendeine Seite und so. Und dann geht man zum nächsten Clip und guckt, ob das noch stabil ist oder nicht. Und daraus erwächst ja eine eigene Attraktivität. Also hier werden Bedingungen aufgebaut, Bedingungen geprüft. Es wird hin und her geht's und er geht es dann durch. Also wir haben diesen Prozess. Sehr hohe Formatkonstanz. Also durchgängig klar gerahmte Q&A-Tour-Bühnen. Es ist immer klar, da sitzt einer, der ist offen für, der schweigt auch mal, bis jemand mutig genug ist, ans Mikrofon zu gehen, um dann vor allem einfach eine Frage zu stellen oder einen Vorwurf zu machen, wie auch immer. Aber Kirk bietet diese Bühne. Das heißt, es gibt eine Mikroorganisation, obwohl es alles unter totaler Spontanität abläuft. Die Redezeiten sind wirklich knallhart verteilt und Charlie Kirk kann in einer halben Stunde noch Witze über dich machen, wo du gar keine Chance mehr hast noch in dieses Gespräch einzugreifen. Wir haben also diese Person auf der einen Seite, die mit ganz hoher Variationslosigkeit ein inhaltliches Programm durchprügeln kann, während die Zuschauerbindung eigentlich über diese ständige Überraschung wer dreht jetzt ans Mikrofon aufrechterhalten wird. Charlie Kirk im Monolog würde das ja vielleicht gar nicht schaffen, sondern er braucht genau diese Konfrontation, die da immer wieder simuliert wird, nur um einen roten Faden durchzuziehen, bei dem ihm eigentlich ziemlich egal sein kann, wer da so steht. Also solche Phänomene. Er ist der Gastgeber, er ist der Hauptredner. Er ist der Instanz der abschließenden Bewertung, schreibt Sebastian. Also wirklich sehr gut, das genau so dann mal aufzuschlüsseln. Wir haben hier eine ganz hohe Asymmetrie und sehr ungleich verteilte Eingriffsrechte in diese inhaltlichen Dispute, die da als angeblich so offen und die die Chance geben usw. ablaufen. Inhaltlich bedeutet das natürlich dann einiges. Wir haben ganz enge Deutungskorridore. Also Menschen sind dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr überrascht, wenn es um Abtreibung, Gender, Grenzen, Religion geht. Sie wollen nur immer wieder wissen, wie Charlie Kirk jetzt herausgefordert wird. Und eigentlich wird es ja immer enttäuscht, weil ihm ja ziemlich egal, dass es wieder agiert wird. Er prügelt halt einfach seine Linie durch und dann achtet man nur auf diese Pointen und so. Also wir haben eine sehr asymmetrische Frame-Verteilung. Wir haben hier Common-Sense-Unterstellungen, die er sich genau angeschaut hat. Also wirklich sehr gut. Ich wünschte mir, dass einige junge Leute in den Universitäten das machen, was eben Professoren nicht können, außer Stefan Kühl, sich das genau anschauen. Genau anschauen, was da passiert und es einfach aufschreiben, sodass es bei dem Leser wie mir zu einer kurzen Reflektion von diesen Sachen kommt. Und eigentlich müsste man das jetzt allen, die selber betriebsblind in ihren 50 Jahre alten Formaten drinhängen, also quasi allen ARD aktuell Leuten, die da so, ach, ich bin heute mit dem Kommentar dran, ja, hat es die Schalte gerade ergeben? Ja, ja, erzählen wir es doch immer Schalte, wo wir klären, was heute Abend kommentiert wird. Aber nur 90 Sekunden, ne? Also, mit denen müsste man das alles mal vorlegen, was so alles möglich ist, ja, wie man das auch sonst noch machen kann. Ja, inhaltlich sehr stark geht das so durch, wie diese biblischen Verweise und moralischen Intuitionen da immer wieder reingebracht werden, um sozusagen eine Konstanz herzustellen und dann auch das Publikum immer wieder über die angebliche Variantenreichtum abzuholen, die dann aber immer wieder dasselbe Vorgesetz bekommen. Also wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Und dann kommt am Ende auf das Performative, auf den Paratext, der da mitläuft, der eben wie institutionell aussieht. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, weil es einer Sehgewohnheit entspricht. Und jetzt ist es halt wirklich wichtig zu verstehen. Drei Millionen Leute oder sagen wir mal acht Millionen Leute gucken die Tagesschau. So. Es sind 80 bis 1000 Leute, keine Ahnung, wie viele verantwortlich dafür, dass die Tagesschau so aussieht, wie sie aussieht. Die haben allerdings große Angst davor, ihr Publikum zu verschrecken. Also unterstellen sie dem Publikum, dass es nicht überrascht werden will, weshalb die Tagesschau immer noch so aussieht, wie vor 80 Jahren. Und das ist ein Problem. Denn der Diskurs läuft ja nicht mehr in der Tagesschau. In der Tagesschau guckt sich eine ältere Frau an, ob die Welt morgen noch da ist. Und dann kriegt sie die Nachricht, Klimawandel ist nur bei den Eisbären. Oder Krieg ist nur da, wo Wüste ist. Hier ist ja keine Wüste. So. Und das sind Probleme. Jetzt würde ich sagen, so wie man hier mit diesem neuen Phänomen umgeht. Also Sebastian Huber guckt sich Charlie Kirk an. Finde ich, sollte man auch mal eine Hausarbeit über die Tagesschau schreiben. Mit genau dieser Sensibilität. Was passiert da eigentlich? Warum hält er da eine 15 Minuten Biologik? Warum ändert sich das Thema immer nach welchen Gesichtspunkten eigentlich und so? Und ich glaube, hier liegt einiges noch an Auftrag, den man mal so nachgehen könnte. Er geht es natürlich dann eng an seinem Fall. Also er ist sehr fallzentrierter Charlie Kirk. Geht dann weiter, wie das dann auch politisch genutzt wurde. Trump und JD Vans schon, bevor überhaupt irgendwer vom FBI da mal eine Konsequenz ziehen konnte, schon saß JD Vans schon im Sessel von Charlie Kirk, hat die nächste Show moderiert und gemeint, jetzt mal alle anschwärzen, die hier irgendwas sagen und so. Also die Ausbeutung dieser neuen Institutionalisierung, so sehr sie auf Fake-Discourse basiert, da ist ja ein Fullswing. Das ist ja wirklich gesellschaftsprägend. Und von daher würde ich sagen, das ist sehr vorbildhaft, auch vor allem, dass er diese Arbeit jetzt einfach auf seiner Webseite zur Verfügung steht. Und seine finale Lehre hier, die Hegemonie entsteht durch Vorsprung im Erzählformat, nicht durch bessere Argumentation oder interessanter Inhalt oder irgend sowas. Das bedeutet, Marshall McLuhan, the medium is the message, ist absolut richtig. Plus, jetzt ist das Medium auch noch immer im Wandel die ganze Zeit. Und das muss man jetzt im Blick haben. Und das ist sehr gut, also sehr auf den Punkt hier. Und vorbildhaft. Da kann man jetzt alle auf discourssebi.de gehen. Und jeder kann sich die Arbeit runterladen. Und denke ich, ich führe das auch mal fort, so in diesem Maße. Denn ich muss ja jetzt auch eine Bachelorarbeit schreiben, oder was auch immer.
Zum Schluss noch Musik, diesmal keine klassische Musik, sondern Jazz. Ich habe mir eine CD gekauft, die den Titel Memento trägt. Bei ECM ist sie erschienen von Marilyn Crispell und Anders Jormin. Marilyn Crispell ist Pianistin, Anders Jormin ist Kontrabassist. Und du merkst, das ist eine ungewöhnliche Kombination. Klavier, Kontrabass, die beiden nur zusammen machen das unter sich Austreten gemeinsam in einen Dialog, der überrascht schon deshalb, weil man selten einen Kontrabass in solch hohen Registern hört. Mitunter denkt man, wird da eine Geige zum Einsatz gebracht. Aber nein, es ist ein Kontrabass. Es gibt ein Stück, das heißt Beach at New Quay. Dort hört man den Kontrabass sogar so, als würden Möwen schreien. Es ist sicherlich experimentell, was die beiden hier vollführen. Dieser Dialog hat mitunter etwas, ja, ich will nicht meditatives sagen, weil das gleich sowas Spirituelles bekommt, aber etwas doch sehr beruhigendes, fein, sessiliertes, etwas, was einen vielleicht ein bisschen geruhsamer werden lässt.
Ja, aber das ist doch meditativ genau richtig.
Das einen öffnet hin zu was auch immer. Kontemplation heißt auch ein Stück for the Children heißt das erste Werk. Es ist also für Leute, die Jazz mögen, beziehungsweise sich für Jets vielleicht bislang noch nicht begeistern, könnten jetzt aber sagen, na, so eine interessante Kombination, so ein Dialog, den werde ich mir jetzt mal anhören. Was man also nicht hier erwarten kann, ist so easy listening, also dass man einfach sagt, man hat jetzt Fahrstuhlmusik hier oder sowas, sondern was jetzt hier wichtig ist, dass man wirklich nur die ganz kleinen Nuancen wahrnimmt. Das ist ein sehr zurückgenommenes Spiel von beiden ist. Oftmals stehen Töne da und bekommen dann eine kleine Erwiderung von jeweils anderen Instrument für sehr geruhsame Abende oder um geruhsam zu werden. Ich empfehle Memento von Marilyn Crispell und Anders Jormin.
Zwei Fragen dazu.
Ja.
Kann man ein Bass so spielen, dass man denkt, das ist eine Geige und nicht zumindest ein Cello?
Ich habe vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es geht wirklich sehr hoch und es wird ganz zart gehaucht. Es ist schon sehr interessant, welche Töne daraus produziert werden. Das geht nicht nur so, sondern wir hören auch ganz normal den Kontrabass, so wie wir uns ihn jetzt erst einmal vorstellen.
Die zweite Frage ist, wenn man Bassist ist, muss man sein Ding selber mitschleppen die ganze Zeit. Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Beim Klavier nicht?
Nein.
Also die sind auf Tour und sie ist dann an immer anderen Klavieren und er spielt auf seinem immer gleichen Kontrabass.
Die beiden, das jetzt genau handhaben, weiß ich nicht. Also der Kontrabassist nimmt sein Instrument mit und das ist ja schon beim Cello schwierig. Also beim Cello ist es ja schon so, dass wenn du dann ein Taxi benötigst, musst du schon ein größeres vielleicht haben, damit das irgendwie funktioniert. Mit dem Kontrabass wird es noch ein bisschen komplizierter. Sicherlich haben die ihre speziellen Instrumente, die sie gerne auch mitnehmen wollen. Ja, das Reisen ist damit heikel. Bei den Pianisten ist es so, dass sie in der Regel nicht mit Klavier reißen. Es gab mal eine Zeit lang, dass Glenn Gould ein Klavier mitnehmen wollte. Es gibt manche Pianisten, die schon mal so Marotten haben. Irgendwann war es dann bei Glenn Gould aber immerhin noch der Klavierstuhl, der immer wieder neu zusammengeflickt werden musste. Aber in der Regel ist es so, dass ein Pianist an den Ort kommt. Also wir reden jetzt hier von denen, die in den großen Häusern spielen. Und dann haben sie eine Auswahl an Flügeln.
Eine Auswahl?
Ja, das heißt sie gehen zum Beispiel in die Kölner Philharmonie, haben dort am Abend ihr Konzert. Dann steht dort eine Auswahl von Flügeln bereit. Die können sie dann testen. Und dann kommt ein Klavierstimmer, der dann auch dieses Klavier mit ihnen einrichtet. Bei Sokolow sollen das viele Stunden sein, bis das so eingerichtet ist. Was auch bedeutet, dass in den Pausen meist der Stimmer nochmal kommt und nochmal korrigiert. Aber das ist tatsächlich so, dass sie sich an diese Instrumente gewöhnen müssen. Allerdings gibt es ja ein Standard in den meisten Häusern. Und bei den meisten Pianisten ist es so, dass sie Steinway spielen, also den Konzertflügel, diesen D-Flügel in der Regel. Das heißt, sie kennen schon an sich das Instrument und legen, glaube ich, auch schon Wert darauf, dass es dann das ist, dass sie nicht mal an einem anderen sehr guten Flügel spielen. Da gibt es unterschiedliche Marotten. Aber bei den Leuten, die jetzt so groß auf Tournee gehen, durch Mehrzeughallen, die nehmen natürlich auch den Flügel mit oder so eine kleinere Version davon.
Wurde ja auch alles mal elektrifiziert.
Geht nicht. Also brauchen wir gar nicht darüber zu diskutieren. Wollen wir gar nicht darüber diskutieren. Wir wollen nur zum Schluss noch hinweisen, dass es den Sommersalon gibt im August und zwar am 22.
Am 22. August.
Ja, es gibt noch Karten. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr kommt. Vielleicht auch Leute mitbringt, die den Salon so noch nicht kennen. Wir zwei werden uns also wieder wichtigen Themen widmen. Vielleicht beantworten wir auch ein paar Publikumsfragen. Mal sehen. Ja, können wir. Wir schauen. Wir bringen auf jeden Fall unsere Themen mit. Sind also dort zu erleben, sind dann auch schon früher da. Es bietet sich an. Man ist auch danach direkt im Zentrum des Geschehens. Das heißt, man kann da überall gut was trinken gehen. Man kann sich eine gute Zeit in Frankfurt machen. Also wir freuen uns, wenn ihr kommt. Und wir freuen uns auch, wenn ihr den Salon und überhaupt den Neuen Zwanziger Podcasts weiterempfehlt. Oder noch schöner, wenn ihr den Salon sogar verschenkt. Das ist allerdings nun möglich bei Steady. Dort kann man den Salon für ein Jahr jemandem verschenken. Vielleicht jemand, der wissen will, wie das mit der Kunstfreiheit oder so ist. Dann bietet sich das an. Dann hat man natürlich auch Zugang zu den alten Salons. Ja, jetzt erstmal einen schönen Monat und dann hören wir uns. Sind gespannt, was dann aus der FDP geworden ist.
Ja, du meinst aus Wolfgang Kupicki. Die FDP ist ja schon vorbei. Ciao, ciao.
Bis dann!